Y
VIA VIDEO CONFERENCING AS PART
OF THIS HEARING MIKE OF THE
MEMBERS PARTICIPATING ROOM WILL
BE SET YOU. THIS OF A LIMB.
DISSIPATING REMOTELY BENITA ON
MUTE YOUR MICROPHONE EACH TIME
YOU WISH TO SPEAK FOR MEMBERS
AND WITNESSES PARTICIPATING IN
PERSON I ENCOURAGE YOU TO WEAR
YOUR MASK WHEN YOU WERE NOT
SPEAKING DR MONEY HERE REST IN
THE OF THE TENDING PHYSICIANS
COVID NINETEEN GUIDELINES THE
USE OF FACE COVERINGS MEANT FOR
OTHER. THE WHERE IT ONLY. IT'S
NOT HAVE SYMPTOMS I BY WEARING
ON ME AS WELL WE ARE NOT
SPEAKING EACH OF US IS PLAYING
A VITAL ROLE IN PROTECTING ALL
MEMBERS AND STAFF WHO ARE IN
ATTENDANCE AS WELL AS A LEAVE.
OF IMAGE SINCE NINETEEN RIGHT
THIS WILL BE TESTIFYING BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE TODAY. DO THEY
ANTICIPATE THE LENGTH OF THIS
HEARING THE COMMITTEE WILL TAKE
A FIFTEEN MINUTE RECESS AT ONE
THIRTY PM TO PROVIDE WITNESSES
A RESTROOM BREAK. AND FINALLY
DOCUMENTS FOR THE RECORD CAN BE
SENT TO BENJAMIN. TABLE OR AT
THE EMAIL ADDRESS PROVIDED TO
STATE. ALL DOCUMENTS WILL BE
PUT INTO THE RECORD. AT THE
CONCLUSION OF HEARING. AND NOW
I RECKON I TO MYSELF FOR FIVE
MINUTES TO OF FOR BEING STATE.
TODAY GRETCHEN COMMITTEE
CONTINUE AS SIMPLE WORK OVER.
INSPIRATIONS RESPONSE TO THE
COVID NINETEEN PANDEMIC IS
DIFFICULT TO OVERSTATE THIS
DISEASE'S DEVASTATING IMPACT
TODAY MORE THAN TWENTY TWO
POINT TWO MILLION AMERICANS
HAVE CONTRACTED COVID NINETEEN
AND TRAGICALLY MORE THAN A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THOUSAND
HAVE DIED. SAME TIME OPEN FORTY
FIVE MILLION IS HAVE FILED FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT OVER THE LAST
THREE MONTHS COVID NINETEEN HAS
WRECKED HAVOC ON THIS COUNTRY'S
PHYSICAL MENTAL AND ECONOMIC
WELL BEING. AND THE PANDEMIC
HAS BEEN ESPECIALLY BRUTAL TO
PEOPLE OF COLOR AND LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES THOUSANDS OF
FAMILIES CAN TELL STORIES TO
LOSE A- WITHOUT BEING ALLOWED
TO VISIT THEM IN THEIR FIGHT.
THE SOCIAL I SO THOUGHT BY C.
AS IN LONG TERM CARE FACILITIES
MILLIONS MORE COULD TELL US
ABOUT LOSING THEIR JOBS ARE
BEING. MOBILISED ON TOP OF THE
DEVASTATION OF THESE COMMITTEE.
THE FACT THAT IT HAD NOT BEEN
FOR A- IN SPONSORS FROM THE
TRUMP IT. AND IN MY- ON PUT
LUCAS ASIAN. CUP DONE. IT GAVE
TO DESTROY IMPACT OF NINETEEN.
WE MUST LEARN FROM AND- THE
MYSTERY MR OF THE PREPARED TO
CALM THIS DISEASE AS MORE OUT
BROOKS. THE SUMMER. POTENTIAL
WAVE COMES IN THE FALL. THE
TESTING HAS BEEN A PROBLEM
SINCE THE BEGINNING. AND WHILE
IT'S IMPROVED WE'RE STILL FOR
FAR SHORT OF NINE HUNDRED. AND
DAILY TEST. EX TO BELIEVE IT.
ALSO BY THE TREES AND REFUSAL
TO DO IMPLEMENT AND THAT
TESTING AND CONS RACE STREET G.
CANNOT CONTINUE I THINK WE NEED
FEDERAL PUBLIC HEALTH EXPERTS
TO TAKE UP LEADERSHIP. AND THIS
ADMINISTRATION IS FAILING TO
ALLOW THAT. CALLED TO BE OUR
FIRST CONSIDERATION TO
ACCELERATE RESEARCH INTO A
VACCINE AND TREATMENTS FOR
COVID NINETEEN WE ALL WANT TO
VACCINE TO BE DEVELOPED AS SOON
AS POSSIBLE IF BEFORE TAX
TREATMENT IS JUST. ARE PART AT
BIRTH MUSH INSURE THAT IT IS.
AN ACCESSIBLE. SOURCE ATTEMPT
TO THE ARREST BY CHAIN WITH. ON
IT IS OF VIALS NEEDED SYRINGE
ANOTHER NECESSARY TO ADMINISTER
A VACCINE WE ALSO NEED TO
IMPROVE TESTING SUPPLIES IN OUR
SUPPLY PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT OR PPE P. P.
FOREFRONT WORKERS ANOTHER
THROUGHOUT THE ECONOMY. THE
WALL SUPPLIES PEOPLE HE HAS
IMPROVED. PRESERVE TOLD US THAT
WE'RE FAR FOR WHERE WE NEED TO
BE. FORTUNATELY LAST MONTH THE
HOW PASSED THOSE ACT WHICH FOR
A PUBLIC AGENTS WITH THE
MANDATE. THE RESEARCH TO ENSURE
WE'RE PREPARED GOING FOR. A
RECALL IS THAT A CHEST FINALLY
FELT GUILTY IN CONTACT RACE
PLANNED AND PROVIDE SEVENTY
BILLION TO CARRY IT OUT. WHAT
HOUR TO STRENGTHEN TWO T.
BATTLES. FILE IN TO INCREASE
RESEARCH DEVELOP AND
MANUFACTURE. AND IN THAT ALL
AMERICANS WILL BE ABLE TO
RECEIVE FREE COVERAGE OF
TREATMENT DRUGS AND EVENTUAL
BACKS NO QUESTIONING THIS
LEGISLATION IS NEEDED TODAY
SENATE IS FILLED. TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IS THREATENED TO
VETO IT WITHOUT PUTTING FORWARD
ANY DIVISION OF THEIR OWN.
PRESIDENT TRUMP REFUSES TO EVEN
ACKNOWLEDGE THE CHALLENGE WE
FACE AND THE DIFFICULT WORK
THAT MUST BE DONE TO PREVENT
FURTHER DESTRUCTION JUST THIS
WEEKEND AS OUTBREAKS FLARED UP
ON PUBLIC HEALTH LEADERS
CONTINUE TO URGE SOCIAL
DISTANCING THE PRESS. ARKANSAS
RISK IT. HOLDING A BLUE RALLY
IN OKLAHOMA NOT THE RALLY HE
SUGGESTED THAT IS STATE OF SLOW
DOWN TESTING TO MASK THE TRUE
LEVEL OF AFFECTION AS THE
COUNTRY. IN FACT THIS EVENING
TO PRESS. WASN'T KIDDING. WHEN
HE MADE THOSE COMMENTS AND I
THINK. EX RECKLESS BEFORE EIGHT
CONTINUOUS THE SERVICE PATTERN
OF IGNORE BISA VISIT PUBLIC
HEALTH EXPERTS EX. IT ALSO
SENDS A HORRIBLE MESSAGE JUST
ERIC IS THAT THEY TO CAKE NOR
PUBLIC TELL THAT BIRDS. AS THIS
JUSTICE CONTINUES TO HARM OUR
COUNTRY IS EXTREME DANGEROUS
PRESIDENT. IN OTHER. GRETCHEN
NEED. HOT HOT SPOTS IN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S UNWILLINGNESS
TO FACE THESE HARD TRUTHS I
THINK IT'S GONNA LEAD TO MORE.
AND MORE THE SUFFERING SO. I'M
THAT WE ARE NATION PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICIALS WITH US TODAY
THANK YOU ALL FOR COMING I'VE
BEEN MIRED- YOUR ROLE AND WHAT
YOU'VE DONE OVER THE LAST FEW
MONTHS- I KNOW I THINK YOU CAN
HELP US ANSWER QUESTIONS ABOUT
WHAT HAS GONE WRONG WITH. IT
PROVING. S. CAN BE. OVER THE
FORTY TESTIMONY AND THAT CAN I.
KING MEMBER FOR FIVE MINUTES
FOR AN OPENING STATEMENT.
LANCASTER BUT BEFORE I BEGIN I
HAVE A PARLIAMENTARY ENQUIRING
YES. MR CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE ROLL
NINETY ONE SAYS THAT A FULL
COMMITTEE HEARINGS THE CHAIRMAN
AND RANKING MINORITY MEMBER
SHALL BE LIMITED TO FIVE
MINUTES EACH FOR AN OPENING
STATEMENT ON MAY DESIGNATE
OTHER NUMBERS TO GIVE A-
STATEMENT OF. MORE THAN FIVE
MINUTES INCREASE THIS ROLE AS A
DOCTOR BURGESS GIVEN- OPENING
STATEMENT. AND I RAISED IT
BECAUSE I KNOW. STOP AT TIMES-
ONLY THE CHAIRMAN AND RANKING
MEMBER HAVE- GIVING OPENING
STATEMENTS. AT OTHER TIMES- WE
HAVE. ALLOWED THE MINORITY YOU
HAVE I BELIEVE AS WELL TO A
DESIGNATED OTHER MEMBER FOR
FIVE MINUTES GIVEN THE
IMPORTANCE OF. HEARING I WOULD
HOPE THAT WE COULD. WHERE THE
SUBCOMMITTEE CHAIRMAN AND
RANKERS COULD- ALSO COMMENT-
AND I WONDER IF YOU WOULD BE
WILLING TO ALLOW THAT. PRE K.
YOUR COMMENTS- MR WALTON BUT-
THE ANSWER IS NO I MEAN FIRST
LET ME REMIND MEMBERS THAT
PURSUANT TO THE RULES. WRITTEN
OPENING STATEMENTS WILL BE MADE.
A PART OF THE RECORD BUT
ACCORDING TO OUR RULES ALL THE
FULL COMMITTEE CHAIR AND
RANKING MEMBER MUST FOR. FIVE
MINS. OKAY HEARING YOU KNOW.
HAVE THESE BIG. AND ADDITION OF
THE EDGING. TO TRY TO DO ALL
THE HEARING. AT THE
SUBCOMMITTEE LEVEL BUT THE
PROBLEM WITH DOING THAT TODAY
IS THAT I THOUGHT THIS WAS HIM
ENOUGH FOR A FULL COMMITTEE
HERE A PLUS. THESE WITNESSES
ARE GOING TO BE TESTED IN AREAS
THAT CROPS THE BOUNDARY VERY
BECAUSE COMMITTEE SO. IF WE LET
THE HOUSE SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THE RANKING MEMBERS OF ALL THE
SUBCOMMITTEES INCLUDING- AND I
ON THIS IS GOING TO DRAG THINGS
ON TOO LONG SO I DECIDED THAT
YOU KNOW WE WOULD JUST HAVE IT
FOR THE FULL COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AND YOU KNOW I POINT OUT I
DON'T WANT TO I CAN GIVE YOU
ALL THE RECORD ABOUT HOW. YOU
WOULD THERE WHEN WE CANCEL
HEARINGS WHICH WE HAD LIMITED.
ARE THE TO FOR COMMITTEE MAY
AND I KNOW YOU'RE SAYING WE
HAVE. THAT WE HAVE TO DO IT
YOU'RE JUST ASKING THAT WE DO
BUT GIVEN THE FACT THAT. I HAVE
TO OPEN ALL THE SUB. AND WE'D
BE HERE ANOTHER HOUR I THINK
ADDRESS I'VE DECIDED. WITH THE
TWO OF US CHURCH RECLAIMING.
MIGHT THIS I GUESS I RECLAIM
TIME ON A PARLIAMENTARY INQUIRY
BUT- I KNOW IN THE PAST WEEK WE
WOULD EVEN BE WILLING TO DIVIDE
THAT SIMPLE FIVE MINS. A MONTH-
MR GOT FOR. PURCHASE BRIDGES ON
THE YOU COULD DO THIS ON THE
OUTSIDE ON TO TEN. THAT'S I'D-
WANT TO USE YOUR TIME THEN NO I
WOULD YOU. US ALLOWED FOR UNDER
OUR RULES MISSIONAL. TO EACH
EACH IT WOULD HAVE. TOTAL
BECAUSE THIS IS A. ERIC IS MY
POINT. YOU JUST HAVE.
SUBCOMMITTEE CHAIR OTHER THAN
THAT AND NOBODY'S FOR TO DO
THAT AT THE POINT SO LET'S JUST
LEAVE IT THE WAY IT IS AND YOU
USE YOUR FIVE AS CHAIRMAN
PARLIAMENTARY WORK YES WHAT
PART OF ROOM. B. THE- DOES NOT
GIVES IT A RANKING MEMBER OF
THE RANKING MINORITY MEMBER
AFTER. OF THE MEMBER TO GIVE AN
OPENING BUT NOT MORE THAN ON
AVERAGE. BUILT INTO THE-
THERE'S A DECENT RANKING MEMBER
IF HE CHOOSES THE RANKING
MINORITY MEMBER IF HE CHOOSES
TO DO SO. JEFFERSON'S MANUAL A
CLEARLY AND I DIDN'T BRING MY
COPY DOWN WITH ME TODAY BUT THE
RULES ARE DESIGNED TO PROTECT
THE RIGHT OF THE MAIN PARTY
BECAUSE GEORGE CAN DO WHATEVER
IT WANTS TO ONCE THE RULES THAT.
TO BEGIN OF THIS GROUP WILL
SESSION. READ THE FACT THAT THE
MINORITY RANKING MEMBER NOT
ONLY GETS HIS FIVE MINUTES FOR
HER FIVE MINUTES BUT THE DEAD A
DESIGNATED REMEMBER GIVEN TO
GET STATEMENTS. SO WHILE WE
HAVE WAVE THAT IN THE- I'LL BE.
IN HERE ACTUALLY GIVES THAT
DECISION TO THE CHAIR AND WHILE
WE'RE ALL FRIENDS AND I KNOW
YOU DO. YOU DO THE BEST YOU CAN
MISTER CHAIRMAN NOT. SIZING
PERSONAL I'M JUST SAYING THE
RULES ARE PRETTY CLEAR. THAT
THE RANKING MINORITY MEMBER
GETS TO DESIGNATE SOMEBODY. AND
IT'S- NOT THE WAY I READ IT
ACCORDING TO THE RULES ONLY THE
FULL COMMITTEE CHAIR AT MAKING
MEMBER MUST BE PROVIDED THE
FIVE MINUTES ON OPENING
STATEMENT AT A FULL COMMITTEE
HEARING. L. S. WITH THE CHAIR.
I THIS INTERPRETATION IS NOT
UNIQUE TO MY TERM AS CHAIRMAN
AT THE FIRST FULL COMMITTEE
HEARING DURING THE RANKING
MEMBERS TERMS CHAIRMAN OF THE
FULL COMMITTEE ON OCTOBER
TWENTY FIFTH TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN HEARING ENTITLED
FEDERAL TO COMBAT THE OPIOID
CRISIS THEN CHAIRMAN WALDEN
ANNOUNCED AT THE CONCLUSION
OPENING STAY. NOW THIS IS. THE
CHAIR. WE GIVE STATE. PARK IN.
SO NOW WE GO TO I WILL THIS AND
THEN IN THE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
KIND WEAKENED THIS CRACK OF
ONLY PUT. THE FULL COMMITTEE
CHAIR AND RANKING MEMBER WAS
FIVE MINUTES EACH FOR OPENING
STATEMENTS OF ME HERE HIS ABOUT
THE MASS ME SEN MONEY SET TWO
THOUSAND NINE. COMMITTEE
AMERICA MY- WHITE TWO NINETEEN
FULL COMMITTEE HEARING ENTITLED
MEMBER DAY ONLY THE FULL
COMMITTEE CHAIR WERE PROVIDED
TIME FOR AN OPENING STATEMENT
SO I'M JUST TEARING SAME THE
SENATE THAT EXIST UNDER MR
WALLS CHAIRMANSHIP AT MINE AND
HIS COULD SESSION- BUT IT'S- DO.
B. ON THE FIVE MINUTES FOR EACH
OF THE FOLK. IS IT BECAUSE THE
TIME LIMIT SEN I MEAN I GUESS
NOW WE'RE WASTING TIME BUT I
MEAN LOOK I DON'T WANT TO TELL
YOU WHAT TO DO BUT I'M- THIS IS.
ON THAT. IN LEADS I RATHER
PROCEEDING HERE FOR EVERYBODY.
ALL RIGHT YOU RECOGNIZE ME MR
WALDEN PROVISION HEREIN I'M I'M
FRUSTRATED BY THAT I KNOW-
MEMBERS ON BOTH SIDES AND BEEN
IN BACK TO TWENTY ELEVEN TWENTY
THIRTEEN- ON RECORD THIS AND
HAVE OTHERS PARTICIPATE. I'M
WANT TO. MILD STATEMENT AT THIS
POINT. I WANT TO THANK OUR
DISTINGUISHED PANEL OF
WITNESSES WHO ARE STILL WORKING
AROUND THE CLOCK TO UNDERSTAND
THIS DEADLY VIRUSES BELLA.
MEDICINES TO. ANAVEX AND- COVID
NINETEEN LAID BARE HELP ALL WE
ARE AND HOW MUCH MORE WE NEED
TO DO AS A GOV. THE WORK BY
COLLEAGUES AT THE ISSUANCE. TO
MODERNIZE THE PANDEMIC ALL
HAZARDS PREPAREDNESS ACT RIGHT
KNOWLEDGE THE INCREDIBLE
EFFORTS OF RED UP INTO AND
DIANE TO GET WHO WROTE THE
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY CURES
LEGISLATION WITH ALL OF THE-
NINE. WORLD TSUNAMI IN DEBT. ON
THE DISK AT THIS REP ARE
DISTINGUISHED ARE LIKE CO
CAPTAINS OF AMERICA'S RESCUE
PLANE A PLANE WE ARE BUILDING
WHILE WE FLY CONGRESS SUPPORTED
THOSE EFFORTS WITH HISTORIC
LEVELS OR INCREASE. FLEXIBILITY
PLAY ON PRESIDENT TRUMP UP
FLIGHTS FROM. AND THEN EUROPE
HE TIGHTENED OUR PURSES
STABBING SUPER TASK FORCE TO
COORDINATE EFFORTS IN INVOKE
EXECUTIVE AUTHORITY SELDOM USE
IT IN TIME A MEMBER. BRENT
CRUDE STAFFORD ACT AND THE
EXPERT. PART OF POWER OF
AMERICA IN A VACATION THROUGH
PRAGUE LIKE ON. WARP SPEED
DURING THIS UNPRECEDENTED
RESPONSE THE ADMINISTRATION AT
OPERATE WITH LIMITED OFTEN
CONFLICTING DAY. EVEN WITH CDC
GUIDANCE IN HAND SOME GET CHOSE
TO IGNORE THAT CAPTAINS AND
THEY ACTUALLY FOR SICK NURSING
HOME AND BACK TO THE NURSING
HOMES. THAT STATE AND THAT.
MEDIA BACKWARD LOOK WITH UNFAIR
IT A TWENTY TWENTY HIDING
ATTACK YOU AND THE MEN AND
WOMEN TO WORK ALONG SIDE OF
EACH OF YOU I COMMEND OUR IS
THE DAY KEEPING FOCUS ON THE
CHALLENGE IS AT HAND AND FOR
EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO BEAT
THIS FALL. WE GET PAST THIS
BEAST WHICH DIDN'T EVEN HAVE A
NAME BACK THEN. WE QUICKLY WENT
FROM KNOWING ABOUT THIS VIRUS
TO CREATING A TEST FOR IT. AND
TESTING MORE THAN TWENTY FIVE
MILLION SAMPLES WITH RECENT
AVERAGES MORE THAN FIVE
HUNDRED. TESTS TODAY WE ALL
KNOW THERE'S MORE TO BE DONE.
WHAT IS THE THING WHICH ADVISER
WHO CAME. WHO BECAME A SELF
PROCLAIMED SWAB GUY QUOTE ON
QUOTE BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
AMERICA NEEDED. WE DISCOVERED
THERE WERE ONLY TWO NASAL AND
THE FACTORS IN THE WORLD ONE IN
MAINE AND ONE IN ITALY IN THE
SENATE VOTE D. A. YOUR- TO MAKE.
WE NEEDED AND THEN I FUNDS MADE
AVAILABLE THROUGH K. MEDICALLY
AND FOR. IN A NEW FOR IN MAY.
MEANWHILE THE PRESIDENT
LAUNCHED PROJECT- BRIDGE TO FLY
MILITARY PLANES TO ITALY TO
PICK UP SWAPS INTO SEARCH THE
GLOBE FOR OTHER SUPPLIES THAT
WE FOUND IN. IT'S A YEAR STATE.
HELP HUNDRED AND ONE THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY SIX.
ABROAD GET BACK HOW OFTEN ON
GOVERNMENT PLANES WITH.
TRANSPORTATION DOWN. WILL
INCREASE OF THOSE IN THE FALL
ONE COUPLE LUCY IS I AT TEAM.
EVERY ASPECT OF THIS BASES I'D
RECOMMEND IT. BARBER GOING.
YEAH IT IN A SECOND OF IN FACT
IS CALLED GET HIM. RISK HAS HAD
ALL PUBLIC. ON PEOPLE'S LIVES.
ERIC IS A- WE WILL WE THE
BREAKING. ON JUSTIN AND
SURVEILLANCE THREE WEEKS AGO
PREPARING TO RECOMMEND ON
THERAPY AND VACCINES VERY SOON.
LESS THAN SIX MONTHS UNITED
STATES HAS CONDUCTED MILLIONS
OF TAPS MANUFACTURED MEDICAL
EQUIPMENT IN CAR FACTORIES USE
THREE D. PRINTERS TO MAKE
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
DEVELOP MULTIPLE VACCINE
CANDIDATES ON ISSUES OF MORE
THAN A HUNDRED MEDICAL DEVICES
DRUGS FOR EMERGENCY USE. NO NO
ATTEND BENEFIT. HI ALL AT
UNPRECEDENTED SPEEDS THESE
INNOVATIONS HAVE THE ABILITY TO
SERVE US WELL AND FAR BEYOND
THIS PANDEMIC WE HAVE SEEN
REMARKABLE COORDINATION
FLEXIBILITY AND COOPERATION
BETWEEN THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH
PRIVATE SECTOR FAITH GROUPS
VOLUNTEERS AND LAWMAKERS ERIC
IS STRONG WHEN WE WORK TOGETHER
TO ACHIEVE COMMON GOALS. WE'RE
CONSTANTLY LEARNING HOW TO
IMPROVE OUR PREPAREDNESS WE
MUST ADJUST OUR RESPONSE BASED
OFF OF FACTS AT HAND AND FOCUS
ON HOW TO BEST MOVE FORWARD WE
MUST UNITE IN A COMMON FIGHT
AGAINST THIS VIRUS PROMOTE.
BASED IN WORLD WAR TWO TO DO
WHATEVER IT TOOK. TODAY OUR
DISTINGUISHED PANELISTS OF
MOBILEYE'S AMERICA'S FINEST
STOP THIS LOADED QUESTIONS AND
ENTREPRENEURS TO EAT THIS
DEADLY MICROSCOPIC ENEMY. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP THREE
YEARS OF PUBLIC SERVICE AND FOR
YOUR DEDICATION THIS LIFESAVING
MISSION. MISTER CHAIRMAN I
YIELD BACK THE BALANCE TIME.
THANK YOU I THANK THE- RANKING
MEMBER AND I'D LIKE TO NOW
INTRODUCE OUR WITNESSES FOR
TODAY'S HEARING- I KEEP CALM
THE WHITE HOUSE THE TASKFORCE
ON CORONAVIRUS BUT I DON'T
ACTUALLY KNOW WHAT THE THAT
STILL. DISTANCING WHETHER
YOU'RE ALL MEMBERS OF IT MORE.
OF SO FIRST WE HAVE DR ROBERT
REDFIELD THE DIRECTOR OF THE
CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL AND
PREVENTION. WE HAVE DOCTOR
ANTHONY FAUCI DIRECTOR OF THE
NATIONAL INSTITUTE OF ALLERGY
THIS TIME THE CHAIR IS GOING TO
RECOGNIZE EACH WITNESS FOR FIVE
MINUTES TO PROVIDE THEIR
OPENING STATEMENT BEFORE WE
BEGIN LIKE SPLAINE THE LIGHTING
SYSTEM. IN FRONT OF YOU THERE
IS A LOT LIKE WILL INITIALLY BE
GREETED THE START OF YOUR
OPENING STATEMENT THE LIGHT
WILL TURN YELLOW WHEN YOU AND
THE CHRISTIAN. I REP FOR
TESTIMONY THAT POINT. TURN RED
WHEN YOUR TIME EXPIRE AS YOU
PROBABLY KNOW THIS ALREADY BUT
I'LL MENTION IT AGAIN SO WE'RE
GONNA START WITH THE DIRECTION
OF RECOGNIZED FOR FIVE MINUTES
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING ON
RANKING BOLTON MEMBER THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO FIBER FOR YOU HM
CALLER. THE COVID NINETEEN
PANDEMIC IN AND THAT IT CENTER
WORLD. MIKE IS THE PUBLIC OF
PRICES ARE NATION AND OUR WORLD
CONFRONTED. IN A CENTURY
OVERALL CASE COUNTS ARE GOING
DOWN SEVERAL COMMUNITIES ARE
SEEN INCREASE CASES DRIVEN BY
MULTIPLE FACTORS. INCLUDING
INCREASED TESTING L. BREAKS AND
EVIDENCE OF COMMUNITY
TRANSMISSION. RIGHT NOW THE
MOST POWERFUL WEAPON AGAINST
THIS DISEASE OUR SOCIAL
DISTANCING ITS COVERINGS AND
TYPING IS THAT WILL HELP US CAN
TRANSMISSIONS. READILY
AVAILABLE TESTING FRANCE'S
TIMELY CONTACT TRACING TIMELY
ISOLATION OF KNOWN CASES AND
SELF QUARANTINE TO BREAK THE
CHAINS OF TRANSMISSION. ONCE
AGAIN I CALL ON THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE TO READ VIGILANTE ON OUR
COLLECTIVE OBLIGATION TO
PROTECT THOSE WHO MAY BE AT
RISK FOR SEVERE COMPLICATIONS
OF COVID NINETEEN DUE TO AGE OR
UNDERLYING MEDICAL CONDITIONS.
YOU MUST ON BUS ON THE COVID
NINETEEN RACIAL AND ETHNIC
GROUPS REPORTER IMPACTED CDC
CONTINUE PROVE ITS DATA
COLLECTION OF COMPREHENSIVE
DATA BEACH KATE RACE AND
ETHNICITY FROM OUR STATE LOCAL
TRIBAL TERRITORY PARTNERS.
REPORT POSSIBLE TRAVAIL IT'S
VERY OF INCREASING. RACE AND AT
THE FROM 30% NOT MORE THAN 2%
CD TO ALSO RECEIVE MORE DATA
FROM OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
PARTNERS. RECENT CDC STUDY
EXAMINED MORE THAN ONE POINT
THREE MILLION COVID NINETEEN
CASES. FELL THE MOST. ON HEALTH
CAN. WERE CARDIOVASCULAR. A B.
AND CAUGHT ONE DISEASE
HOSPITALIZATIONS WERE SICK I'M
SORRY. FOR THESE INDIVIDUALS
AND DEATH TWELVE TIMES I WAS
READING ON THESE COMPARED TO
THOSE WITHOUT. YOU SEE IT IN TO
FOR THE EQUITY SOUTH AUSTIN
SOCIAL TO TURN. ARE BEING
ADDRESSED THROUGH THE COVID
NINETEEN RESPONSE CDC CONTINUES
TO PROVIDE COMMUNITIES WITH
TECHNICAL EXPERTISE. TOOLS AND
INFORMATION TO CONFRONT THE
MARS CDC SCREEN ENDED MORE
FIFTEEN HUNDRED SPECIALIST
RESOURCING GUIDANCE DOCUMENTS
WOULD HAVE BEEN CONSULTED OR
THE ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
TIMES THE SEAT BELT SIGN. WE'VE
DEPLOYED OVER FIVE THOUSAND NO
RISK. WITH MORE THAN FORTY
RAPID RESPONSE TEAMS ON THE
GROUND THAT. THE LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS AND HEALTH
OFFICIALS WITH A DECENT
EPIDEMIOLOGY SURVEILLANCE
INSPECTION TROLL LABORATORY
SCIENCE COMMUNITY MITIGATION.
WE'RE NORMALLY GRATEFUL. THE
RESPONSE THAT'S THE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS THE FIRST
RESPONDERS THE CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE HERS WHO HAVE
SERVED AND SACRIFICED TOO MUCH.
CITY CENTRE ON PUBLIC HEALTH
PARTNERS ACTIVELY WORKING ON
THE FRONT LINES OF THIS
DEMOCRAT ANAGRAMS REMINI
TOWARDS. MINS IN A LOCAL SYSTEM
THAT HAS BEEN UNDER RESOURCE
FOR DECADES. JUST SUPER CITY IS
MEANT TO AWARD NEARLY TWELVE
BILLION DOLLARS. THE STATE'S
TERRITORIES TRIBES IN
LOCALITIES. TO ENHANCE THEIR
WRITTEN RESPONSE CAPABILITIES
WHEN CONFRONTED BY THE DISEASE
AT CDC AND PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS. MUST REAL TIME
JUST BASED ON REAL TIME DATA.
IS THE BACKBONE OF ANY DISEASE
BONDS WITH THE RESOURCES THE
CONGRESS'S PROVIDED DATA
MONETIZATION IS UNDER WAY. WE
ALSO MUST ENSURE THAT OUR
LABORATORIES AND RESILIENCE AND
VANCE TECHNOLOGY PERSONNEL
EXPERTISE AND SUPPLIES- ARE
BEING SOURCED. OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH WORKFORCE MIGHT GROW
EXPONENTIALLY TO ADDRESS COVID
CAN IN FUTURE PUBLIC HEALTH.
I'LL CONCENTRATE ON BEING
RECRUITED PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS ACROSS OUR NATION
BOTTOM LINE SUSTAINED
INVESTMENT IN THE PUBLIC HEALTH
SYSTEM IS A VESTMENT AND PRESS
OF THE NATION. LAST CD'S GONE
THERE ONCE A HEAD WIND THE NEXT
SEASON'S INFLUENZA ILLNESS WILL
OCCUR SIMULTANEOUSLY
POTENTIALLY WITH COVID NINETEEN
INCREASING THE CHALLENGES ON
HOSPITAL CARE PERFECT AND THE
PUBLIC. THIS CALL IS ALSO.
THANK URGED HIM PEOPLE BE PART.
AND TO EMBRACE FLU THAT WITH
COPS FOR YOUR YOUR FAMILY IS IN
THE COMMUNITIES A SINGLE. WILL
SAVE LIVES THANK YOU AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO YOUR QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
RANKING MEMBER WALDEN. THANK
YOU ALL FOR THE GIVE ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS WITH YOU
TODAY THE ROLE OF THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTES OF HEALTH AND
RESEARCH ADDRESS ON COVID
NINETEEN. THE APPROACH TO THE
NIH IT'S VERY SIMILAR TO WHAT
WE DO WITH OTHER EMERGING
INFECTIONS. IT'S A FOUR PRONGED
APPROACH FIRST THE STUDY THE
FUNDAMENTAL KNOWLEDGE OF THE
VIRUS HEALTH AS WELL AS THE
HOST RESPONSE TO. THE SECOND
HELP DIAGNOSTICS AND ASKED. A
THE THIRD IS THE CHARACTERIZING
TEST THERAPEUTICS. AND THE
FORCE IS TO DEVELOP SAFE AND
EFFECTIVE VACCINES SPEAKING OF
THE FIRST FUNDAMENTAL KNOWLEDGE
OF THE VIRUS BUT THE VIRUS IS
CAPABLE OF DOING. WE'VE DONE A
NUMBER OF STUDIES NOW THAT IT
FORMED HOWARD APPROACH
THERAPEUTICS AND VACCINES FOR
EXAMPLE THE PRECISE MOLECULAR
STRUCTURE. OF THE SPIKE PROTEIN
WHICH IS THAT PART OF THE VIRUS
WHICH ACTUALLY GIVES IT ITS
NAME ON A VIRUS. THE SPIKES
CHECK OUT FROM THE VIRUS THAT
IS. BY THIS IS IN BODY THIS IS
BEEN THE SITE MANY. SYSTEM
THOSE THAT WE FOR. SET DAMAGE.
THIS IS RECEPTOR WHEREBY THE
VIRUS BUYING TO SELL IN THE
BODY ALLOWING IT TO ENTER AND
CAUSE DISEASE IN ADDITION WE
DEVELOP ANIMAL MODELS WE DO
NATURAL HISTORY STUDIES SUCH AS
UNDERSTANDING THE VIRUS IN
DIFFERENT DEMOGRAPHIC GROUPS.
CAN IS THE DEVELOPMENT OF
DIAGNOSTICS AND ESSAYS WE
NEEDED AND WE WILL GET IT
WITHIN A REASONABLE PERIOD OF
TIME BASED ON A MAJOR
INVESTMENT IN THE RAT X.
PROTEIN- PROGRAM DIAGNOSTICS
THAT ARE POINT OF CARE SIMPLE
PRECISE- SENSITIVE AND
SPECIFIC. WE HOPE BY THE END OF
THE FALL INTO THE EARLY. WELL
HAVE THESE FOR WHITE. THIRD
MINUTE CHARACTERIZATION OF
DRUGS FOLLOW HER TO THE FIRST
SUCCESSFUL RANDOMIZED PLACEBO
CONTROLLED TRIAL OF A DRUG
CALLED REINVESTED. WHICH IS
USED IN HOSPITALIZED PATIENTS
WITH LUNG DISEASE IT SHOWED A
STATISTICALLY SIGNIFICANT
MODEST IMPACT ON DECREASING THE
TIME TO IS FROM SPINNING.
AIMLESSLY FAST RECOVERY IN
ADDITION THIS DRUG IS NOT USED
IN COMBINATION WITH ANOTHER
DRUG THAT BLOCKS THE
INFLAMMATORY RESPONSE. SENATE
WE ALL LOOKING RIGHT OTHERS.
COMBO CLASS. DROPS MORE
ANTIBODY AS WELL AS A IMMUNE
DAYS. FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF
SAFE AND EFFECTIVE VACCINES THE
HALLMARK OF ALL. REALLY
DEFINING RESPONSES THAT WE HAVE
TO VIRUS DISEASES IF YOU LOOK
AT THE HISTORY OF VIRAL
DISEASES IT IS GENERALLY
VACCINES THAT PUT THE NAIL IN
THE COFFIN OF THESE TYPES WE
ARE NOW MOUNTED A MAJOR EFFORT.
IN WHICH WE'RE COLLABORATING
INDUSTRY PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS
THAT TRIAL DEVELOPED THE WOMAN
ON WITH EACH. IN OTHER WAYS TO
HAVE MULTIPLE TRIALS IN WHICH
WE HAVE IN COMMON QUESTIONS ARE
BEING ASKED COMMON LAB RESULTS
BEING LOOKED AT COMMANDEER SAVE
MONEY. IN PROPERLY SET. AND
POINTS. THOSE VACCINES AND
THERE WERE MORE THAN ONE THERE
ARE SEVERAL THAT ARE MOVING
ALONG AND VERY SPACES ONE OF
THEM WILL ANSWER PHASE THREE
STARTED IN JULY THIS IS ONE
THAT IS ALREADY SHOWN
INCRIMINATE STUDIES. FAVORITE
SPOT. MODELS THAT. IT WOULD BE
OTHERS DOUBLE ONE MONTH TWO
MONTHS THREE MONTHS LATER
ALTHOUGH YOU CAN NEVER
GUARANTEE AT ALL THE SAFETY AND
EFFICACY OF THE VACCINE UNTIL
ACTUALLY. IN THE FIELD WE
CAUTIOUSLY OPTIMISTIC BASED ON
THE CONCERTED EFFORT AND THE
FACT THAT WE ARE TAKING
FINANCIAL RISKS NOT RISKS TO
SAFETY NOT RISK TO THE
INTEGRITY OF THE LANDS BUT
FINANCIALLY YES. TO BE A- THE
GAME SO THAT. AND I BELIEVE IT
WILL BE WHEN AND NOT IF WE GET
FAVORABLE CANDIDATES WITH GOOD
RESULTS WE WILL BE ABLE TO MAKE
THEM AVAILABLE THE MASS PUBLIC
AS THIS COMMITTEE ONCE AGO WITH
ANY COMPANY WHOSE. PUT IS AN
ELLEN DIER AND THE BEGINNING OF.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. TIM THE CHIP
IN THE APPLE TO QUIT LATER
THANK YOU. THANK YOU DOC FOUND
THANKS ROY. ON TO FIND THIS
PANDEMIC AND I'LL SAY THE SAME
ABOUT- ROGER ARE. BYE BYE OF
THE MOST YOUR RECORD HIGHS FOR
FIVE MINUTES HELLO. THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN. THEN I'LL OUR
CONVERSATION YOU CALL ANY.
RANKING MEMBER WALDEN MEMBERS
OF THE. SECRETARY IS QUITE READ
COURT TION OF COVID TESTING
EFFORTS WITHIN DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH AND YOU SERVICE. AND I
WOULD LIKE TO CLEAR THAT
ALTHOUGH I AM NO LONGER FULL
EMPLOYEE TO THEME PARK I AM
MAINTAINING MY ROLE
COORDINATING TESTING. AGYNESS
ON OVER TWO. IN COVID NINETEEN
TASK NOW AVERAGING ABOUT FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND TESTS PER DAY.
EVEN WITHOUT ANY MAJOR
TECHNICAL ADVANCES I ESTIMATE
THE NATION WILL HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO PERFORM BETWEEN
FORTY. MILLION A MONTH. TWO
ADDRESS THE PUBLIC HEALTH
CHALLENGES OVER THE PAST MONTHS
WE IMPLEMENTED A PHASED
APPROACH TO BE PROTESTING NEEDS
AT EACH STAGE OF THE PANDEMIC
SPECIALTY NET DURING RE OPENING
WEDNESDAY NEEDS PROTECTING HIS.
YES IN EARLY MARCH HHS A
DEVELOPMENT FORTY ONE COMMUNITY
BASED DRIVE THROUGH TESTING
SITES IN LOCATIONS PRIORITIZED
BY THE CDC AND COLLABORATE FOR
STATE AND LOCAL PARTNERS. SITES
NEARLY THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
HIGH RISK INTO THE- AND SERVED
AS PROTOTYPES THAT HAD BEEN
LOCATED FAULTY FAULT. NEXT WE
LEVERAGE TRUST FURTHER
IMPLEMENT COMMUNITY TESTING
ESPECIALLY FOR MINORITIES AND
UNDERSERVED IS THAT RIGHT
GRAHAM IS NOW FOR TEXTING AT X.
ON ELEVEN WILL. IN FORTY SEVEN
STATES AND THE DISTRICT 70% OF
WHICH ARE IN COMMITTEE WITH.
THE HIGHEST OF ALL. IT HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY EIGHT THOUSAND AND-
FEDERALLY QUALIFIED CENTERS
OVER TWENTY NINE MILLION PEOPLE
ACROSS THE NATION THEY PROVIDE
CARE TO ONE IN FIVE OF THOSE
ARE IN SHORT ONE IN FIVE RURAL
AMERICA IS ONE IN THREE LOOK.
POP UP AND ONE. HOMELESS MOST
VULNERABLE AMONG US 93% OF F.
Q. H. THESE OFFER COVID
NINETEEN CASTING. TO FURTHER
EXPAND ACT WE AUTHORIZED ALL
LICENSED PHARMACIST TO ORDER
ANY MINISTER COVID NINETEEN
TESTING UNDER THE PUBLIC
READINESS AND EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS TO A PRESS BACKED
OVER 9% OF AMERICANS LIVE
WITHIN MILES OF THE PHARMACY.
AGAIN DURING WIDESPREAD
MOBILITY. JUNE FOR IN THE
FORTIES PROVIDED TO SECRETARY
CARES HHS RELEASED A NEW MAYOR
CORY LABORATORY RIPPING
GUIDANCE SO THAT WE- ALL GROUP
BENNETT. WE FROM COOK COUNTY
DUSTING LAB REPORTS MUST
INCLUDE. READ AGAIN FROM LIKE
RACE AT AGE AND GENDER. AND
TODAY I AM PLEASED TO ANNOUNCE
THE SELECTION OF MORE HOUSES
SCHOOL OF MEDICINE AS THE
AWARDEE FOR A NEW FORTY BILLION
DOLLAR INITIATIVE TO FIGHT
NINETEEN AMONG RACIAL AND
ETHNIC MINORITIES WELL IT'S
ROLL AND OTHER SOCIALLY
VULNERABLE. OPERATIVE OF WITH
THE OFFICE. AS A MINORITY
HEALTH AND MOREHOUSE SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE WILL DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT A STRATEGIC NETWORK
OF NATIONAL STATE TERRITORIAL
TRIBAL AND LOCAL ORGANIZATIONS
DELIVER COPE NINETEEN RELATED
NATION TO COMMUNITIES HARDEST
HIT BY THE DOWNTURN IN THE FOR
OF THIS AGREEMENT MORE HOW
SCHOOL OF ASSEMBLED. MILLION
DOLLAR. THANKS TEST RESULTED IN
ON. DEMAND FOR SUPPLIES
REAGENTS LABORATORY PLATFORMS
TO MEET THIS DEMAND WE SECURED
THE GLOBAL SUPPLY CHAINS
REGULATORY ERIC RIDGE WE WERE
DIRECTLY MANUFACTURER STING THE
MASTIC PRODUCTION. WE
COLLABORATED WITH EXTERNAL
PARTNERS TO IN TEKNAF TERMS WE
SECURED AND PRIORITIZE YOUR SIX
POINT OF CARE TESTS FOR STATE
PUBLIC HEALTH LABORATORIES. THE
IN HOME SERVICE AND OTHER LOCAL
MEDIA. FINALLY THREE OF THE
AFTER THE FURTHER INVEST INTO
AND- THESE ACTIONS AND OTHERS
HAVE ENABLED OUR CURRENT
EFFORTS WITH STATES TERRITORIES
AND TRIBES TO IMPLEMENT
EVIDENCE BASED DIAGNOSTIC AND
SURVEILLANCE PLANS. I WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE BY RECOGNIZED MY
FELLOW OFFICERS IN THE UNITED
STATES PUBLIC OUR HEALTH
SERVICE COMMISSIONED CORPS THE
UNIFORMED SERVICE THAT I LIED
FOUR THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED
EIGHTY TWO OFFICERS. AT THE
POLL TO SUPPORT THEM. IT INTO
THE DIAMOND CRUISE SHIP AND
SHIP. BASES REPATRIATING
AMERICANS TO OUR COMMUNITY
BASED TESTING SITES THE FEMALE
ON TASK FORCES DIRECTLY INSIDE
NURSING HOMES AND TO FIELD
HOSPITALS ACROSS OUR NATION
EXAM FIND THE CARE. AT ALL THE
STEEL FOR THOSE WHO HAVE
SUFFERED DURING THIS PANDEMIC.
THANK EACH AND EVERY ONE OF
THESE OFFICERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES AND ON THEIR BEHALF I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK ALL OF YOU
IN CONGRESS FOR SUPPORTING OUR
TRAINING. ESTABLISHMENT OF
SERVER. DURING FOOTBALL FUTURE
NATIONAL EMERGENCIES THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE THESE REMARKS. THANK
YOU HOUR ROLLING THANK YOU FOR
MENTIONING THE- THE BOTH
MILITARY AND CIVILIAN- WERE OUT
FRONT. AND HELPING MR THIS
CHRIST SAID. REALLY APPRECIATE
ALL THAT THEY DO HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HELP THEM AS MUCH
AS POSSIBLE. SO THAT'S NOT
SPEECH. IS THIS IS THE DOCTOR
ON COMMISSIONER HAHN. SIR A
TERRIBLE ON RANKING MEMBER
WALDEN AND DISTINGUISHED
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR INVITING ME HERE TODAY.
FIRST LIKE TO START BY THANKING
ALL OF YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF
THE AGENCY IN US GOVERNMENT
WITH A LOT OF PASS AND BECOME
LAW. OF THE LAND THIS HELPED A
GREAT DEAL OUR RESPONSE. FDA
HAS A CRITICAL ROLE IN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S RESPONSE
TO THE COVID NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
WE REMAIN FOCUSED ON OUR
MISSION OF PROTECTING PROMOTING
THE HEALTH GIVE AMERICAN.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S REQUEST. WE
HAVE PROVIDED PROCREATE
REGULATORY. PLEASE TO SHOWED
THAT THE AMERICAN PUBLIC. HAS
ACCESS TO CRITICAL MASS
PRODUCTS SEAFOODS. COMP
GOVERNMENT. BEGINNING OF THIS
PANDEMIC. WE APPRECIATE MORE
THAN A HUNDRED EMERGENCY USE
AUTHORIZATIONS FOR DIAGNOSTICS
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
THAN. ON OTHER DEVICES AS WELL
AS FOR DRUG PREP PRODUCTS.
SINCE THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY WAS DECLARED WE
ISSUED MORE THAN FOUR FIFTY
GUIDANCE DOCUMENTS TO HELP
ENSURE THE CONTINUITY OF
HEALTHCARE AND SAFE FOOD
SUPPLY. AND WE PUT INTO PLACE
NEW INITIATIVES TO ACCELERATE
THE DEVELOPMENT OF NEEDED
PRODUCTS. THIS WITH THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC UP TO DATE ON
WHAT THEY NEED TO DO TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES AND EXPLAIN THE
VIRUS FROM SPREADING. WE ARE
NOW PREPARING FOR THE NEXT
PHASE OF ADDRESSING THIS
EVOLVING CRISIS. IT IS MISSION
CRITICAL THAT THE AGENCY
CONTINUE TO BE DILIGENT
ASSURING THE SAFETY OF THE
PRODUCTS WE REGULATE. THAT WE
ALSO PUT IN PLACE TO SEIZE
NEEDED TO ASSURE THE
PROTECTIONS THAT THE PUBLIC
WILL NEED. THERE ARE A NUMBER
EXPERIENCE GAME FOR THE PAST
FEW MONTHS THAT WILL INFORM OUR
PLANS. WE RECOGNIZE WE MUST BE
BOLD IN DECISION MAKING AND
ADVANCE EFFECTIVE SOLUTIONS TO
ACHIEVE CHALLENGING PUBLIC
HEALTH OBJECTIVES. THEREFORE WE
HAVE BEGUN A COMPREHENSIVE REAL
TIME REVIEW AND ASSESSMENT OF
OUR ACTIONS TO DATE TO ADDRESS
THE COVID NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
THE OBJECTIVE IS TO TRY AND
ADDRESS POTENTIAL
ORGANIZATIONAL AND PROGRAMMATIC
CHANGES THAT SHOULD BE
IMPLEMENTED WITHOUT DELAY. AND
TO ADVANCE ON RESPONSE. TO THE
COVID NINETEEN. WE NEED TO
ENSURE THAT WE BRIDGE WHAT IS
WORKING WELL. WELL AT THE SAME
TIME REVIEWER FRAMEWORK AND
POLICIES TO BE COMPETITION TO
EFFECTIVELY IDENTIFY. AND
RESPOND TO QUICKLY INVOLVING
THE CAP SITUATIONS. YOUR FOCUS
WILL BE TO IDENTIFY WHAT
REGULATORY POLICIES SHOULD BE
CONTINUED. AND ACCELERATED
CONSISTENT EFFECTIVE EXECUTIVE
ORDER THIRTEEN TWO NINE FOUR
SIGNED BY THE PRESIDENT.
DURABLE POLICY ORGANIZATION ON
PROGRAMMATIC CHANGES WILL BE
CONSISTENT WITH THE DANCING THE
AGENCIES PUBLIC HEALTH MISSION
AND WILL INFORM OUR STRATEGIC
HIGHER LEARNING FORWARD. ONE OF
THE CHALLENGE FACING AT DURING
THE COVID NINETEEN PANDEMIC IS
HOW DO WE SURE THE TIMELY
REVIEW OF MEDICAL PRODUCT
APPLICATIONS DESPITE INCREDIBLE
SURGE VOLUME. CONSTRAINTS ON
OUR ABILITY TO CONSTRUCT IN
SITES AFFECTIONS. I AM PLEASED
TO ANNOUNCE TODAY THAT FDA HAS
MAINTAINED THE SAME PACE OF
MEETING ITS GOALS ON
APPLICATIONS FOR MEDICAL
PRODUCT. FOR THE LAST SIX OF.
NINETEEN IN RECENT YEARS WE ARE
ON TARGET TO MEET USER FEE
GOALS FOR THE DRUGS THIS YEAR
BY REVIEWING IN TAKING TIMELY
ACTION ON AT LEAST 90% OF BRAND
GENERIC AND BIOSIMILAR DRUG
APPLICATIONS. EVEN DURING THE
PAST. ADDITIONALLY THIS WORK IS
COMPLETED AND WHEN THE NUMBER
OF APPLICATIONS RECEIVED IN
SOME CENTRES IS SUBSTANTIALLY
HIGHER THAN THE PRE COVID NOT
IN TIMES. I WANT TO THANK THE
MORE THAN NINETEEN THOUSAND
POLICE AT THE AT THE FDA FOR
THEIR INCREDIBLE EFFORTS. ONE
THAT REFLECTS THE REMARKABLE
DEDICATION AND COMMITMENT TO
THE PUBLIC HEALTH OF ALL
AMERICANS. FINALLY I'D LIKE TO
DISCUSS. FOR ALL AMERICANS
NAMELY THE WORKED FTAS DURING
TO FACILITATE THE MOVEMENT OF
SAFE VACCINES AND THERAPEUTICS.
FDA YOU IN DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM
CALLED THE CORONAVIRUS
TREATMENT ACCELERATED PROGRAM
OR C. TAP AND WE CONTINUE TO
WORK NIGHT AND DAY TO PROVIDE
GUIDANCE AND TO REVIEW
PROPOSALS FROM THESE SCIENTISTS
AND RESEARCHERS WHO ARE
DEVELOPING THERAPIES. LET ME BE
CLEAR DATA IN SCIENCE WILL
DICTATE WHEN WILL HAVE SAFE AND
EFFECTIVE TREATMENTS AND
VACCINES FOR COVID NINETEEN AS
DOCTOR FELT SHE JUST MENTIONED.
TOWARD THAT END D. A. IS USING
EVERY AVAILABLE AUTHORITY AND
APPLYING EVERY APPROPRIATE
REGULATORY FLEXIBILITY TO
FACILITATE THE DEVELOPMENT AND
TESTING. WE HAVE NOT LOST SIGHT
OF OUR SOLEMN RESPONSIBILITY TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE. TO ENSURE
DECISIONS RELATED TO ALL
MEDICAL PRODUCTS ARE BASED ON
SCIENCE AND DATA THAT IS A
COMMITMENT AT THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC CAN HAVE CONFIDENCE IN.
CAN I ASSURE YOU THAT THE DAY
WILL PROVIDE LEADERSHIP
EXPERTISE GUIDANCE INFORMATION.
AND WHATEVER ELSE IS NEEDED AS
WE CONTINUE TO ADDRESS IS
UNPRECEDENTED TOWNS THANK YOU
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
COMMISSION. CONCLUDES OUR
OPENINGS- FROM THE WITNESSES ON
OUR MOVE TO MEMBER QUESTIONS.
EACH MEMBER WILL HAVE FIVE
MINUTES TO ASK QUESTIONS OF OUR
WITNESSES AND I'LL START.
RECOGNIZING MYSELF FOR FIVE
MINUTES. NOW YOU KNOW THAT I'M
VERY CRITICAL OF THE PRESIDENT-
FOR A LACK OF LEADERSHIP FROM
THE STATE OR THIS PANDEMIC
WHICH I THINK CONTINUES. AND OF
COURSE IS DIFFICULT BECAUSE YOU
WORK IN FOR THE PRESIDENT. AND
I'VE- PRETTY GIVE YOU ON
VACATION. ACTUALLY WANTED TO
TAKE MORE. AND HE- AS THE
DOCTOR WHO MENSCH COMMITTEE ON
FULLY COCKED OF THE DATA AND
THE SCIENCE SO IT'S DIFFICULT
BECAUSE I'M AN ISSUE QUESTIONS
ABOUT. THE PRESIDENT'S LACK OF
LEADERSHIP AND I KNOW IT'S HARD
FOR YOU TO ANSWER THOSE SO
WE'LL SEE. BUT I DO BOOK THE
PRESIDENT IS ENCOURAGING
BEHAVIORS THAT ARE NOT
CONSISTENT WITH GOOD PUBLIC
HEALTH SUCH AS URGING THOUSANDS
TO ATTEND. NOT MAYOR THE
WEARING OF. AND I CAN'T IMAGINE
THAT THE NIH OR CDC WAS
SUGGESTS AS A BEST PRACTICE IN
THE FACE. DEMOCRAT SO SELECTORS
CLICK TWO VERSIONS OF ALLERGY
HERE ONCE THE PRESIDENT. ON
HOPEFULLY IS BASED ON DATA AND
SITES- BUT I WANT TO HEAR FROM
THE EXPERTS SO LET ME START
WITH DOCTOR FOR FEWER TRUSTED
VOICE AND I'VE ALWAYS BEEN
CANDID WITH US EMERIC PUBLIC.
GIVE DONE VOTE. WHERE WE ARE.
AT FIVE. THIS CALL. IS CLEARLY.
THANK YOU VERY FOR THE QUESTION
IS THE IT REALLY IS A BAG WE
HAVE A VERY LARGE VERY
HETEROGENEOUS MAJOR DIFFERENCES
FOR EXAMPLE BETWEEN THE NEW
YORK METROPOLITAN AREA IN
CASPER WYOMING- IF YOU LOOK AT
HOW WE'VE BEEN HERE WE'VE BEEN
HIT BADLY I NEED ANYBODY LOOKED
AT THE NOT AS WE HAVE NOW OVER
A HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND
DEATHS WE HAD TWO AND A HALF
MILLION. SO IT'S A SERIOUS
SITUATION IN SOME EX WELL RIGHT
NOW FOR EXAMPLE THE YORK METS.
AREA WHICH HAS BEEN HIT
EXTRAORDINARILY HARD. HAS DONE
VERY WELL IN BRINGING THE CASES
DOWN AND USING THE LINES THAT
WE HAVE VERY CAREFULLY PUT
TOGETHER. IN THIS IS FASHION.
YEAH OPEN THEIR CITY AND THEIR
STATE HOWEVER IN OTHER AREAS OF
THE COUNTRY WE'RE NOW SEEING A
DISTURBING SURGE OF
INSPECTIONS. THAT LOOKS LIKE
IT'S A COMBINATION BUT ONE OF
THE THINGS IS AN INCREASING
COMMUNITY SPREAD. AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT I'M REALLY QUITE
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT AND YOU
KNOW THAT THIS IS BEEN
SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN A PRESS
OVER THE PAST COUPLE DAYS. WE
WERE GOING DOWN FROM THIRTY
THOUSAND. TO TWENTY AND THAT WE
SORT OF STAYED ABOUT FLAT AND
NOW WE'RE GOING UP A COUPLE OF
DAYS. THIRTY THOUSAND ACTIONS
AS CLOSE TO ME THE- S. THAT.
THIS AND OVER. IS YOUR TO HAVE
THEM. THE SYSTEM THE TESTING TO
IDENTIFY ISOLATE AND CONTACT
TRACING AND EFFECTIVE WAY SO
THAT WHEN YOU SEE THOSE
INCREASES YOU CAN UNDERSTAND
WHERE THEY'RE COMING FROM. AND
YOU CAN DO SOMETHING ABOUT THEM
RIGHT NOW THE NEXT COUPLE OF
WEEKS ARE GOING TO BE CRITICAL
IN OUR ABILITY TO EXPRESS
SEARCH. WAS SET IN FLORIDA IN
TEXAS IN ARIZONA AND IN OTHER
STATES THEY'RE NOT THE ONLY
ONES THAT HAVING A DIFFICULTY.
I'M ON DISNEY CHANNEL IT'S A
BIG BAG. SOME GOOD AND SOME NOT
WE HAVE A PROBLEM WITH. ALL
RIGHT NOW I'M GONNA HAVE TO ASK
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT BECAUSE YOU
TALK ABOUT A STATE AND HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS THANK. YOU
AFTER ON YOUR CHILD. THAT IS
RALLY ILL THE WEEK THE PRESS
SAID I QUOTE WHEN YOU DO TEST
TO THAT EXTENT YOU'RE GOING TO
FIND MORE PEOPLE IF YOU'RE
GOING TO FIND WORK CASES. SO I
SAID TO MY PEOPLE SLOW THE
TESTING DOWN PLEASE ON QUOTE.
AND THIS MORNING HE SAID HE
MEANT THIS. THE DOCTOR FELT
SHOULD DO YOU AGREE WITH THAT
DOES THAT MAKE SENSE SET TO
SAFELY OPEN OUR ECONOMY WE
SHOULD BE GETTING THEM PROTESTS.
OF THE DAY WHO NEEDS A TECH CAN
GET ONE AND YOU DON'T HAVE TO
MENTION THE PRESIDENT I DID.
TELL US ABOUT TESTING AND- ALL.
THE MEMBERS OF. ALCOHOL YOU'RE
MY IS ON A AUTISM OF THE TASK
FORCE AND MY COLLEAGUES ON THE
TASK FORCE TO MY KNOWLEDGE I
KNOW FOR SURE BUT TO MY
KNOWLEDGE NONE OF US HAD EVER
BEEN TOLD TO SLOW DOWN ON
TESTING THAT JUST IS A FACT IN
FACT WE WILL BE DOING MORE
TESTING AS YOU HEARD FROM THE
JURY BOX. ONLY TEST TO
SPECIFICALLY IDENTIFY PEOPLE IN
THE IDENTIFY ISOLATED CONTENT
TRACE ALSO MORE SURVEILLANCE IF
YOU WANT TO GET YOUR ARMS
AROUND AND UNDERSTAND EXACTLY
WHAT'S GOING ON IN COMMUNITY
SPREAD SO IT'S THE OPPOSITE
WE'RE GONNA BE DOING MORE TO
NOT LESS AN ENEMY THIS ESTIMATE
REDFIELD GREW AT THE PRESENT ON
THIS DO YOU THINK WE SHOULD BE
TESTING MORE PEOPLE YOU DON'T
WANT TALK ABOUT ISN'T THIS
TELLS IF YOU THINK WE SHOULD BE
TESTING GREAT. YES DOCTOR. ALL
OF THE HAVE. BEEN COMMITTED TO
IN. READILY TO ON TO WE MADE UP
MARK AND- ON WE STILL HAVE A TO
GO. ONE OF THE KEY THINGS AS
TONY MENTIONED IS SURVEILLANCE
EXPANDING SURVEILLANCE BECAUSE
OF THE SYMPTOMATIC NATURE
DISINFECTION. AND IN DOING SO
WE'RE LOOKING AT WAYS THEY CAN
REALLY SUBSTANTIAL IN
INSTRUCTING BY POTENTIALLY CORN
SAMPLES SO RIGHT NOW. RIGHTS
AND TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND CENTEL'S TEST TODAY IF
WE CAN PULL SAMPLES FIVE TO ONE
THAT WOULD BRING IT TO THREE
MILLION TEST TODAY SO. WE'RE
CONTINUING TO TRY TO ENHANCE
AND IT'S A CRITICAL. RESPONSE
THANK YOU THE ACURA TO
RECOGNIZE THAT MR WALDEN FIVE
MINUTES. A CHAIRMAN LET ME LET
ME STRAIGHT TO THE QUESTION-
THAT MY COLLEAGUE GAS I'LL JUST
ASK EACH OF YOU FOR YES OR NO
ANSWER AS PRESIDENT TRUMP EVER
DIRECTED YOU TO SLOW DOWN
TESTING FOR COVID NINETEEN IN
THE UNITED STATES. REDFIELD NO
YES SIR. NO COMMENTS THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT LET'S GO TO SOME
OTHER ISSUES HERE- DOCTOR ON-
YOU CREATED A- A WEBSITE I
BELIEVE ON THE FDA SIDE DEALING
WITH CONVALESCENT PLASMA PLASMA
AND THE ANTIBODY RICH
INVESTIGATIONAL THERAPIES THAT
MAY HELP FIGHT THE VIRUS.
WHAT'S THE STATUS OF THE
RESEARCH CAN EFFECTIVENESS OF
CONVALESCENT PLASMA INVITING
COVID NINETEEN WHAT WE KNOW
RIGHT NOW. THANK ON SMALL DENT
ON REALLY IMPORTANT QUESTION
FOR THERAPEUTICS POINT OF VIEW
ON AS EVERYONE HERE KNOWS
ACCOMPLICE IMPLIES MAZE WHERE
YOU TAKE THE NATURAL IMMUNITY
FROM PERSON WHO'S RECOVERED
COVID NINETEEN THOSE
ANTIBODIES. AND THEN
ADMINISTERED TO A PERSON'S. SO
WE HAVE PARTNERED WITH FLORIDA
IN HHS- AS WELL AS THE MAYO
CLINIC TO DEVELOP ACT WHAT'S
CALLED AN EXPANDED ACCESS
PROGRAM. WE HAVE SAFETY DATA
FROM OVER TWENTY THOUSAND
PATIENTS THEY CHOSE THIS IS A
VERY SAFE THERAPY AND OUR
PRELIMINARY ASSESSMENT OF THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THIS PLASMA IS
QUITE ENCOURAGING. WE CONTINUE
TO LOOK AT THE INFORMATION. ON
IF THOSE DATA HOLD WE WILL HAVE
A POTENTIALLY ANOTHER WEAPON IN
THE ARMAMENTARIUM AGAINST COVID
NINETEEN. THOSE FINAL RESULTS
IS ALSO ALLOW US TO HAVE
INFORMATION THAT WILL FEED THE
DEVELOPMENT ON THE KELANA
BODIES IN SOMETHING ELSE CALLED
A HIGH PREMIUM GLOBULIN WHICH
WE CAN PULL THAT HAS BEEN
EXECUTED AS INJECTION TO BE.
IT'S A GOOD STORY RIGHT NOW.
FOR THE FOR DAY TO COME IN AND
WE SHOULD KNOW SHORT ABOUT THE-
THEY'RE ALSO SAID RANDOM ON
TRIALS LOOKING AT THIS AS WELL
THAT OUR ON GOING ACROSS THE
COUNTRY. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH A DR REDFIELD'S CDC
HAS DEVELOPED A NEW TEST TO US
SIMULTANEOUSLY ATTACK- TWO
STRAINS OF INFLUENZA AND THE
COVID NINETEEN. AND IS SEEKING
INPUT EMERGENCY USE TOWARD THE
CTC ENVISION ITS COMBINED
TESTED THE USE YEAH I THINK
IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT- AS I
MENTIONED AS WE GET TO THE FALL
WE'RE GONNA HAVE INFLUENCES AND
COVID AT THE SAME TIME- AND-
CDC'S. RELEVANT DETAILS FOR THE
PUBLIC HEALTH SYSTEM. BUT IN
PARALLEL THE PROPERTY SECTOR
NOW IS ALSO ADVANCING GOT
ADVANCED DEVELOPED REDUCTION
MONTHS WENT ON. TO PROJECTS SO
TO SELL EIGHT. I'M GOING TO
ASSIST TO COOK. PATHOGENS ARE
TRYING YOU WANT TO COMMENT ON
THE YES I EIGHTY SIX DOES WILL
DRIVE WE BEEN WORKING WITH A
COMPANY TO ACTUALLY AT THAT I'M
A DRAWS BEEN AT THE FOR OF THIS
IS BEEN A GREAT. I WOULD JUST
TO GO. WITH MY CALL. WERE ALL
CAN. ABOUT THE- OF CLOSER. OF
IN FULL. A B. AS WELL AS COVID
NINETEEN WHEN IT COMES TO FLU
SEASON. SO WE WANT TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO SIMPLIFY.
THE DIAGNOSIS AND YOU CAN HAVE
THAT IF YOU HAVE A SINGLE TASK.
AND WE'RE WORKING WITH MULTIPLE
MANUFACTURERS AS USUAL THE CDC
IS USUALLY IN THE LEAD. BUT THE
MULTIPLE MANUFACTURERS BOTH
THAT POINT OF CARE. AND
LABORATORY WHO WILL HAVE THIS
TYPE OF TEST AVAILABLE RIGHT
EXCELLENT- YOU ALL BEEN SUBJECT
TO A LOT OF CRITICISM AS HAS
THE PRESIDENT. OFTEN THAT'S
LEVELED. AFTER WE KNOW FACTS WE
DIDN'T KNOW AT THE TIME WHEN
THINGS STARTED. AND SO IT'S
REALLY GREAT IF YOU HAVE
HINDSIGHT TWENTY TWENTY VISION
YOU CAN LOOK BACK. SAY THE
DONE. THEN I WOULD LOOK FORWARD.
WHAT DO YOU. YOU NEED FROM. YOU
DO NOT HAVE NOW. TO HAVE A MOVE
READY FOR THE FALL WHAT SHOULD
WE BE PREPARING FOR NOW- FOR
THE FALL. OKAY WHO WANTS TO
START. ON DOWN TO A MINUTE. TO
ANSWER SO DR REDFIELD. I THINK
FIRST I WANT TO JUST EXPRESS
OUR APPRECIATION TO CONGRESS
FOR THE SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING.
TWO TWELVE BILLION DOLLARS TO
THE STATES TO HELP PREPARE
THEIR COVID RESPONSES AND
REALLY THAT'S IN ON A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF RESOURCES I WOULD
ONLY. WE TO HOW TO MAKE THIS IS
SUSTAINABLE INVESTMENT. AS
OPPOSED TO A SPORADIC AND INTO
DISPERSE CHALLENGE WE HAVE ON
OUR ABOUT YOU WHAT WE'VE BEEN
WORRIED. WHAT THAT YOU HAVE
WELL I JUST. DR DEAL SAID WE
EXTRAORDINARILY GREAT. FOR THE-
ON PRESS AMOUNTS OF FUNDED THAT
THE CONGRESS GATE WHICH WHICH
REALLY MAKE IT TOTALLY PASSED
FOR US TO DO THE KINDS OF
THINGS WE NEED TO DO ON AN
EMERGENCY BASIS BUT THE AND
MENTION WHAT DR PHIL SAID WE
HAVE TO ESTABLISH SOME
CORPORATE MEMORY. I SAID
COMMITTEE. EARLY TIMES OVER THE
MANY YEARS. THAT WE FORGET
THINGS WHEN WE GET DISTANT FROM
THEM YEAH WE'RE GOING THROUGH A
TERRIBLE ORDEAL RIGHT NOW. WE
NEED TO HAVE IN PLACE THE
STABLE TYPE OF SUPPORT. FOR
PREPAREDNESS FABRICS WE WILL
GET THROUGH THIS THIS WILL END.
UP POLICE RATHER THAN LATER
NEED TO ESTABLISH A SYSTEM SO
THAT WE'RE PREPARED IF YOU
CHECK OUT BREAKS THANK YOU. MR
CREDIBILITY JUST ANSWER THE
QUESTION QUICKLY SEVERAL. WHAT
DO YOU NEED YOU DON'T HAVE WHAT
SHOULD WE BE WORRIED ABOUT- I
WANT TO EXPRESS MY THANKS AGAIN
TO WRITE COMMITTEE BUT LET ME
GET TO THE POINT. I THINK
SUSTAINABILITY COMMITMENT IS
VERY FRIGHTENED I WAS INVOLVED.
IN A BOWL AND TWENTY FIFTEEN
DALLAS. I TRUMP AT LEAST SOME
OF THE POLICY OPTIONS DURING
THAT TIME AND YOU SEE OVER FIVE
YEAR PERIOD WE SORT OF FORGOT
ALL THE LESSONS THAT WE WERE
TRYING TO GET IMPLEMENTED
INCLUDING P. E. N. UP. POPS ON
I WOULD SAY SOME OF THE BIGGEST
LIMITATIONS I KNOW EVERYONE IS
GOING ON THAT'S- ASKED. IN
FIRST. ALL RIGHT ABOUT ON CALL.
HUNDRED HELP TODAY TRYING TO
HUNDRED. WHO'S ON AN ICY YOU
BACK WHO'S NOT WHO HAS DONE A
LATER. HOW MUCH YOU HAVE LEFT.
AND WE GOT THROUGH THIS EARLY
NOT BY SYSTEMS BUT BY. PEOPLE
WORKING TWENTY FOUR SEVEN THE
THIRD THING IS. I'M JUST GONNA
POUND AT THE VACCINE
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THIS COUNTRY.
A TO PROMOTE VACCINATION TO
PROMOTE VACCINE CONFIDENCE. TO
MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE HAVE THE
RIGHT INFORMATION. ABOUT SAFETY
AND EFFICACY THAT WE ORDER
ENOUGH FLU VACCINE BECAUSE WE
REALLY NEED TO GET EVERYBODY
VACCINATED THIS WINTER OF ONE
THING THAT MINIMIZES OUR
PROBLEMS WITH EVERYBODY FLU
VACCINE. THAT'S ONE LESS VIRUS
THAT COULD KILL. TWENTY THIRTY
FIFTY THOUSAND SEVENTY THOUSAND
AND BUT- HE DIDN'T GIVE ONE
THOUGHT. WITH COVID AKAN. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR THE SUPPORT
ONE BIG POINT I WANT TO MAKE
HERE IS THAT WHAT WE LEARNED
DURING THIS. EPIDEMIC WHATEVER
DRAWS SAID IS THAT WE HAVE AN
ACCESS TO INFORMATION Q. WE
HAVE A LOT THAT WE NEED TO
COLLECT REAL. WORLD EVIDENCE IN
REAL TIME TO EMERGENCY CHESTNUT.
I WOULD DO DURING INFANCY TO
INFORM. ON HOW WE CAN CHANGE
THEM FOR. SO YOU'RE WORDS. REAL
IN CHIN CHIN WOULD BE
INCREDIBLE ON. I'M SENATE WE'RE
GONNA MOVE TO OUR MEMBER FACED
ON SENIOR. AND I THINK ON. FEW
ARE. ARE VIRGIL'S JUST REMINDED
ON MUTE IF YOU DON'T. DO SO ON
YOUR OWN ON JUST KEEP REMINDING
AT. CEMEX WE HAVE- MISTER RUSH
FROM ILLINOIS. I WANT TO.
HOLDING THIS IMPORTANT. SIMPLY
BEATING ELEMENTAL ON HEARING ON
THE RACIAL AND ETHNIC HEALTH.
MEDIA IN LEARNING HOW HARMLESS.
HELLO SHARON AT. IS A SUN ROOM
ARTICLE HOME THIS WELL. ONE
NINE IN THE SAME WAY THAT'S ONE
OF MY- NEWS ON THE- WELL THIS
IS CERTAINLY NOT THE ONE ONE
WAS. ONE MINIMUM HELLO. ONE OF
WALK MEN AND WOMEN. CORONAVIRUS
AND THE NOT. DURING OVER
TOMORROW. WELL. MY.
INSTITUTIONAL RACISM. PARDON.
ANYTHING ALSO BRING MORE MAN
HEARING. I THINK I KNOW THE GUY
DID HEAR IT QUITE AS CLEAR AS
SOMEONE BUT I THINK I KNOW WHAT
THE CONGRESSMAN REFERRING. SO
WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE- ON.
COMMUNITY AND THEN THEY MIGHT
ALREADY CAN. IN GENERAL AS A
DEMOGRAPHIC GROUP. THERE ARE
TWO ELEMENTS THAT MAKE IT MUCH
MORE DIFFICULT FOR THEM AND WHY
THEY'RE SUFFERING
DISPROPORTIONATELY. ONE IS THE
RISK. OF INFECTION. BECAUSE OF
ECONOMIC AND OTHER
CONSIDERATIONS. THE JOBS THAT
THE MAJORITY OF THEM WOULD FIND
THEMSELVES IN. DOES NOT ALLOW
THEM TO PROTECT THEMSELVES BY
LOOKING INTO A COMPUTER AND
DOING TELEWORK MOST OF THEM.
ARE ESSENTIAL ON OUTSIDE HAVING
TO MINGLE. IN A SOCIETY IN
WHICH THE VIRUS. IS
CIRCULATING. SO RIGHT AT THE
GET GO. THEY HAVE A GREATER
RISK OF GETTING INFECTED. AND
THEN WE KNOW FROM A LOT OF
EXPERIENCE NOW. THAT THE
SITUATION. REGARDING WHAT
THEY'RE NOT YOU HAVE SERIOUS
CONSEQUENCES. HOSPITALIZATIONS
IN ADDITION COMPLICATIONS AND
DEATH. IN LATE VERY STRONGLY.
THE PREVALENCE AND INCIDENCE OF
UNDERLYING COMORBID CONDITIONS.
WHICH ARE CLEARLY
DISPROPORTIONATELY. MORE
EXPRESSED. IN AFRICAN AMERICAN
POPULATION. THEN IN THE ROOM
THE POPULATION AT. I PUT.
DIABETES OBESITY CHRONIC LUNG
DISEASE AND KIDNEY DISEASE. SO
ONE FOR WE HAVE A SITUATION
WHERE IT'S SORT OF A DOUBLE
WHAMMY OF THE NEGATIVE
CAPABILITY OF THEM TO RESPOND
THROUGH NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN.
BECAUSE OF UNDERLYING
CONDITIONS AND THE CONDITIONS
IN WHICH THEY FIND THEMSELVES
WITH NOT KNOWING HOW. WOULD
YOU. CONSIDER OUR REASONS IT'S
NO. WHAT THE- THANK. THERE ON
SIMILAR ALONG YOUR MERRY WAY
TIM TO NEWS FOR MORE. I THINK
THE QUESTION WAS WHAT I IS
RACISM AS CONTRIBUTING NO I
DON'T THINK THAT YES THANK YOU
CONGRESSMAN WELL I MEAN
OBVIOUSLY THE AFRICAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY HAS SUFFERED FROM
RACISM FOR A VERY VERY LONG
PERIOD OF TIME AND I CANNOT
IMAGINE THAT THAT IS NOT
CONTRIBUTED TO THE CONDITIONS
THAT THEY FIND THEMSELVES IN
ECONOMICALLY AND OTHERWISE SO
THE ACCOMPLISHMENT IS YES. NINE
FOUR NINE FOUR. I MEAN FOR
EIGHT MILLION ON A. I'M JUST
TRYING MANAGING. ONE OF CURRENT
K. TO A OPEN NAME ON HIM IN THE
VEHICLE THE TRAIN WAS CALLS ONE
HUNDRED MILLION NO FOR CHECKING
AND OKAY. WE ON. JAMES AND-
THANK YOU OUR CONGRESSMEN ON
FOR TESTING AND CON RACE WE'RE
GONNA BE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS I
MEAN THAT'S THE AMOUNT OF
INVESTMENT THAT WE'RE DOING
PARTIALLY THROUGH CDC THIS
SPECIFIC AWARD IS TO YOU HAVE
MORE HOUSE LEAD A CONSORTIUM OF
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE ONE HUNDRED
BLACK AND- LOOTED UPS U. S. THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS ARE
THE NEW COUNCIL URBAN INDIAN
HEALTH ETCETERA ETCETERA TO
REALLY FOCUS ON SPECIFIC
EDUCATIONAL TESTING AND LINKAGE
HERE NEEDS OF UNDERSERVED
MINORITIES AND SOME OF THOSE
ALSO IN THE RURAL POPULATION.
MY PERSONAL HIS FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS IS A START YOU NEED TO
BE A LOT MORE THAN THAT IN
ORDER TO REACH THE PEOPLE THAT
WE- REACH. I ANKARA NET IS THAT
MR UPTON FROM MICHIGAN. THANKS
THANKS VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
THAT REALLY APPRECIATE THE
TESTIMONY THAT WE HEARD THAT
THUS FAR IN INTERNATIONAL AFTER
TWEETING ALL OF OUR OUR- I
GUESS WHAT I AT. BACKED OUT HE
RAN THANK YOU GREAT YOUR
SERVICE FOR SURE. IN RECENT
WEEKS- WHO OF COURSE YOU MADE
THE STATEMENT THAT WE HAVE AS
MANY AS A HUNDRED MILLION DOSES
OF BACK SENIOR FORTY YEAR. I
HEARD FROM A NUMBER OF
COMPANIES THAT IF PASSED IN
RECENT DAYS AFTER SNIFFER-
FIZER. OKAY GRABS A BILLION
DOSES FOR THE END OF THAT YEAR
CALENDAR YEAR TWENTY ONE. SO IT
STARTED IN NOT. INCLUDING OUR
NO PROCESS IT. OR MAYBE EVEN
GET SOME PRODUCTION A LITTLE
BIT BUT- FIVE WHITE EARLY
LAWYER. NOT YET AT. A WORKING.
THE PROBLEM WAS SET OF THE
MARKET PLACES IN EARLY SAVING
THE WORLD LET'S FACE IT. WHAT
YOU SHOULD DO FOR WHAT IS THE
HOW EARLY. WE MADE A CD MP WAY
EMERGENCY USE AUTHORIZATION
APPROVED FOR ANY OF THESE
VACCINES BASED ON WHAT YOU KNOW
TODAY AND UNDER THE SCENARIOS
THAT WE MAY SEE SOMETHING IN
THE NEXT NUMBER OF MONTHS IN
TERMS OF APPROVAL RATE OF WHAT
YOU THINK IS A POP A REAL
DISTINCT POSSIBILITY WHERE WE
MIGHT END UP. BE OKAY YOU. I
DID NOT HEAR ON IT WELL I
DIDN'T HEAR EVERYTHING YOU SAID
BUT I THINK I GOT ENOUGH OF IT.
TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION AT
LEAST THE LAST PART BUT I THINK
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT I WELCOME
THE OPPORTUNITY. TO ADDRESS
THIS THE IDEA ABOUT THE DOSES
THAT WOULD BE AVAILABLE YOU
KNOW A COUPLE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE BEGINNING YES
SOME COMPANIES SAYING THAT IN A
COUPLE OF YEARS HERE TO LET.
MANY WINDOWS. I THINK MOST
RAISE THEIR EYEBROWS AND THINK
THAT HOW IS THAT GONNA HAPPEN
AND IT IS BECAUSE THINGS ARE
BEING DONE AT RISK BOTH
COMPANIES. TO COME. TO MAKE
DOSES EVEN BEFORE YOU KNOW THE
VACCINE WORKS. SO THE RISK OF
THE SPEED IS NOT RISK TO SAFETY
IS NOT RISK. TO SCIENTIFIC
INTEGRITY IS RISK THE MONEY. SO
PUT THAT ASIDE. THE POINT THAT.
AT THE CONCLUSION OF THE MAID.
I THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT. WE
NEED TO BE CAREFUL. THAT WE
DON'T JUMP BECAUSE OF ARE
NEEDED TO GET VACCINES FOR
THOSE WHO NEED IT. THAT WE DO
NOT DEFINITIVELY PROVE SAFETY
AND EFFICACY BEFORE WE MAKE
DECISIONS ABOUT DISTRIBUTION.
WE'VE HEARD A LOT ABOUT
EMERGENCY AUTHORIZATION
EMERGENCY USE AUTHORIZATION IS
IMPORTANT. BUT IT HAS TO BE
DONE IN A SITUATION WHERE YOU
FULFILL THE CRITERIA. FOR THE
MERCHANTS USE AUTHORIZATION I
WOULD BE VERY DISAPPOINTED IF
WE JUMP TO A CONCLUSION. BEFORE
WE KNEW THAT A VACCINE WAS
TRULY SAFE. AND TRULY EFFECTIVE
BECAUSE I WOULDN'T WANT TO
PERPETUATE AND BEGIN. OF NOT
NOT. IS TRULY SAFE AND TRULY
EFFECTIVE THAT'S THE REASON WHY
WE'RE DOING SEVERAL RANDOMIZED
PLACEBO CONTROLLED TRIALS WITH
POWER ENOUGH THAT COULD GIVE US
THAT ANSWER. I HOPE THAT
ANSWERS YOUR QUESTION FRED.
JUST ONE QUICK WOULD BE THE
EARLIEST YOU THINK UNDER
SCENARIO THAT WE MIGHT. YOU'LL
SEE IN YOUR WAY IF YOU BACK YOU
ARE A LONG WAYS I GUESS
CORRECTLY B. YES THE EIGHT
RIGHT CORRECT. THREE ISSUE THAT
THAT. YES THE ANSWER IS YES LET
ME JUST QUICKLY ANSWER THAT
HANDED OVER TO TUESDAY BECAUSE
HE MAY WANT TO ANSWER THAT
WE'RE GOING INTO THE FIRST
PHASE ONE PHASE THREE EFFICACY
TRIAL IN JULY. IT TAKES AT
LEAST A MONTH TO GET TO THE
SECOND DOES BECAUSE IT'S A
PRIME BOOST YOU'LL TAKE ANOTHER
COUPLE OF MONTHS TO CREW OR IN
ROLL. ENOUGH PEOPLE THAT IF
THERE IS VIRAL ACTIVITY IN THE
COMMUNITY AND WE HAVE OUR
SIGHTS NOT ONLY IN THE UNITED
STATES BUT ALL OVER THE WORLD
IN BRAZIL AND SOUTH AFRICA. SO
IF WE GET AN EFFICACY SIGNAL
YOU'RE GONNA GET A DISEASE.
MORE QUICKLY THE MORE CASE
THERE ARE NO DOUBT THAT NOT THE
CASE TAKE LONGER AND THAT'S THE
REASON WHY YOU CAN'T. DO IT
DICK. OF GONNA GET THOSE DATES
STEVE YOU WANT TAKE IT HERE.
YES ON SEVEN TECH FOUND. SO
JUST THE OF ISSUES TO YOUR
POINT CONSTANT ON ONE IS WE ARE
ON. WE ARE WORKING WITH
SPONSORS ACROSS THE BOARD
PRIVATE INDUSTRY OPERATION
SPEED XCERRA THOSE WHO ARE
DEVELOPING VACCINES AND WE'RE
PROVIDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
REGARDING CLINICAL TRIAL DESIGN
THE NUMBER OF PARTICIPANTS IN
CLINICAL TRIALS. AS WELL AS THE
END POINTS THAT WE WANT TO SEE
TO MAKE EDUCATION ABOUT SAFETY
AND EFFECTIVENESS AND I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE WITH DOCTOR THOUGHT
SHE SAID AND THAT IS. HE THE
CELEBRATION IS REALLY AROUND
TAKING FINANCIAL RISK- AROUND
THE DEVELOPMENT PROCESS
EXHILARATION IS NOT CUTTING
CORNERS WITH RESPECT TO THE
ASSESSMENT OF SAFETY AND
EFFECTIVENESS. AMERICAN PEOPLE
CAN RELY UPON THE FACT THAT FDA
HAS MANY EXPERTS IN THE VACCINE
YEAH YOU'VE BEEN DOING THIS FOR
YEARS AND WILL RELY UPON THE
SCIENCE AND DATA WHEN IT'S
AVAILABLE TO IS. MAKE THAT. THE
REGARDING A- PRE THAT'S WHEN
THAT WILL HAVE. THANK YOU FOR
YOU FRED NEXT WE HAVE
GENTLEWOMAN FROM CAL MS ISSUES.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN ON
MORNING NUMBER. I'D LIKE TO
START WITH DOCTOR. DR MEDIA AND
EIGHT NUMBER SINCE WE- AND- I
EXPRESS YOU LOVE MY- LIVES
ARRANGEMENTS ARE. ABOUT THEM
STC DIRECT OF THE MOST
PRESTIGIOUS INSTITUTIONS IN THE
WORLD. ELECTIONS DISEASES
PREVENTION. ELECTIONS TODAY.
ONE IS NUMBER ONE NOTN THE
WORLD. IN ELECTIONS AND THEN
WHAT'S. ANYTHING ANY. YEAH
EMERICA PEOPLE ARE IN PAIN.
THERE'S GREAT DEALS. PLEASE
THERE'S- R. BECAUSE FOR MANY
REASONS AND I URGED YOU. AS
HEAD OF C. D. G. TO SPEAK
DIRECTLY TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
I KNOW THE AGENCIES ARE TALKING
TO EACH OTHER I CONSIDER THAT A
WHISPER BECAUSE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ARE NOT HEARING YOU
SPEAK OUT. THEY DESERVE TO HEAR
THE TRUTH WE HAVE HEARD DR
BELCHING EACH TIME AND TIME
AGAIN PUTTING OUT INFORMATION
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE. THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE INVITED ON
THIS ISSUE OF THE OF THE VIRUS
IMAGINE THAT SO I CONTINUE TO
URGE YOU TO SPEAK OUT YOUR
DOCTOR WHAT YOUR WHITE JACKET
ON AND STATE WEEKLY AMERICAN
BASEBALL THEY WANT TO KNOW. HOW
MANY WHAT IS. MY KIDS ASKED ME
ON A CONCERT BASIS WHAT'S NEXT
WHAT IS OUR GOVERNMENT DOING
THAT'S A HAUNTING QUESTION AND
SO WHILE WE'RE DOING THE NICE
BACK AND FORTH THIS MORNING
GOOD QUESTIONS ON THE PART OF
MEMBERS. ON I REALLY REMAIN
DISMAYED AT THE ARE DEEPLY
DISAPPOINTED WE NEED LEADERSHIP
COME OUT OF THE CDC. REAL
LEADERSHIP. IT WAS AN OUTRAGE
THERE WAS A GATHERING IN TULSA.
SIX OF THE PRESIDENT TO BE
IMPEACHED PEOPLE WERE INFECTED
AND IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THE
TWO SECRET SERVICE AGENTS WERE
HOW CAN THE CDC A WHY OUT OF
THIS THIS CAN DAMAGE THIS
VIRUS. TO BE SOMETHING
POLITICAL YOU HAVE TO PUSH BACK
YOU'RE A SCIENTIST YOUR DOCTOR
THAT THE DOCTOR HON I'M SURE
YOU READ THE SEVERAL ARTICLES
REGARDING- I DROPPED THE CLERK
WHEN EVERY STUDY STATES IT
DOESN'T WORK IN ANY SETTING IN
FACT IT HAS KNOWN US. ON
CARDIAC HE'S THE ONE SO THE A
DANGER IN TERMS OF THIS EFFECTS.
S. NEWS THE ALL THE DAY. ARE
YOU GOING TO INFORM THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE DOCTORS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY ABOUT THESE FACTS.
THANK YOU CONCERN FOR THE
QUESTION AND INDEED WE ARE I
CAN REFER THE COMMITTEE TO
SEVERAL DOCUMENTS THAT WE HAVE
PUT OUT OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
WEEKS REGARDING HYDROXY CLERK
WHEN. WITH RESPECT TO THE
ISSUES WE SHOULD A SAFETY ALERT
PARTICULAR AROUND THE
COMBINATION OF KENTUCKY CLERK
WITHIN OTHER DRUGS THAT MIGHT
AFFECT THE HEART ON AND AS YOU
KNOW WE'VE TAKEN IT REASONS
RECENT ACTION REGARDING. WAY
WHAT THE ZIP THE- DIRECTLY TO
YOUR- PEOPLE SO ISN'T THIS. JAN
HOW TO DROP YOUR CAR. YES
MA'AM- THERE IS A NIFTY VOICES
PIECE THAT'S OFFERED BY ME AS
WELL AS A PIECE THAT'S DIRECTLY
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ABOUT
THE STATUS OF YOUR CREATOR I
WANT TO KNOW IF YOU HAVE STATE
AGAIN SPOKEN OUT VERBALLY. VP
THE DOG ACROSS THE COUNTRY. I
DON'T. HERE HEY MARK WITH ALL
DUE RESPECT YES MA'AM AND I
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION BUT-
EVERY OPPORTUNITY I'VE HAD TO
BE IN THE MEDIA I'VE BEEN ASKED
THAT QUESTION AND I HAVE
COMMUNICATED THAT SAME
INFORMATION ABOUT. GRETCHEN ON
THERE BEEN SEVERAL DAYS.
ARTICLES EXPRESSING CONCERNS.
OVER PRESS FREEDOM PLACED EFTA
OUT BY THE- STATE UNEQUIVOCALLY.
ANY POLITICAL PRESSURE IS
APPLIED DO YOU AND YOUR DATE.
IN LATE REPORT THAT JUSTICE
COMMITTEE. I WILL CERTAINLY ON
QUICKLY STATED IF I RECEIVE
POLITICAL PRESSURE REPORT THIS
COMMITTEE I CAN TELL YOU THAT I
HAVE NOT FELT POLITICAL
PRESSURE NOR HAS THE FDA TO
MAKE ANY DECISION IN ANY
SPECIFIC DIRECTION. THANK YOU
NOT ABOUT IT'S ABOUT A DIRECT.
A POLITICAL PRESSURES SO ON
THANK YOU FOR YOUR RESPONSE.
BACK THANK YOU THIS ISSUE. NEXT
IS- MR ALLOWED A FROM A HIGH.
VIGOROUS CHAIRMAN AND- THANKS
TO OUR WITNESSES AND ALL THE
HARD WORK FOR YOU BEEN DOING
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL MONTHS
FOR NOMINEE UNITED STATES FOR
INDIVIDUALS FROM AROUND THE
WORLD REALLY APPRECIATED. THAT
FOX AFFECTED THOSE ARE MY
QUESTIONS WITH YOU. AND I KNOW
THAT OUR- LEADER- THIS WATERING
HAD BROUGHT SOME OF THIS UP
WOULD YOU FURTHER EXPLAIN HOW
AN INFECTED INDIVIDUAL.
DEVELOPS ANTIBODIES IN HOW LONG
THOSE ANTIBODIES REMAIN
EFFECTIVE IN FIGHTING OFF THE
VIRUS. IN ARE USING DIFFERENT
LEVELS OF ANTIBODIES AND PEOPLE
WHO HAVE BEEN INFECTED AND WHAT
THAT MEANS IN TERMS AND UNITY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
QUESTION CONGRESSMAN LATTA. SO
WE NEED TO START OFF BY SAYING.
THAT WE WANT TO ASSUME YOU'RE
DEALING WITH A ANYBODY TEST HAS
BEEN VALIDATED BY THE FDA- BY
THE NIH THAT'S IMPORTANT
BECAUSE A LOT OF THE CONFUSION
OUT THERE THERE ARE TESTS THAT
ARE NOT VALIDATED LET'S ASSUME.
A GOOD TEST. WHENEVER THE BODY
GETS CONFRONTED WITH THE VIRUS
AND RECOVERS- EVEN WHEN THEY
DON'T RECOVER THE BODY IS
STIMULATED TO MAKE ANTIBODIES.
IN GENERAL FOR VIRUSES THAT WE
HAVE A LOT OF EXPERIENCE WITH.
THOSE ANYBODY SERVE TO PROTECT
YOU AGAINST EXPOSURE AND
INFECTION AFTER YOU'RE EXPOSED
TO THE SAME VIRUS. SO THAT'S
WHAT WE CALL IMMUNOLOGICAL
MEMORY AND THESE PROTEINS
BLOCKED THE VIRUS. THE ONE
THING WE DO NOT KNOW YET. WITH
COVID NINETEEN. IS THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE TYPE
OF ANYBODY BECAUSE THE BEST
ANYBODY'S CALLED NEUTRALIZING
ANYBODY. NAMELY IF THIS WITH A
VIRUS AND THIS IS WHERE THE
VIRUS BINDS TO THE CELL THE NEW
JULY THE BODY WALK. IRIS ON THE
TO TELL THEIR ANYBODY'S AGAINST
OTHER PARTS OF THE VIRUS THAT
ARE CALLED BINDING ANTIBODIES
THEY DON'T NEED MUCH. SO YOU
GOTTA MAKE SURE YOU GET THE
RIGHT. THE SECOND THING IS WHAT
WE STILL DON'T KNOW IS WHAT THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
TIGHTER OF THE ANYBODY HIS NAME
THE LEVEL OF THE ANYBODY AND
THE DEGREE OF PROTECTION. THE
THIRTEEN WE DON'T KNOW IS HOW
LONG OR WHAT THE DIRECTION OF
THAT ANYBODY IS GOING TO BE
WE'RE GOING TO FIND THESE
THINGS OUT. AS WE STUDY THESE
INDIVIDUALS OVER MONTHS AND A
YEAR OR MORE BUT REMEMBER WE'RE
ONLY A FEW MONTHS INTO THIS. WE
NOTE TAKE ANYBODY B. AS WHITE
THAT THERE PROTECTED FOR SOME
PERIOD OF TIME. WE ARE KNOW HOW
LONG THAT WOULD BE. SO THE CLUB
I WAS GONNA ASK WHICH IS A
SUBTEXT DOES THAT MEAN IF
YOU'RE EXPOSING YOU OF ANYBODY
THAT. ACTIVE LIKE WE YOU ARE WE
DON'T KNOW HOW LONG YOU ARE
PROTECTED. DR REDFIELD. WHEN I
VACCINE TREATMENT IS THE- HOW
LONG WILL IT BE DISTRIBUTED TO
AMERICANS. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION. THIS GET IT'S A
CRITICAL ISSUE THAT IS
CURRENTLY. UNDER DISCUSSION
WITHIN THE TEAM- TO LOOK AT-
WHAT THE APPROPRIATE
PRIORITIZATION FOR DISTRIBUTION
IS I WANT TO JUST A COMMENT
THAT IT MAY BE VERY DEPENDENT
ON WHAT THE PRODUCT IS EACH OF
THESE VACCINE PRODUCTS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY BEING DEVELOPED. MAY
IN FACT HAVE DIFFERENTIAL-
UTILIZATION FOR DIFFERENT
POPULATIONS SO- ON THEIR WITH
THEIR- THEIR SERIOUS
CONSIDERATION TO TRY TO DEVELOP
THOSE PARTICIPATIONS AND IT'S
GOING TO BE IMPORTANT- TO
DEVELOP THEM DEPENDING ON THE
PRODUCT THAT. THEY'RE GOING TO
BE BUT TO. DR ON HAND THANKS.
THANKS FOR TAKING MY CALL SO ON
THURSDAY ON FRIDAY NIGHTS ON
SATURDAYS APPRECIATED. YEAH
THE- FTA- PROVIDING EMERGENCY
USE AUTHORIZATION FOR RUN DOES
APPEAR YOU EXPECTORANT VISION
THE FCAT ISSUE ANYMORE EASY
WAYS FOR POTENTIAL TREATMENTS
IN THE FALL. ARSON FOR
POTENTIAL THERAPIES THAT
ADDRESS SIR RIGHT YEAH YES SIR
SO- WE ARE WORKING VERY CLOSELY
WITH SPONSORS REGARDING- THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THERAPEUTICS
INCLUDING WITH OPERATION ONCE
HE'D HUNDRED AND THIRTY ONE
CLINICAL TRIALS ON GOING RIGHT
NOW- I ANTICIPATE THAT WE WILL
RECEIVE DATA. REGARDING A OF
SEVERAL THERAPIES IN THE TWO
PLASMA DEAN ONE OF THEM BUT WE
JUST DISCUSSED WITH CONGRESS
WOMAN A POTENTIALLY ALSO WITH-
SOME- ANTI INFLAMMATORY AGENTS
AS WELL AS- FOR MONOCLONAL
ANTIBODIES- ON POST THOSE ARE
BEING ACCELERATED THROUGH THE
PIPELINE ON THE- THERAPEUTICS
AS WELL AS PROPHYLAXIS AND
LOOKING FOR. AGAIN K. JUDGE YOU
A PROPER BECAUSE WE HAVE TO SEE
THE DATA BUT I DO ANTICIPATE
THAT WE WILL BE RECEIVING DATA.
THE SHARE PRICE START ARE YOU.
THANK OUR NEXT WE HAVE MINS TO
GET FROM CALL. THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN I WANT TO
THANK THE PANEL AND WELCOME ALL
OF YOU AND IF YOU'VE HEARD
EVERY PART OF MY STOP COMMITTEE
THE OVERSIGHT INVESTIGATION
SUBCOMMITTEE A NUMBER OF TIMES
AND JUST TO LET YOU KNOW THE
AISLE AND I SAID COMMITTEE IS
GOING TO BE CONTINUED ITS
INVESTIGATIONS WELL HOW.
RESPONDED TO THIS WE'RE GO IN
THE FUTURE SO YOU CAN EXPECT TO
HEAR FROM US I WOULD HAVE SOME
BRIEF QUESTIONS FOR EACH
WITNESS AND I'D LIKE TO START
WITH YOU AND MARK GERARD. ON
THE CHECK AND TALK. HIS
COMMENTS. LAST WEEK. STATING
THAT THAT. SIX ARE THE DOUBLE
TESTED BECAUSE WHEN YOU DO A
QUOTE CALLING TO FIND MORE
PEOPLE AND THEN AGAIN THIS ART
PRESIDENT IN CASE. US YES WE'RE
TEST FAR MORE THAN ANY OTHER
COUNTRY AND OTHERS AND IT WAS
SMALLER THAN WE STOP FURTHER
CASES THIS IS WHAT HE SAYS AND
HE ALSO SAID THIS MORNING THAT
HE DOESN'T TALK ABOUT. SO IT
TURNS. OUT DR BRENT. IT STARTED
TO TEST LAST I WOULD ASK YOU
WHO YOU ARE NOW IN CHARGE OF
OVERSEEING THE TEST HAS THE
PRESIDENT ASKING YOU TO DO
FEWER TASKS. THANK YOU AND
AGAIN I WANT TO CLARIFY THAT
YOU DESERVE. WORK YESTERDAY
WOULD WORK AT. THIS PRESIDENT
HAS NOT NEITHER THE PRESIDENT
NOR ANYONE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS INSTRUCTED
OR SUGGESTED THAT WE SHOULD DO
LESS TESTING HAVE SAID THAT TO
ME AND WE ARE PROCEEDING IN
JUST THE OPPOSITE WE WANT TO DO
MORE OKAY. OF HIGHER QUALITY.
SO I WANT TO ASK YOU AT ROLL
YOU THINK THAT IT'S A- GOOD OR
A BAD IDEA TO DO LESS TESTING
SO IT WILL LOOK LIKE. YOUR
CASES. MY PURPOSE MY PURPOSE IN
LEADING IS TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF TESTING THE ONLY WAY
THAT WE WILL BE ABLE TO
UNDERSTAND WHO HAS THE DISEASE.
WHO IS INFECTED AND CAN PASS IT
TO DO APPROPRIATE CONTACT
TRACING IS TO TEST
APPROPRIATELY SMARTLY IN AS
MANY PEOPLE AS WE CAN. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. G. I WANTED TO ASK
YOU SEEN SOME DATA THE LAST FEW
DAYS THAT- THAT WHILE CASES ARE
GROWING UP. IN THIS COUNTRY
GASSER GROWING DOWN AND- I'VE
SEEN SOME REPORTS ON THE END
MEDIA THAT IN PART THAT'S
BECAUSE YOUNGER PEOPLE TEND TO
NOT TO DIE FROM COVID. ARE ARE
THE ONES BEING EFFECTED SHOULD
WE SEE THIS AS A POSITIVE SIGN
OR SHOULD WE STILL BE WORKING.
I THINK IT'S TOO EARLY TO MAKE
THAT KIND OF LINK CONGRESS
WOMAN LET ME EXPLAIN. DEATHS
ALWAYS LAG CONSIDERABLY BEHIND
CASES YOU MIGHT REMEMBER AT THE
TIME THAT NEW YORK WAS IN THEIR
WORST SITUATION. WHERE THE
DEATHS WILL GOING UP AND YET
THE CASES WAS STARTING TO GO
DOWN THE DEATHS ONLY CAME DOWN
MULTIPLE WEEKS LATER. SO YOU'RE
SEEING MORE CASES NOW WHILE THE
DEATHS ARE GOING DOWN THE
CONCERN IS IF THOSE CASES THEN
INFECT PEOPLE WHO WIND UP
GETTING SICK AND GO TO THE
HOSPITAL. IT IS CONCEIVABLE YOU
MAY SEE THE DEATHS GOING UP SO
I THINK IT'S TOO EARLY TO SAY
BECAUSE DEATHS ARE GOING TO.
THANK YOU. THE DOCTOR PATCH YOU
THROUGH TO WE'VE SEEN AND I AND
I THINK YOU AND I HAVE TALKED
ABOUT THIS MOST VACCINES TAKE
YEARS IF NOT DECADES TO BE
APPROVED AND IT ENDED PROVE
THEY PROVED EFFICACIOUS AND
SOMETIMES WE DON'T FIND A
VACCINE AT ALL I HAVE TWO
QUESTIONS FOR YOU NUMBER ONE DO
YOU BELIEVE THAT WE WILL FIND A
VACCINE FOR THE CORONAVIRUS AND
NUMBER DO. YOU STILL STAND BY
V. PREDICTION YOU GAVE US SOME
MONTHS AGO THAT WE COULD
ACTUALLY HAVE A VACCINE BY
EARLY TWENTY TWENTY ONE. I
BECAUSE OPTIMISTIC WOMAN THAT
WE WILL BE SUCCESSFUL. IN
GETTING A VACCINE THERE'S NEVER
A GUARANTEE OF THAT BUT THE
EARLY DATA THAT WERE SEEN
REGARDING THE IMMUNOGENICITY
AND THE INDUCTION OF GOOD
RESPONSES. MAKES ME CAUTIOUSLY
OPTIMISTIC ALWAYS KNOWING THAT
THERE'S NEVER A GUARANTEE YOU
REMEMBER I TOLD YOUR COMMITTEE.
A FEW MONTHS AGO. VACCINE WOULD
BE AVAILABLE FROM A YEAR TO
EIGHTEEN MONTHS I SAID THAT IN
JANUARY. OF TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY TWENTY A YEAR FROM
JANUARY IS DECEMBER I STILL
THINK THERE IS A REASONABLY
GOOD CHANCE THAT BY THE VERY
BEGINNING OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
THAT IF WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A
VACCINE THAT WE WILL HAVE IT BY
THEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DARKER ON MISTER CHAIRMAN IDEA
BACK. THANK THE GENTLEMAN NEXT
WE HAVE MRS ROGERS FROM
WASHINGTON STATE. I HOPE. I'M
NOT THE WORST ACTORS THIS YEAR.
MY HERE RECOGNIZED FOR FIVE
MINUTES. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
I WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR AND
THE RANKING MEMBER FOR HOLDING
THIS HEARING AND APPRECIATE OUR
WITNESSES FOR TESTIFYING TODAY
ON COVID NINETEEN IS THE
CHALLENGE OF THIS CENTURY AS I
HAVE SAID IT'S A HELP AT THE
MOMENT THIS IS ABOUT ICE TIME.
WE OF. OVER A HUNDRED THOUSAND
AMERICANS AND WE MUST REMEMBER
THAT WE'RE NOT OUT OF THE WOODS
YET. I WANT TO ESPECIALLY
EXPRESS MY HEARTFELT GRATITUDE
FOR HEALTH CARE WORKERS THE
FIRST RESPONDERS THE EMERGENCY
AND ESSENTIAL WORKERS. WHO HAVE
BEEN WORKING AROUND THE CLOCK
THE FACT VIRUS SAVE LIVES AND
KEEP OUR FAMILY SAFE. S. R. S.
WORK TIRELESSLY TO DEVELOP A
VACCINE AND TREATMENT I'M
CONFIDENT THAT THERE'S NO
COUNTRY IN THE WORLD IS BETTER
EQUIPPED. TO LEAD FOR A MEDICAL
BREAKTHROUGH THEN AMERICA. WE
CAN'T TRUST CHINA THE WEEK AND
THAT'S WHAT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION HAS CREATED
PROGRAMS LIKE OPERATION WARP
SPEED WILL BRING TOGETHER. THE
BEST. WHAT TO DO. COUNTER
MEASURES UP FIGHT THE- WE'RE-
THE OF ARTIFICIAL. SUPER
COMPUTING MACHINE LEARNING TO
SPEED UP DISCOVERIES AND
ENHANCE OUR KNOWLEDGE BASE OF
THE VIRUS. IN WASHINGTON STATE
WE HAVE RESEARCHERS WELL AS
BIOTECH PHARMACEUTICAL
INNOVATORS WILL CONTINUE TO BE
AT THE FOREFRONT OF THESE
GROUPS. LOOK FORWARD TO LEARN.
AND APPRECIATE ALL OF YOU BEING
HERE. TWO AND WHAT IT MEANT IS
CONTINUING TO DO TO LEAD ON THE
OF TESTS AND TREATMENTS THAT
AMERICAN NEEDS SO THAT WE CAN
USHER IN A NEW ERA OF
INNOVATION AND HELP. HERE'S TO
WHEN THE FUTURE KEEP OUR
FAMILIES HEALTHY AND SAFE
LIVES. AND TO ENSURE OUR
ECONOMY BOOMS AGAIN WE MUST GET
THIS RIGHT. DR SAL G. AS YOU
KNOW ADJUVANTS MAXIMIZE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF VACCINES WOULD
YOU JUST EXPLAIN A LITTLE BIT
FURTHER WHAT AN ADJUVANT IS AND
ARE THERE ANY NOVEL SYNTHETIC
ADJUVANTS IN THE PIPELINE AND
IF SO HOW WILL THEY PLAY A ROLE
IN THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PURSUIT. OF A COVID NINETEEN
VACCINE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THAT QUESTION CONCERN AND
ADJUVANTS IS A PRODUCT DISTINCT
FROM THE VACCINE ITSELF. BUT
WHEN GIVEN IN CONJUNCTION WITH
THE VACCINE IT ENHCES THE
POWER OF THE IMMUNE RESPONSE SO
IF YOU HAVE. A VACCINE THAT
GIVES A LEVEL OF RESPONSE THAT
HERE. WHEN YOU GET AN ADJUVANT
TOGETHER WITH IT YOU OFTEN
BOOSTED TO A MUCH HIGHER LEVEL.
WE USE ADJUVANTS IN SEVERAL
VACCINES THE N. I. H. AS A
MAJOR PROGRAM. IN THE PURSUIT
AND DEVELOPMENT OF NOVEL
ADJUVANTS OF ALL DIFFERENT
TYPES AND IN FACT THAT'S PART
OF THE PROGRAM RIGHT NOW. TO
ACCELERATE ON VACCINE
DEVELOPMENT CAPABILITY SO IT'S
A GOOD QUESTION BUT IT'S A VERY
IMPORTANT PART OF WHAT WE DO.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR THAT I DR HAUNTED YOU KNOW
FDA'S DECENTRALIZATION OF
DIAGNOSTIC TEST OVERSIGHT IS
BEEN VERY HELPFUL IN EXPANDING
THAT BILL. BUT NOT FOR COVID
NINETEEN TEMPER. HAS THIS WHAT
WOULD YOU SPEAK TO HOW THIS
FLEXIBILITY HAS BENEFITED THE
GENERAL PUBLIC AND HOW YOU
THINK IT WOULD BE HELPFUL IN
THE FUTURE FOR OUTBREAKS OR
NOVEL VIRUSES. THANK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH COUNCIL APPRECIATE
THE QUESTION- AS YOU POINTED
OUT THE FLEXIBILITIES HAVE
ALLOWED US TO WORK WITH TEST
DEVELOPERS THIS IS HAS BEEN
THROUGHOUT THE COOK COVID
PANDEMIC WITH ALL OF OUR
MEDICAL PRODUCTS A BALANCE
BETWEEN THE OVERSIGHT SO THAT
WE HAVE TESTS THAT ARE VALID
REPRODUCIBLE ACCURATE BUT AT
THE SAME TIME ALLOWED
DEVELOPERS THE ABILITY TO HAVE
THE FREEDOM TO DEVELOP THOSE
TASKS. DEVELOP THIS SHIP THAT I
THINK HAS BEEN VERY FOR MOVING
FORWARD I PARTICULARLY LIKE IT
WITH RESPECT TO THE FLEXIBLE
GIVEN THE STATE YOUR DATE IN
PARTICULAR WHICH HAS AN
EXCELLENT- BUT PUBLIC
LABORATORIES AS- THOSE ARE THE
SORT OF THINGS THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT NOW. AS WE TALK
ABOUT HOW WE WANT TO MOVE
FORWARD THAT WE COULD
POTENTIALLY PUT IN PLACE ON A
PERMANENT BASIS TO FACILITATE
TESTED ON AND- HOPEFULLY WILL
NEVER BE IN A POSITION AGAIN
WHERE WE HAVE TO DEVELOP TEST
OVER SUCH A SHORT PERIOD OF
TIME. LIKE WE'VE REMARKABLY
DONE THIS TIME. I NEED TO TALK
ABOUT HOW THESE FLEX. COULD
STIMULATE INNOVATION AND
DEVELOPMENT ATTACKS. GREAT WELL
THANK YOU ALL THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP YOUR
COMMITMENT. DURING THIS TIME A
LONG HOURS AND I. THE WAY THAT
WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE PREPARED- IN
THE FUTURE WHATEVER WEAKNESSES
THANK YOU GOOD TO BE WITH.
THANK YOU. AND NOW WE GO TO
MISTER DOYLE COMING TO US FROM
PITTSBURGH. MR DOYLE. IS MR
DOERING SISTER CHAIRMAN ACT I
FORGOT ON MUTE THANK YOU YOU
HEAR ME NOW YES HE RECOGNIZED
FOR FIVE MINUTES. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN FOR HOLDING THIS
HEARING- AND THE RANKING MEMBER
ALSO WITH OUR WITNESSES
OPERATOR SERVICE ON BEHALF OF
THE AMERICAN. THIS COMMITTEE
HAS CONTINUED TO CONDUCT
OVERSIGHT OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION'S SHORTCOMINGS
RELATED TO PROCURING AND
DISTRIBUTING PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT OR PP.
WHEN STATE SOME HOSPITALS WERE
FACED WITH CRITICAL SHORTAGES
OF EP SUCH AS MASKS AND GOWNS
PRESIDENT TRUMP PASSED BY. THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WAS QUOTE
NOT A SHIP MARK. I WISH ALL THE
RESULT OF A FAILURE OF
LEADERSHIP WITHOUT A NATIONAL
EXPRESS. STATE'S A PATTERN AND
FOR THEMSELVES AND EVEN COMPETE
AGAINST EACH OTHER FOR ALL
SUPPLIES. IT'S BECOME DESPERATE
OUT THERE AT ONCE. THIS ASKED
HER INITIAL REPORTS AT THIS
GROUND WAS ON BOARD ON THE
FLIGHTS. WELL A LACK OF
CENTRALIZED COORDINATION AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL CREATED A
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE COMPETITION
BETWEEN THE STATES AND FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. TO SECURE LIMITED
SUPPLIES DRIVING UP PRICES AND
EXACERBATING EXISTING
SHORTAGES. AT WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING JUST YOU DO WE HAVE
ENOUGH. EACH FOR EVERY
FRONTLINE WORKER WHO NEEDS
WHETHER THEY BE HEALTH CARE
WORKERS FIRST RESPONDERS ARE
THOUSANDS OF OTHERS WHO JOB
WHAT'S AMID RISK FOR PEOPLE
STILL HAVING GOOD REVIEWS AND
NINETY FIVE MASS RIDGE. AND IF
WE DON'T ENOUGH WHAT YOU'RE
GREAT. OKAY GREAT WE- AND YOUR
FACTORING THE SUPPLIES. WELL
THANK YOU FOR THE IN A WILL DO
MY BEST THE THAT AT ROLL CALL
CHECK CERTAIN RUNNINGS CHAIN
WITH WITH ALSO DR KADLEC FROM
ASPER BUT BEING A MEMBER OF THE
UNIFOR UNIFIED COORDINATION
GROUP THAT'S IF PASSED. I'M
PRETTY FAMILIAR WITH THIS- I
THINK IS THAT MOBILE OBJECT
TESTIFIED BEFORE AND I THINK WE
ALL KNOW IS THAT- THERE WAS AN
ABSOLUTE SHORTAGE OF EVERYTHING
WHEN THIS STARTED. ON EVERYONE
IN THE WORLD WAS LOOKING FOR
THE SAME A SUPPLIES AND WE TRY
TO MANAGE AT. BOTH FROM
INCREASE THE SUPPLY IN USING
THE DPA MULTIPLE TIMES. ON FOR
A COUPLE ON THE RISK FREE
THAT'S MINS DEEP TITLE ONE. FOR
AND NINETY FIVE M. HONEYWELL IN
OWENS AND MINOR. ON TWO IN
ACTION. ESTIMATE THAT THAT THE
COUNTRY IN THE FALL IF THERE
WERE A COVID OUTBREAK DEGREE
WOULD NEED ABOUT A HOT. FORTY
NINE HUNDRED FORTY MILLION.
FIVE PER MONTH. ON WE SHOULD.
HUNDRED EIGHTEEN. OUR MARKET.
DEMAND BY THAT TIME IS WITH NOT
AVAILABLE WHEN THE STORE IN MY
THE- WAS HERE. THIS WAS ALL
OFFICER. AND I'LL JUST SAY.
BETWEEN MORE. FIRST IN JUNE
NINETEEN. THE GOVERNMENT
DISTRIBUTED OR ARE ENABLED THE
COMMERCIAL DISTRIBUTION THROUGH
THE AIR BRIDGE OF A HUNDRED AND
SIXTY MILLION AND NINETY FIVE
MASS SIX HUNDRED AND THIRTY
EIGHT MILLION SURGICAL AND
PROCEDURAL MASS. TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY ONE MILLION GALLONS IN
OVER SIXTEEN BILLION PAIRS OF
GLOVES SO THIS WAS REALLY AN
ENORMOUS EFFORT WE NEED TO BE
BETTER PREPARED ALL NEEDS TO BE
ON SHORE. WERE WORKING BUT US
AND ASKED POINT OUT FOR SIX IN
NINETY DAY SUPPLY. A WE TALK TO
ALL GOVERNORS IN EVERY STATE
MANY OF THE STATES ARE ALSO
DOING THEIR OWN SUPPLIES FOR
SIXTY TO NINETY DAYS SO I'M
CONFERENCE BEING ON HERE ON
ONE. AT THE MASS THE FACT.
WE'RE GOING TO MARCH THIS IS WE
WORK MONTHS AGO. THANK YOU
OUTGROW OUR DOCTOR LET ME ASK
YOU TO ME PURPOSE. YES THIS. I
SEEN MANY ACTOR WITH LITTLE
PREVIOUS SIX ON THIS. OF I FEEL
ENTER THE MARKS ARE RECORDS
INDICATE THAT THIS. IT DON'T
TAKE THE RISK. ON A TO WHAT
REMAINS I WHAT'S THE IS THE
EIGHT ONE SHORT THE COMP ARE
NOT CERTAIN. FEDERAL OVERSIGHT
AND INJECTING ACTUALLY STOP VP
IN THE UNITED STATES. I THANK
CONGRESSMAN THIS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT ISSUE- DURING THE
HEIGHT OF THIS EPIDEMIC AND THE
INCREASED DEMAND A WE PROVIDED
REGULATORY FLEXIBILITY FOR
COMPANIES BUT INSISTED THAT
THEY PROVIDE CERTAIN CATION
OFFICE. R. N. STA HE WILL SERVE
THAT THE PP MAX OTHER
REQUIREMENTS THAT THAT WE WHAT
WE HAVE IN PLACE AND THAT THE
FOREIGN GOVERNMENTS HAD FACED.
A BUT WE DID SOMETHING ELSE
WITH RESPECTED THAT IS ALSO
PART OF THE CDC. FOR EXAMPLE
WITHIN FIVES TO TEST TO VERIFY
THAT IN FACT THAT SELL THE
CATION OVER THE- E. ON THE
ADVOCACY THE PEOPLE. FACE AND
YOU'VE CORRECTLY IDENTIFIED
THAT FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS-
SUBSEQUENT PRODUCT THAT WAS
SHIPPED IN THE COUNTRY DID NOT
MEET THOSE SPECIFICATIONS WE
MEET. TOOK ACTION TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE ARE OFTEN THE MARKET.
YOU YOU. WANT TO REVERSE SWING.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN I SEE
MIKE IS EXPIRED YOUR BACK.
THANK YOU MR DOROUGH NEXT WE
HAVE A MISTER GUTHRIE COMING TO
US FROM KENTUCKY. ARE YOU MUTED
DO ON YOU. I THOUGHT I DID I
APOLOGIZE HYBRID GOT THREE
APOLOGIZE. I AM. DOCTOR ON
DOCTOR WHO I'M INTERESTED IN
THE IN THE COVID NINETEEN
COUNTERFEIT TESTING AND I HAVE
A BILL THAT WOULD BRING ON.
THANK ON EXACT THAT WOULD
ENSURE THAT THERE HAS THE
AUTHORITY TO DESTROY THE
COUNTERFEIT TESTING DEVICES NOW
FOLLOW UP WITH THE QUESTION.
WITH THIS ONE I'M INTERESTED IN
WHAT THE PEOPLE THAT I. TALK TO
EVERYDAY YOU'RE INTERESTED IN
IS WHAT'S GOING ON IN THE
FUTURE HOW WE'RE GOING TO
PROTECT OURSELVES MOVING
FORWARD. WE NEED LOOK. ON FROM
ASKED WHEN TO LOOK FOR END UP.
ON THE ON THE CEILING. ABOUT
DRAWN ARE. IN ALL THE PEOPLE
ECON THINGS. BUT IT ALL JUST GO
DR READING SAID AKHTER
FOUNDATION AND DR HANA SHE'LL
TALK ABOUT LEAD TESTING. AND
HOW THAT MIGHT BE AFFECTED.
WELL THE PEOPLE THAT I TALK TO
WANT TO WATCH A COUPLE WALK IN
MARCH. YOU MAY WANT TO GO ON
AUGUST OUR KIDS GOING TO BE
GETTING BACK IN SCHOOL OR
NURSING HOMES GOING TO BE STATE.
WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO READ.
DONALD ABSOLUTE. WE'LL HAVE CO.
WHAT'S THE- GONNA BE A DOCTOR
ABOUT YOUR DO WE NEED TO BE
LOOKED FOR A DOCTOR ON. TESTING
L. OPEN UP FOR YOU TO TALK
ABOUT. WHAT'S IT GOING TO LOOK
LIKE. IN OUR KIDS GOING TO BE
ABLE TO GO BACK TO SCHOOL.
THANK ON ALL STAR DOCTORATE.
THANK YOU CONGRESSMAN I THINK
FIRST FOREMOST. AND IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE CONTINUE TO
TAKE THIS TIME. TO CONTINUE TO
ACCELERATE OUR CAPACITY TO
DIAGNOSE. OBVIOUSLY VALUABLE
TIME WE TEST RESULTS- THAT
CAPACITY FOR. ISOLATION
TRACING. AND SONS BORN TEEN
THAT'S FUNDAMENTAL WE'RE
WORKING HARD TO DO THAT. AS I
MENTIONED NJ WE HAD ABOUT SIX
THOUSAND CONTACT TRACERS IN
THIS COUNTRY THE BEGINNING IN
JUNE IT WAS UP TO AROUND TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT THOUSAND.
CONTINUE TO INCREASE IN MY VIEW
A HUNDRED THOUSAND- TO GET THAT
OPERATIONALLY FUNCTIONAL THAT'S
GOING TO BE. CRITICAL FOR WHAT
WE'RE DOING SECONDLY WE DO HAVE
TO REINFORCE IN THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
SOCIAL DISTANCING.
INTERVENTIONS THAT WE'VE
DISCUSSED CRITICALLY FACE
COVERING- SIXTY DISTANCING AND
HAND WASHING- I ANTICIPATE THAT
THE STATE'S WILL. BEGIN THE
HIGHER EDUCATION AND TWELVE
IT'S GOING TO BE ON A
JURISDICTION TO JURISDICTION
DECISION A CDC WILL BE
SUFFICIENT IF YOU AN ADDITIONAL
GUIDANCE ON THIS. TOPIC IN IN
THE DAYS OF THE- AS WE CONTINUE
TO. WORK AND IT. OPEN UP THESE-
TYPICALLY THE SCHOOL SYSTEMS ON
THE OPEN THEM UP I WILL END
WITH. NURSING HOMES I THINK
WE'VE MADE ENORMOUS PROGRESS IN
THE LONG TERM CARE FACILITIES
ENHANCING INFECTION CONTROL-
AMAGER ARMY ONE MOMENT ABOUT
THE COMMITMENT THAT THEY'RE
SEEING A TO PROVIDE ALL NURSING
HOMES- PROTECTIVE. FOR A PERIOD
OF TIME. HAVE A GREAT DAY ONCE
IN THE NURSING HOMES ACROSS
THIS COUNTRY WERE WE RECOMMEND
THAT ALL RESIDENTS GET TESTED
SO THAT WE CAN START WITH. A
BASELINE OF UNDERSTANDING WHERE
THE EPIDEMIC IS I WILL JUST END
WITH THE FACT THAT ALTHOUGH
THEY ONLY MAKE UP POINT 6%
POPULATION. IN PRESIDENT MAY UP
MORE THAN 35% OF OUR MORTALITY.
LET ME SEE YOUR CURRENT THEY'LL
DOCTOR FAUCI YET LET ME BRIEFLY
ADDRESS THE QUESTION YOU ASKED
ABOUT SCHOOLS BECAUSE WE GET
ASKED THAT ALL THE TIME I THINK
THE IMPORTANT THING TO POINT
OUT. IS THAT AS YOU WELL KNOW
WE LIVE IN A VERY BIG COUNTRY
THAT IS CERTAINLY NOT A
UNIDIMENSIONAL COUNTRY IT'S
VERY VERY DIFFERENT WHAT BRENDA
NEW YORK METROPOLITAN AREA
CASPER WYOMING. WHEN YOU'RE
ASKING SCHOOL. YOU HAVE TO SAY
WHERE ON TALKING ABOUT. BECAUSE
WE HAVE DIFFERENT REGIONS
DIFFERENT STATES DIFFERENT
CITIES TOWNS AND COUNTIES. SO
SOME CALORIES MAY HAVE SUCH A
LOW LEVEL OF INFECTION. SCHOOLS
CAN OPEN IN A WAY THAT'S
EXACTLY LIKE NORMAL OTHERS MAY
BE IN A SITUATION WHERE IT
ISN'T REALLY BAD WE WANT TO
CLOSE THE SCHOOL. BUT YOU MIGHT
WANNA MAKE SOME MODIFICATIONS.
ALTERATIONS OF SCHEDULING
THINGS LIKE. A NEW ONE DAY OR
ANOTHER DAY. SO IT'S UP TO THE
LOCAL OFFICIALS TO EVALUATE.
WHERE YOU ALL. TO GIVE THE RE.
THE WRECK. WE REALLY VERY
CAREFUL PUT OUT ABOUT THE
GUIDANCE OPENING SCHOOLS SO YOU
DON'T WANT TO MAKE ONE SIZE
FITS ALL FOR THE UNITED STATES
YOU WANT TO TELL IT TO THE
DEGREE OF VIRAL DYNAMICS IN THE
PARTICULAR LOCATION THAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT. SO LOOKING
FORWARD. WE GET CLOSER TO THAT
POINT WE CAN MAKE THOSE
DECISIONS THAT'S THAT'S
UNFORTUNATE BUT OBVIOUSLY THIS
IS THE REALITY I'M ABOUT A CALM
DR HAN I'LL SUBMIT A QUESTION
FOR THE RECORD FOR POLL. FOR
POLL SAMPLING I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND I YIELD BACK. THANK
YOU MR GUTHRIE AT SOUND LIKE
THERE WAS A MONSTER THAT WAS
GOING TO ENVELOP YOU AT SOME
POINT THERE- YES WE HAVE OF
MICHIGAN HOUSE KEEP FROM
ILLINOIS. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
AND I WANT TO THANK THE
WITNESSES. ON I HAVE TO
DISAGREE WITH YOU DR REDFIELD I
THINK KNOW WHERE. HOUSE THE R.
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION'S GONNA
LACK OF LEADERSHIP BEEN MORE
APPARENT THAN IN OUR NATION'S
NURSING HOMES AND LONG TERM
CARE FACILITIES WHERE WE'VE
LOST FIFTY THOUSAND RESIDENTS
AND WORKERS. TOOK COVID
NINETEEN. SO LET'S REVIEW SOME
OF THE DEADLY FAILURES. YOUR
DELAYED COLLECTION ON. AND
DEATHS IN NURSING HOMES YOU
HAVE NOT REQUIRED REQUIRED
STATES TO CONDUCT TESTING. YOU
ARE- YOU ARE NOT GIVING WORKERS
ADEQUATE DEFEATED I AGREE WITH
FOX CONGRESSMAN DOYLE ON THAT-
TO PROTECT THEMSELVES YOU ARE
ALLOWING FACILITIES TO
LITERALLY KICK RESIDENTS OUT ON
OUT ON TO THE STREETS IF
THERE'S A MORE PROFITABLE
CALLED. PATIENT. WHITE I'M IN
MAN OF MINS TO ROLL WHO IS
BASED FOR THE OF OUR NURSE HOME
RIGHT. HAVE DECLINED GERMAN
LOANS INVITATIONS SPEAK- I WANT
MAYOR REFERRED THEM TO DR
REDFIELD'S ON THE CDC WEBSITE
EX EXPLAINS THAT YOUR MISSION
IS TO SAVE LIVES FIVE. UPCOMING
FIVE OUR IN FROM. THAT WOULD
TAX OUR NATION SO WHY DIDN'T
YOU REQUIRE NURSING HOMES TO
REPORT ANY DATA ON COVID
NINETEEN CASES AND DEATHS UNTIL
MAY FOUR MONTHS AFTER YOU MAY
REMEMBER YOU TOLD ME ABOUT THE
FIRST CASE ON ILLINOIS JANUARY
THIRTIETH. L. ON OUR TO RECORD
THAT THE KIDS ON HUMAN TO HUMAN
TRIALS ARE TRANSFER- I'M JULY
FOURTH ON JUNE FOURTH YOU-
TESTIFIED BEFORE THE HOUSE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE AND
APOLOGIZE FOR CDCS IN AT WHAT I
WROTE. RESPONSE TO COVID
NINETEEN RACE AND ETHNICITY.
DATA YEAH. THE SAME DAY. SYRIA
AND TO SEE FINALLY COVID
NINETEEN FROM NURSING HOMES AND
FAILED TO INCLUDE RACE AND
ETHNICITY INFORMATION SO WHEN-
WHEN MY OFFICE ASKED HIM OUT
ABOUT THE EXCLUSION WE WERE
TOLD- TO ASK THE CDC'S CELL
WILL YOU PROMISE TO INCLUDE.
THIS IS THE INFORMATION MOVING
FORWARD SO THAT WE CAN IDENTIFY
THE ADDRESS OF THE OF THE
ADDRESS THE RATE VERITIES IN
NURSING HOME ON COVID NINETEEN
CASES. THANK YOU CONGRESSMAN
FOR YOUR QUESTION- FIRST I WANT
TO STRESS THAT SINCE IN THE
EARLY BEGINNING OF THE
PANDEMIC- WE'VE- INITIALLY
ENCOURAGED ALL NURSING HOMES TO
REPORT THE CASES THROUGH THEIR
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS. AND THROUGH
OUR NATIONAL HEALTHCARE SAFETY
NETWORK AS OF MANY A- FACT THAT
IF I COULD JUST BRIEFLY DROPPED
ON THE WORLD TO ENCOURAGE. THAT
I THINK IT'S A PROBLEM THAT THE-
THERE'S BEEN KURTZ BUT WHAT
ABOUT. I'M AS I SAID THAT WAS
AS OF MAY NOW IT IS A REQUIRE
TO JUST BE REPORTED- IN IN
THROUGH CDC- AS A AS AS- WE ARE
WE TO MAKE COMPOUNDS TO INCLUDE
ETHNIC AND RIGHT FIELD AND
DATA- AS WELL AS A WOULD
ARGUED- PUT FORTH THAT WE
WORKED HARD TO REALLY
ACCELERATE. AT YOUR REACH I
MEAN IT IN SECTION CONTROL FOR
IN THESE NURSING HOMES TO TRY
TO MITIGATE THE SITUATION AND
UNFORTUNATELY WE DID
EXPERIMENTS IF POINT OUT WHERE
THERE'S NO RIGHT ANSWER TAKING
A HIGH BURDEN OF THIS INITIAL
OUTBREAK. CAN YOU DO WERE. IS
REPORTING THIS FROM IS TO BE
FOR FACE CDC FOR THE DATA TO
CMS CMS WILL FORWARD FACE IT SO
FAMILIES CAN MAKE DECISIONS
BASED UNDER ANY. ABOUT
DIFFERENT NURSING HOMES ARE
FORMING WE HAVE RECOMMENDED
THAT THE NURSING HOMES AS YOU
MENTIONED ON THE SCREEN ALL
RIGHT IT'S- AND WE RECOMMEND
THAT THEY SCREEN. WORKERS IN
THEIR HOMES. ON A WEEKLY BASIS
BECAUSE WE HAVE THIS IS AN AREA
AFTER DOING. AS A NATION TO
PROTECT FAX I'M INTERESTED IN
THIS KIND OF SUGGESTION
RECOMMEND. IT'S CLEARLY NOT.
BEEN UNLOCKED I FEEL THIS IS
THE VIEW OF MANY OBSERVE FAMILY
IS WERE. THAT THERE IS CRISIS
OUR NURSING HOMES. JUST AND THE
WEEKEND YES. THE GOVERNMENT OR
TO AND I YIELD BACK. THANK YOU
SHOULD HAS THE A MISTER ALSO
TECH. THIRTY CHAIRMAN WALDEN
LIT REPUBLICAN MEMBER GREG
WALDEN FOR HAVE THIS VERY
IMPORTANT HEARING WILL GO FOR
EXPERT WITNESSES Y'ALL BETTER
FRONT LINES FOR THE COVID
NINETEEN VIRUS FOR ABOUT HALF A
YEAR AGO WE GREATLY APPRECIATE
ALL YOUR EFFORTS TO MAKE OUR
COUNTRY SAFER. A SPECIAL HOW DO
YOU. OVER RISING MYSELF
COMMISSIONER HAHN. WELLS. FIRST
OF ALL ALL THE LITTLE TEXAS A
GREATER HOUSTON CONSIDER SPIKE
IN COVID NINETEEN CASES OVER
THE LAST WEEK. R. STAYS IT
STAYS THREE RE OPENING. THE
TREND IS NOT GOOD. THE DOCTOR
TOLD ME THOUGHTS HERE HOUSTON
OF TEXAS DOCTORS THREE HOTELS
HELLO TWITTER CORY SAID. IT
DIRECTORY PROCESS HOUSTON WILL
BE THE WORST AFFECTED SYRIAN
I'D STATE'S BABY ARRIVAL WE'RE
SEEING RIGHT NOW IN BRAZIL END
QUOTE. AND THAT IS SCARY. ONE
REASONS DUE TO KELLY. HIGHER
RISK K. WHICH THE CALENDAR
THIRD LARGEST TOWN IN AMERICA
IN THE COUNTY SEAT OF HARRIS
COUNTY WEBSITE HERE'S COMING
HOUSTON. THE FOURTH LARGEST
CITY. WITH A TURBO WHATEVER
GRAFTED FOR THE RECORD. ABOUT
THE BIG THE ESPORTS IN HOUSTON
AND HARRIS COUNTY REPORTER.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SO ORDERED.
BERG Q. THERE'S MANY FACTORS OR
HAVE THE SPARK RIGHT NOW IN
TEXAS IN HOUSTON. IT WOULD
SCARE ME THE MOST IS THE
INCREASE IN THE TAXES CASES.
WAVES. TWENTY THIRTY NINE THE
SO CALLED YOUNGSTERS. LAST WEEK
THERE WARNS BIRD FLU CASES IN
MY HOMETOWN OF SHOULD WHERE IN
MY ON CAMERA FOR BED IN THE
GREAT USER REGIONS. THIS IS
BECAUSE THE GRATITUDE. A
SEPARATE TWO MORE FORMER BOSS
PHIL GRAMM SAID THAT'S ABOUT
THESE PEOPLE HI HOW ARE YOU
THIS CRISIS. DURING THE COVID
NINETEEN CURVE EDITING THE
PANDEMIC IT'S LIKE GOING TO
HEAVEN. EVERYONE WANTS TO GO
THERE YOU WERE IF YOU WERE WHAT
DO THE HARD WORK TO MAKE IT
HAPPEN. OUR CALL THE BAD
ATTITUDE CURVE. AND DR FAUCI IF
YOU WERE A KID FOR A DAY HOW
QUICK CHANGE THIS BAD ATTITUDE
CURVES THAT MAKE THINGS PEOPLE
ADDRESSES ISSUE WITH BRICK IT
TRULY IS. WELL CONGRESSMAN YOU
BRING UP A VERY GOOD POINT ONE
OF THEM VERY PERPLEXING THINGS
ABOUT COVID NINETEEN AND KNIVES
AS SOME OF YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN
DEALING WITH VIRAL OUTBREAKS
FOR THE LAST. FORTY YEARS I'VE
NEVER SEEN A SINGLE VIRUS. THAT
IS ONE PATHOGEN HAVE A RANGE
FROM 2240% OF THE PEOPLE HAVE
NO SYMPTOMS. SOME GET MARCH
THIS. TWO AT HOME FOR A FEW
SOME ARE IN BED FOR WEEKS AND
HAVE SYMPTOMS EVEN AFTER THEY
RECOVER OTHERS GO TO THE
HOSPITAL SOME REQUIRE OF OXYGEN
SOME REQUIRE INTENSIVE CARE.
SOME GET INTEGRATED IN SOME DIE.
SO YOU HAVE A SITUATION THAT IS
VERY CONFUSING TO PEOPLE
BECAUSE SOME PEOPLE THINK IT'S
TRIVIAL IT DOESN'T BOTHER ME
WHO CARES. AND THAT'S ONE OF
THE REASONS WHY WHAT WE DO
HAVE. IS A LACK OF
APPRECIATION. THAT YOU HAVE A
DEEP RESPONSIBILITY. YOU HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO YOURSELF
BECAUSE I THINK THINKING THAT
YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE NO
DELETERIOUS CONSEQUENCES IS NOT
TRUE WE'RE SEEING MORE AND MORE
COMPLICATIONS IN YOUNG PEOPLE.
BUT EVEN THOUGH THE MAJORITY
THE OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF
THEM DO WELL. WHICH YOU CAN'T
FORGET. IS THAT IF YOU GET
INFECTED. AND SPREAD THE
INFECTION EVEN THOUGH YOU DO
NOT GET SICK. YOU ARE PART OF
THE PROCESS OF THE DYNAMICS OF
AN OUTBREAK. YOU MIGHT BE
PROPAGATING. INADVERTENTLY
PERHAPS INNOCENTLY IS INFECTING
SOMEONE WHO THEN INFECTS
SOMEONE WHO THAT IS SOMEONE WHO
IS VULNERABLE THAT COULD BE
YOUR GRANDMOTHER YOUR
GRANDFATHER YOUR SICK UNCLE
WHOM HAVE YOU WHO WARNS OF
DYING. SO IT'S A VERY DIFFICULT
MESSAGE PEOPLE SAY I'M YOUNG ON
HEALTHY WHO CARES. YOU SHOULD
CARE. NOT ONLY FOR YOURSELF BUT
FOR THE IMPACT YOU MIGHT HAVE
ON THE DYNAMICS OF THE OUTBREAK.
THE BRAND ATTITUDES ABOUT TIME
THEY REQUEST FOR THE RECORDS
FOR DR REDFIELD ABOUT HURRICANE
BACK TOWARDS THE COVID NINETEEN
PEOPLE FROM THERE SHE HOPES ARE
YOU BACK THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER OLSON NEXT WE
GO TO MR BUTTERFIELD FROM NORTH
CAROLINA. YOU MIGHT HAVE TO ON
MUTE SHE K. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN I MIGHT NOT. BE ABLE
TO DO IT. YES BUT DEATH THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND THANK
YOU TO ALL OF OUR WITNESSES
TODAY. MISTER CHAIRMAN IN
RESPONSE TO COVID NINETEEN
CONGRESS HAS APPROPRIATED
SIGNIFICANT FUNDING GROUP CARES
ACT. AND IT LOOKS LIKE SOME OF
THAT MONEY IS FINALLY GETTING
INTO UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES.
ON THE CONGRESSIONAL BLACK
CAUCUS HEALTH BRAINTRUST LEAD
BACKGROUND. HAS MET WITH SOME
OF YOU AND WE WOULD YOU.
FUNDING FOR NOW AND COMMUNITIES
TO FIGHT THE PANDEMIC. AFRO
SECRETARY. BOARDING THAT H. HAS
FORMED A PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
MOREHOUSE SCHOOL OF MEDICINE I
THAT'S GOOD. PARTNERSHIP TO
COORDINATE HD TV NETWORK
ORGANIZATIONS TO DELIVER COVID
NINETEEN RELATED INFORMATION
THE MINORITY COMMUNITIES
HARDEST HIT BY THE PANDEMIC.
DOES THE MOLD IS FUNDING GET
THE GOLD. TO ENGAGE IN
AGGRESSIVE CONTACT TRACING AND
OTHER TESTING AND EDUCATION WE
NEED MORE THAN INFORMATION.
WHAT IS THAT MANDATE. TWO THANK
COOK QUESTION SIR ARMED THE
INTENT OF THIS AWARD IS REALLY
TOO ON MY- HOUSE TO PHYSICALLY
CONTACT TRACING THEMSELVES BUT
TO BE A LEAD INSTITUTION TO
PARTNERSHIPS THROUGHOUT THE
NATION SO THAT PUBLIC HEALTH
ORGANIZATIONS ETCETERA CAN USE
THE WELL OVER. ELEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS AT THE CDC SENT OUT WE
ARE NOT **** MORE HOUSE
STEPPING THE BOOTS ON THE
GROUND RESISTING THE TO THE OF
THE OPERATION. BUT OUR WORK
THROUGHOUT. YEAH YES THANK YOU
THAT HAVE IS THE IS PRESS ARE
RESTRICTED. D. R. BE HAPPY TO
GET INTO THIS BUT THEY THEY
ASSEMBLED REALLY A REMARKABLE
GROUP OF PARTNERS USING DIGITAL
TECHNOLOGIES ARE ALL TYPES OF
NETWORK TECHNOLOGIES HAVE VERY
DISCRETION ON THIS IS THE OUT
OF MY OFFICE. WHAT I WANT. I
WANTED FOR THAT THE UNDER
SERVED GET THE INFORMATION GET
TESTING IS CLEARLY. THAT'S WHAT
I WANTED HERE BROUGHT THE
SPECIAL BACK ABOUT YOU WATCHING
POST REPORTED THIS MORNING THAT
ARIZONA IS SEEING A TROUBLING
SPIKE THE STATE OF ARIZONA AND
AS WE ALL KNOW PRESIDENT. EX
POINT GAP RIGHT. AND DREAMS
CHURCH AND I SUSPECT HE WILL
NOT BE WEARING A MASK I KNOW
THAT WILL DISAPPOINT YOU IT
STARTED TO SUPPORT ME. ON THE
WASHINGTON POST ALSO REPORTED
THAT ARIZONA GOT IT I RIGHT
DOWN TO SEVEN PERCENT. BUT NOW
IT IS UP 220% AFTER A THREE
WEEK RUN AT. IN MY STATE OF
NORTH CAROLINA WE GOT IT THAT
WAS SET. IN BALLET NORTH
CAROLINA IT'S UP 210% SO 10% IN
NORTH CAROLINA UP FROM SEVEN
AND 20% IN ARIZONA WHAT IS THE
ADMINISTRATION. SPECIFICALLY
DOING TO SLOW THE SPREAD IN
STATES LIKE ARIZONA AND NORTH
LADDER THAT ASKING. AS. IT I
AWAY FOR TESTING. WELCOME THE
THAT SPEAK OF ALL CLEARLY THAT
THERE ARE ADDITIONAL INFECTIONS
THAT ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR THOSE
INCREASES BECAUSE WHEN YOU GET
AN INCREASE IN THE PERCENTAGE
OF YOUR TESTS THAT ARE POSITIVE
THAT'S AN INDICATION THAT YOU
DO HAVE ADDITIONAL INFECTIONS
SO ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT BE
SPOKEN ABOUT AS VERY CLEAR IS
THAT WHEN YOU HAVE THOSE KINDS
OF INCREASES YOU MUST IMPLEMENT
ON THE GROUND. AS EFFECTIVELY
AS POSSIBLE THE MAIN POWER THE
SYSTEM THE TESTS TO
IDENTIFICATION ISOLATION AND
CONTACT RACE TO TRY AND BUILD
ON ITS URGES IS IN THE TWO
STATES THAT YOU'RE SPEAKING OF
HOW. THIS **** IT OF THOSE
CASES BECAUSE NOT THEN YOU HAVE
THE- I'M HAVING GRAD INST
INCREASE IN COMMUNITY SPREAD.
WHICH WOULD BE MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT TO CONTAIN AS THE
COMMUNITY SPREAD AMPLIFIES
ITSELF. BUT IT JUST SEEMS TO BE
A IN CLOSING ABOUT THE BELGIAN
YOU DON'T NEED TO RESPOND TO
THIS BUT IT SEEMS TO ME THAT
THE PRESIDENT SEEMS TO THINK
THAT CONGRESS IS OVER AND HE
CAN JUST PUSH IT ALL TO THE
STATES ON THE DATE THAT'S
COMING OUT OF THE STATE SHOWS
THE NECESSITY THAT ABSOLUTELY.
OKAY NATIONAL STRATEGY BECAUSE
WHILE THE BUYERS MAKE SAME
CONTAINED IN SOME AREAS IT IS
CONCEIVABLE THAT WE CAN SEE A
RESURGENCE EVERYWHERE THIS
FRIGHTENS MAKING SHOULD CRY AND
WE AMERICAN PEOPLE. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN I YIELD BACK. THANK
YOU BETTER. SIR NOW DOCTOR
BURGESS IS HERE AND- RECOGNIZE
HIM FOR FIVE MINUTES. THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN IN FACT THAT WAS WITH
YOU VIRTUALLY EARLIER SO I
HEARD ALL THE DISCUSSION BACK
AND FORTH AND I WOULD ASK
UNANIMOUS CONSENT. TO MY
OPENING STATEMENT BEFORE. I DO
WANNA THANK OUR- IDOLS FOR
BEING HERE TODAY OUTSIDE OF A-
TINY LITTLE WE TACKED ONTO A
BUDGET HEARING ON FEBRUARY
TWENTY SEVENTH WE REALLY HAVE
NOT HEARD. FROM THIS GROUP
ENOUGH HIM IN THIS COMMITTEE
AND CERTAINLY THE HEALTH
SUBCOMMITTEE SOLANA THANK YOU
FOR. YOU WILL NEED TO BE HERE
TODAY AND TESTIFY IT ALSO
OBSERVES THAT WE'RE ABOUT THE
ONE YEAR ANNIVERSARY OF THE
PASSAGE AND SIGNING OF THE
PANDEMIC HAZARD PREPAREDNESS
ACT WE HAD A WONDERFUL
OPPORTUNITY. IN JANUARY
FEBRUARY ABSOLUTELY MARCH OF
THIS YEAR DO SOME REAL TIME
INTROSPECTION WHETHER OR NOT
THAT BILL. HAD GOTTEN THINGS
RIGHT DID WE DO WHAT WE
PERFORMING AS INTENDED. WAS IT
GOING AS EXPECTED AND WHATEVER
REASON WE CHOSE TO TALK ABOUT
LANKFORD TOBACCO HORSE. AND
TICKET STUBS INSTEAD. SO WE
COULD THE- TO SHARMA BUT THIS
CAN DOES COMMITTEE BEAR FOR
THAT RESPONSE AS WELL. SINCE
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
COMMITTEE SPREAD AND INCREASE
IN COMMUNITY SPREAD I. ALSO AS
OUT TO YOU BEEN TALKING TO SOME
OF MY COUNTERPARTS PHYSICIANS
LOWER RIO GRANDE VALLEY AND
SPREAD HIM THAT PARKED NEAR THE
BORDER OF MEXICO COMMUNITY
SPREAD HAS BEEN APPARENTLY
SIGNIFICANT OVER THE LAST WEEK
TO TEN DAYS. I GUESS THE
QUESTION I WOULD HAVE FOR YOU
FOR YOU AND FOR ADULTS WHO ARE
IS. SINCE WE RECOGNIZE
COMMUNITY SPREAD IS INCREASING
AND WE RECOGNIZE THAT THEY'RE
STILL GOING TO BE THE
VULNERABILITIES OF CONGREGATE
LIVING FACILITIES WHAT ARE WE
DOING TO MAKE CERTAIN THAT THE
APPROPRIATE AMOUNT OF PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT IS
AVAILABLE. TO OUR CONGRESS. HIS
EXTEND. NOT JUST IN THE VALLEY
BUT ANY ANY PLACE WHERE WE SEE
THIS COMMUNITY SPREADER
INCREASING. SO ON. THANK YOU DR
BURGESS GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN
ON THAT AGAIN I AM FAMILIAR
WITH THE KEEP THE SITUATION
FROM MY WORK ON THE U. C. G. AT
FEMA. AND I THINK YOU I THINK
YOU KNOW THAT- IT WAS DECIDED
BY THE U. C. G. OF VERY EARLY.
THAT WHEN WE WERE ABLE TO
SECURE THE PP WOULD SENT
DIRECTLY TO EVERY AND WE'RE
SENDING TV DIRECTLY TO FIFTEEN
THOUSAND UP POLICE NUMBERS FOUR
HUNDRED. NURSING HOMES. IT'S IN
THE NUMBERS ARE REALLY
STAGGERING MILLIONS OF FACE
SHIELD. ON MASS THIRTEEN
MILLION PAIRS OF GLOVES ALREADY
THERE SO THAT'S BEING
DISTRIBUTED RIGHT NOW. AND
THEY'RE GONNA BE POSSIBLE
CHARGES OF THAT- AGAIN ADVIL
POLL OBJECT. IT'S THROUGH THE
PIPES. BURST DOWN ALL THIS. YOU
KEEP AND WE INTERACT ON SO
THAT'S GOING TO BE ALL WAY
THROUGH AND SEPTEMBER- THROUGH
ALL FIFTEEN THOUSAND FOUR
HUNDRED NURSING HOMES WITH
MULTIPLE SHIPMENTS OF THAT
WOULD YOU AGREE THAT THAT IS A-
ON NOT ON THE IMMEDIATE HORIZON
AHEAD THAT'S ONE OF THE BIG
VULNERABILITIES. UNITY
STRESSING AGAIN SOMEPLACE. ALSO
NO WE GOT AREAS. WHERE THIS
CONGREGATE LIVING. PEOPLE WITH
THE WITH WITH MULTIPLE RISK
FACTORS. SO ON I THINK IS.
MAYBE BEEN SET BY THE
COLLEAGUES WE ARE CLEARLY
SEEING COMMUNITY SPREAD- IN A
NUMBER OF AREAS IF YOU.
COUNTIES I THINK DOCTOR
BURKE'S- DETAILED YESTERDAY
THERE ABOUT A HUNDRED AND TEN
COUNTIES OF REAL CONCERNED
ABOUT IT WELL I GUESS FEDERAL
FOR YOU THREE FOR INTERRUPTING
BUT MY TIME IS SHORT. I GUESS
WHAT I'M ASKING. ARE WE PRETTY.
AND D. OUR ADMINISTRATORS AND
EXECUTIVES IN NURSING
FACILITIES NURSING HOME
FACILITIES. KNOW HOW TO ACCESS
VIA THE VAST AMOUNTS OF
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
IS BEING AVAILABLE THROUGH
BRIDGING BETWEEN THE WORK
YOU'VE DONE. BECAUSE IF WE
DON'T GET IT TO THE END USER.
THAT IT'S AVAILABILITY
INDEPENDENT WILL AFFECT ALL OF
US. VERY BRIEFLY BECAUSE I KNOW
THE TIME ON I UNDERSTOOD THE
ANSWER IS YES BECAUSE WE
DECIDED TO SHIP DOOR TO DOOR
BECAUSE WE COULDN'T NECESSARILY
RELY ON STATE DISTRIBUTION
SYSTEMS. YOU KNOW BECAUSE YOU
JUST CAN'T GET THAT DEEP BUT
THE ONLY WAY TO DO IT IS GET
THE ADDRESS AND SHIP IT. AND
THEN SECONDLY THAT. UP REGIMENS
THAT ARE NOW MANDATED TO CMS
RECOMMENDED BY CDC ARE A PRETTY
EXCELLENT REP EVERY NURSING
HOME RESIDENT GETS TESTED EVERY
WORKER GETS TESTED EVERY WEEK
THIS IS A VERY ROBUST ASKING
WELL REGIMENT. BUT FOR TAX
CERTAINTY HAS BEEN IN TEXAS
TECH RED FIELD IN JUST OVER
BRIEFING. MY HEAD REMAINING
DEAL BECAUSE. AND HER ABILITY
TO FIGHT THIS VIRUS. WHILE
WORKING IN THE CDC IN ATLANTA
WHO ARE CHINESE NATIONALS DO
YOU HAVE SUCH PEOPLE ON LOAN
FROM FROM CHINESE LABS EARLY IN
THE AGENCY. WELL I A CITY SHE
DOES HAVE AN OFFICE CDC HAS AN
OFFICE IN BEIJING THAT IS RIGHT
NEXT TO THE CHINA CDC AND WE
WORK COLLABORATIVELY. ON A
SERIES OF THINGS CRITICALLY
RESPIRATORY VIRUSES IN
PARTICULAR INFLUENZA- WE
HAVEN'T BEEN BROUGHT IN INTO
THE OVERALL CHINESE.
INVESTIGATION OF THIS CURRENT
CROWN A VIRUS EPIDEMIC THAT'S
SOMETHING I REQUESTED THE- BACK
END AND IN JANUARY THIRD AND
INFORMALLY ON JANUARY SIXTH. ON
I WANT TO BE HELPFUL TO YOU ON
THAT CELEBRA WILL FOLLOW UP
WITH YOU AND- I HAVE SOME IDEAS
OF SOME OF THE THINGS THAT YOU
MIGHT THINK ABOUT AS WELL
THAT'S A CRITICAL PART OF. OUR
DISCUSSION GOING FORWARD. TO
THE- THANK. THE THANKS WE'VE TO
MISS SUING CAL. THEY HAVE AND
ME I HAVEN'T IT THANK YOU MR
ONE TO ALSO THANK WITNESSES FOR
BEING HERE TODAY ON TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN YOU REALLY APPRECIATE IT
SOMEONE ON ONE OF OUR QUESTIONS
TODAY. ON FOCUS ON HOW TO BE.
IN THE MIDST OF THIS PANDEMIC
EIGHT I LIKE TO FOCUS MY PLACE
YOU JERK AND HOW WE ARE
PREPARING FOR THE COMING WEEKS
AND MONTHS ALSO THERE ANOTHER
EXCERPTS FROM. ARE SECOND
WAITING ARE J. LANKFORD STATE.
SHE LIVES SEE YOU THERE. YOU
HAVE SAID THAT WE ARE STILL THE
WAY THAT I UNDERSTOOD DIFFICULT.
WHAT IS WAY WOULD LOOK WHAT WAS
YOUR IN HIGH ACCOUNT ON LIKE A
COUNTS AGAINST. HOWEVER WE MUST
BE EFFECTIVE PREPARE OUR
COMMUTE. ARE HEALTH WORKFORCE
AND CONSTITUENTS FOR WHAT COULD
COME AS WE MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT
RETURNING TO WORK. GOING TO
SCHOOL AND TRYING TO REACH AS
TO WHAT WE ARE SOMEWHAT NORMAL
LIFE. SHE ON ONCE YOU PUT YOUR-
HI MASSACRED KAPLAN RIGHT NOW
WHAT ARE THE PROJECTED
INFECTION MORTALITY RATES THE
SECOND HALF OF TWENTY TWENTY
AND EARLY TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
COMES FROM AND IT IS REALLY
IMPOSSIBLE TO GET ANY
PROJECTION ABOUT WHAT THE
FATALITY RATE- CASE RATES ARE
GOING TO BE IT'S GOING TO
DEPEND ON SO MANY FACTORS I
THINK YOU ALLUDED TO THAT IN
THE BEGINNING OF YOUR QUESTION.
WHEN PEOPLE TALK ABOUT SECOND
WAVES AND I'VE SAID MULTIPLE
TIMES PUBLICLY THAT WE ARE
STILL IN THE MIDDLE OF FIRST
WAVE. SO BEFORE YOU START
TALKING ABOUT WHAT IS TAKING
WHAT IS WHAT WE'D LIKE TO DO.
SOUTH UNDER CONTROL THE NEXT
COUPLE OF MONTHS. SO THAT WHEN
WE ENTER INTO. THE FALL EARLY
LATE AND THEN EARLY WINTER.
THAT WE HAVE SUCH A LOW
BASELINE. THAT WHEN YOU DO HAVE
THE HABITABLE SITUATION OF
CASES APPEARING AS YOU TRY TO
GRADUALLY RE OPENED THE COUNTRY
WHICH WE'RE ALL TRYING TO DO.
TO VARYING DEGREES DEPENDING
UPON WHAT STATE CITY TOWN OR
COUNTY OR IN THAT IF YOU GET A
LEVEL THAT'S VERY LOW WHEN YOU
GET NEW CASES YOU CAN CONTAIN.
AND CONTAINING B. IS IDENTIFY
ISOLATED CONTACT TRACE RATHER
THAN HAVE SUCH A HIGH LEVEL
THAT WHEN YOU GET INCREASES YOU
HAVE TO MITIGATE RIGHT FROM THE
BEGINNING. SO THAT REALLY AS
YOU CAN IMAGINE COMPLICATES THE
SITUATION AND MAKES IT
IMPOSSIBLE TO PREDICT WHAT CASE
OKAY THE RATE IS GOING TO BE
UNTIL JUNE- WAY YOU WHY DO YOU
GET THAT TO BASELINE. AND IT
CAN YOU KEEP IT THERE. AS YOU
ARE IN COMPLICATING SITS IN BED
WOMAN. WHEN WE INTO THE WIND.
AND A- MOVE HAVE THIS SEASON
AND THAT'S THE REASON WHY WE
WERE SAYING ALL OF US. WHY IT'S
SO IMPORTANT TO REALLY GET AS
MANY PEOPLE VACCINATED WITH
INFLUENZA AS YOU POSSIBLY CAN
SO THAT YOU CAN AT LEAST TAKE
OFF THE TABLE FOR MANY PEOPLE.
ONE OF THE CONFOUNDING ISSUES
AND WE'RE GOING TO FACE THIS
WINTER OF TWO RESPIRATORY BORNE
INFECTIONS SIMULTANEOUSLY
CONFOUNDING EACH OTHER. NOW
WHAT WOULD YOU SAY DOCTOR DOWN
SHE- UNDERSTANDING THAT WE
DON'T KNOW YET BUT WE HAVE A
SENSE FAST. INSTANTLY WHAT THE
PUBLIC KNOWS SO THEY CAN BE.
THIS IS R. ONE. AS WE CAN ALSO
THE TRICK REGIS THAT. ON THIS
SECOND WAVE SOMEHOW ANOTHER
MANAGER'S BECAUSE I THINK THAT
ALL OF US BELIEVE SOMETHING IS
GOING TO BE HAPPENING. AND WE
NEED TO KNOW WHAT WE CAN DO NOW.
THANK YOU FOR THAT THE SECOND
PART OF THE QUESTION THAT A LOT
OF THINGS THAT CAN BE DONE. WE
KNOW WHAT THE FAILINGS WERE
EARLY ON A LACK OF ENOUGH THE
PP A LACK OF ENOUGH AND NINETY
FIVES HOSPITAL BED ISSUES
VENTILATED ISSUES ALL THAT IS
RIGHT NOW BEING STORED UP IN
THE STRATEGIC. NATIONAL
STOCKPILE IN RACE. WHAT WE HOPE
NEVER OCCURS BUT WHICH VERY
WELL MIGHT OCCUR SO WHAT'S THE
PREPARATION ALSO AS ADVISED
MENTIONED AS WE GO INTO THE
FALL WE LIKELY WOULD WE HAVE
THE CAPABILITY OF DOING FORTY
TO FIFTY MILLION TESTS PER
MONTH. WHICH MEANS WE CAN GET A
MUCH BETTER GRASP OF WHAT THE
SITUATION IS OF THE DYNAMICS OF
VIRUSES IN THE COMMUNITY. SO
HOPEFULLY WE WILL BE MUCH
BETTER PREPARED IF IN FACT WE
DO GET THIS SECOND SURGE AND WE
WERE MONTHS AGO. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH BOB SHE- I THANK THE
GENTLEMAN- NEXT WE MOVED TO MR
MCCANDLESS. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN- I GAVE MY FIRST.
QUESTION TO A DOCTOR FOR LG AT
THE NEW YORK TIMES'S CNN
WASHINGTON POST- HAVE
RELENTLESSLY CRITICIZED
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S RESPONSE.
COVID NINETEEN. LATER FAILURE
YOU HEARD TODAY A LACK OF
LEADERSHIP. BUT WAIT. YOU KNOW
NEARLY SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE HAVE DIED IN
AMERICA FROM DRUG OVERDOSE AND
WE STILL HAVE A SOLUTION. EIGHT
HAS KILLED OVER SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE IN AMERICA. AND
WE DON'T HAVE A CURE FOR THAT
EITHER. LOOK THE FIRST CASE THE
COVID MISDIAGNOSIS AMERICA JUST
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY FIVE DAYS
AGO. ACCORDING TO JUDGE WHY WE
HAD EARLIER THIS IS THIS SPRING
THE PHARMACEUTICAL EXPERTS SAY
THEY THAT WE COULD HAVE A
TREATMENT BY FULL. VACCINE I
DID MY JANUARY. KEEP IN MIND IT
TOOK ALMOST TEN YEARS. I'M OF
THE VACCINE FOR THE INFLUENZA
AND FOUR YEARS FOR MONTHS UP
NEVERTHELESS THE MEDIA AND THE
LEFT SIMPLY CAN'T HELP BUT
CRITICIZE. PRESIDENT TRUMP SO
MY QUESTION TO YOU IS DO YOU
THINK. DO YOU THINK THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS BEING
TREATED JUDGED FAIRLY. WELL
ACTUALLY THAT'S AN UNFAIR
QUESTION YOU'RE BECAUSE YOU'RE
ASKING ME TO PASS JUDGMENT ON
THAT PRESS IS. TREATING OF THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
THAT'S IN IT MAY BE UNFAIR BUT
YOU'VE HAD YOU'VE NEVER
NUMEROUS TIMES YOU'VE COMMENTED
AND CRITICIZE OR ARE-
CONTRADICTED WITH PRESIDENTIAL
AISLE YOU THINK HE'D BE IN
JUDGE FAIRLY WELL IT DEPENDS ON
WHAT YOU MEAN I MEAN I WORK IN
THE WHITE HOUSE AND I BELIEVE
THAT EVERYONE THERE IS DOING
EVERYTHING IT POSSIBLY CAN.
THANK YOU WHAT THEY DIDN'T DO.
THANK YOU TIM IS LATE AND I GOT
A- AT THE NEWSPAPER THAT THAT
IS LATER MARCH THIRTY. THERE
WAS NO. ON WEARING MASKS AT THE
END OF PRESIDENT YOU KNOW
REALIZE ON YOUR YOUR EXPERTISE.
DO YOU NOW REGRET NOT ADVISING
PEOPLE MORE FORCEFULLY. TO WEAR
MASKS EARLIER. OKAY WE'RE GONNA
PLAY THAT THE- LET ME EXPLAIN
TO YOU WHAT HAPPENED BACK THEN
SHOULD BE A YES OR NO NOW
THERE'S MORE THAN A YES OR NO
BUT THE TONE OF YOUR QUESTION I
DON'T REGRET THAT BECAUSE LET
ME EXPLAIN TO YOU WHAT HAPPENED
AT THAT TIME THERE WAS A
PAUCITY OF EQUIPMENT THAT OUR
HEALTH CARE PROVIDER IS NEEDED
WHO PUT THEM. DAILY IN HARM'S
WAY OF TAKING CARE OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE ILL WE DID NOT WANT TO
DIVERT MASKS AND P. P. AWAY
FROM THEM TO BE USED BY THE
PEOPLE OKAY NOW THAT WE HAVE
BEEN OFF THE RECOMMENDED TO
REQUIRE JOE THANK YOU FOR THAT
DEMOCRATS YOU SHOULD DOCTORATE
FUELING DIRECTION. TO YOUR
NURSE. AS YOU ABOUT EARLIER.
MAY NOT A 40% OF ALL THE DEATH
IN THE CD KEY ISSUE GOD ON PRO
FOR THESE. YES STATE'S LIKE
MISSION. NEW YORK NEW JERSEY
AND CALIFORNIA APPARENTLY.
APPARENTLY DISREGARDED THAT
GUIDES. THE DOCTOR REVEALED DO
YOU THINK THE DECISIONS OF
THESE GOVERNORS LED TO
UNNECESSARY DEATHS AND EASIER
SONOMA. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTION I THINK THE CRITICAL.
THE ISSUE HERE IS TWO THINGS
ONE OUR GUIDANCE IS JUST THAT
GUIDANCE. TWO AREAS THAT WE
COULD IMPACT THE NURSING HOMES
FOR TWO CLEANING INFECTION
CONTROL WORKING TOGETHER WAS
CMS VERY AGGRESSIVELY EARLY ON
AFTER THE SEATTLE OUTBREAK WAS
RECOGNIZED IN THAT NURSING HOME
REALLY EVERY CHANNEL THE ENERGY
INTO LOOKING AT THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE SECTION
CONTROL IN THOSE NURSING HOMES.
THEN RESTRICTED VISITORS TO
NEGATIVE REVIEWS. THAT THE
DECISIONS LEAD TO UNNECESSARY
DEATHS BY NOT BY ALLOWING
INFECTED. RESIDENTS TO COME
BACK INTO THE NURSING HOME. I
THANK YOU AGAIN ALL OF THESE-
DECISIONS THAT HAVE BEEN MADE
IN THE EARLY DAYS- ARE- SUBJECT
TO- TO HINDSIGHT WE GAVE CLEAR
GUIDANCE AND HELP PEOPLE.
SHOULD BE HANDLED IF THEY COME
INTO THESE NURSING HOMES OKAY
COULD NOW THE THIRD QUESTION
BACK AGAIN DR READY FOR. OF WE
KNOW IN THE FORESEEABLE FUTURE
THAT WE'RE NOT GONNA HAVE ZERO
RISK OF TRANSMISSION. TO THAT
END BUT IT'S STILL GIVING ON
OUR ECONOMY TO RECOVER WE KNOW
OUR SCHOOLS HAVE REOPENED TO
GOING BACK TO THE SCHOOL
QUESTION IN ADDITION TO TRACY
DISTANCING WEARING MASKS WHAT
RACE FACTION. NEEDED IN YOUR
MIND AND YOUR MINDSET. FIRST ON
TO GO BACK TO SCHOOL WHAT'S THE
RATE OF INFECTION. 1% YEAH I'M
NOT PREPARED TO GIVE YOU THE
DEFINITIVE ANSWER I AM STUPID
TO SAY THAT ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT THINGS WE NEED TO
LOOK AT IS NOT THE NUMBER OF
INFECTIONS BUT THE CONSEQUENCES
OF THESE INFECTIONS WHEN USED
TO BE REALLY BIG CONSEQUENCES.
ONE IS POSSIBLE HOSPITALIZATION
AND MORTALITY IN THE OTHERS ARE.
RIGHT AND I THINK WE'RE CLEARLY
SEEING IN MANY PARTS OF OUR
NATION THAT ONE CAN. OPEN OUR
ECONOMY SAFELY- BUT IT IS GOING
TO REQUIRE MORE VIGILANT SINCE
ALL OF US SEE ALL RIGHT NOW
WITH THE SOCIAL DISTANCING
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO TRY
TO EMPHASIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
SOCIAL DISTANCING FACE MASK AND
HAND WASHING AS WE CONTINUE TO
DO IT THAT'S MY EXPECTATIONS OF
MANY JURISDICTIONS WILL BE OPEN
SCHOOL WE'RE GOING TO TRY TO
GIVE THE GUIDANCE THAT HELP
THEM DO IT. SAFELY I THINK THE
RIGHT IS THE RIGHT APPROACH TWO
BEFORE IT IS GOING TO BE
INFLUENCED BY THE CANAL OF THE
AISLE JURISDICTION AT THE TIME.
I'M NOT PREPARED TO GIVE YOU
THAT NUMBER BUT I THINK WE'RE
GONNA BE UP PROCEDURE DICK SHE
TOOLS FOR YOUR THAT UNDER. ARE
WE NOW GONE. MS K. GENERAL.
FROM I ASK EVERYBODY TO AND ME
BEEF THEY BEGIN. RIGHT THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU TO OUR
WITNESSES TODAY UP. YOU COMPARE
THE NUMBER OF CONFIRMED CASES
AND THE NUMBER OF DEATHS IN THE
UNITED STATES WITH COUNTRIES
ACROSS THE GLOBE. IT'S REALLY
SHOT AND IT'S IT MAKES ME ANGRY
IT MAKES ME SAD AT THE SAME
TIME WE HAVE TWO POINT THREE
MILLION CONFIRMED CASES WE HAVE
JUST. OVER ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THOUSAND AMERICANS LOST
THEIR LIVES JUST IN FEW MONTHS
TIME. IT APPEARS THAT OTHER
COUNTRIES HAVE DONE A BETTER
JOB OF CONTROLLING THE SPREAD.
THEY'VE DONE A BETTER JOB ON
TESTING AND TRACING EVERY
ADVANTAGE OF THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA HAS WITH OUR
SCIENTISTS ARE PUBLIC HEALTH
EXPERTS. ARE SOMETHING HAS GONE
WRONG HERE AND I THINK IT
STARTS AT THE TOP I THINK THE
PRESIDENT'S BEHAVIOR AND
COMMENTS UNDER MY BELT BOTH
PROFESSIONS UP EVERY STEP OF
THE WAY. OUR DOCTOR LIKE TO
KNOW HOW OFTEN. INTERACT WITH
THE PRESIDENT AND TALK TO HIM
ABOUT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
GUIDELINES AND BRING ALL OF
YOUR EXPERTISE TO BEAR HOW
OFTEN YOU INTERACT WITH THE
PRESIDENT. WELL I HAVE REGULAR
INTERACTIONS WITH THAT AS PART
OF THE WHITE HOUSE TASK FORCE
AS A MEMBER TO IT AND
PARTICIPATE IN EACH AND
EVERYONE OF THE TASK FORCE
MEETINGS. AND IS RELATED TO MY
INTERACTIONS DIRECTLY WITH THE
PRESIDENT AND THEN I'M GOING TO
THOSE BETWEEN MYSELF ON
PRESIDENT. WELL YOU KNOW EVERY
TIME THE PRESIDENT CONTRADICTS
SCIENTIST EVERY TIME HE-
CONTRADICTS OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
EXPERTS WHETHER. THE WEARING OF
MASS OR MASS GATHERINGS OR
DRINKING BLEACH OR TAKING. A
HYDROCHLORIC WHEN IT COST LIVES
AND I AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUES
THAT WE- REALLY EXPECT YOU TO
BE MORE OUTSPOKEN WHEN IT COMES
TO THESE PUBLIC HEALTH.
ADVISORIES ARE IT CONFLICT THAT
HAS COST LIVES AND- OUR
BLOCKCHAIN ALL CHANGED AFTER
THE FOR DR BALAJI YOU KNOW
FLORIDIANS ARE VERY CONCERNED
IN. ALL THE LATEST SPIKE IN
CASES OF THE FLORIDA DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH ANNOUNCED JUST A
LITTLE WHILE AGO WE'VE GOT
ANOTHER THIRTY THREE HUNDRED
CASES AND SIXTY FOUR DEATHS
JUST SINCE WHAT WAS ANNOUNCED
YESTERDAY 25% OF THE TOTAL CASE
IN FLORIDA HAVE BEEN CONFIRMED
IN JUST THE PAST TEN DAYS. AND
WE HAVE A OF POSITIVITY RATE OF
NOW UP 213% IN THE PAST WEEK SO
WHAT MESSAGE DO YOU HAVE FOR
THE STATE OF FLORIDA AND OTHER
HOT SPOTS ACROSS THE COUNTRY AS
WEEK. OF HAVE SO MANY MORE
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO FEEL INVENT
POLL THAT ARE ARE TESTING
POSITIVE AND OUR ECONOMY IS
OPENED UP WHAT IS YOUR ADVICE
TO. AUTHORITIES IN IN HOT SPOTS.
NO MY ADVICE TO THE BEANS
ADVICE THAT WOULD GIVE TO. AND
EVERYONE. TO FOLLOW THE
GUIDELINES THAT WE HAVE VERY
CAREFULLY THOUGHT OUT AND PUT
OUT. IN HOW ONE CAN RE OPEN OR
OPEN AMERICA AGAIN. AND THAT IS
TO STAY WITHIN THE FRAMEWORK OF
THE PARTICULAR PHASE OF RE
OPENING YOUR IN. AND SAID I
THROW CAUTION TO THE WIND I
THINK WHAT HAPPENS LATER TO THE
COMMON MADE A LITTLE WHILE AGO.
AT THE FUSION THE MUST BE
PRETTY AMONG YOUNG PEOPLE. WHO
HAVE A PENT UP URGE TO GO OUT
WHICH IS UNDERSTANDABLE. BUT
WHAT THEY NEED TO APPRECIATE.
IS THAT THEY ARE PART OF THE
PROCESS OF THE DYNAMICS OF AN
OUTBREAK. AND ALTHOUGH THEY
THEMSELVES MADE RECEIPT. THAT
THEY ARE A VERY LOW RISK FOR
SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE
DELETERIOUS TO THEM. BY
PROPAGATING THE PROCESS OF THE
OUTBREAK THEY MAY BE INDIRECTLY
HURTING PEOPLE BY INFECTING
SOMEONE WHO THEN INFECTS
SOMEONE. WHO THAT INFECTS
SOMEONE WHO'S VULNERABLE SO
THEY NEED TO UNDERSTAND THAT IF
WE CAN GET THAT MESSAGE ACROSS.
THAT IT'S NOT AN ALL OR NONE
PHENOMENON GETTING BACK TO
NORMALITY IS GOING TO BE A
GRADUAL STEP BY STEP PROCESS.
WHEN CAUTION TO THE WIND. WHAT
ABOUT THE END AND WHAT ABOUT
MASS FOR YOUNG PEOPLE THERE'S A
LOT OF. YOU KNOW THAT. THE
LEADERS. YOUR ADVICE DO YOU SAY
BECAUSE YOU'RE A TRUSTED
SCIENTIST AND AN EXPERT WHAT DO
YOU SAY DIRECTLY ABOUT WEARING
MASKS AND MASS GATHERINGS. I'LL
BE VERY CONSISTENT ON ALL SAY
IT YET AGAIN THANK YOU SHOULD
NOT CONGREGATE IN CROWDS YOU
SHOULD KEEP A DISTANCE. AND
EVEN THOUGH MANY PEOPLE FOR A
VARIETY OF REASONS DO NOT
LISTEN. TO THE. NOT SUGGESTION
BUT PLEASE TO NOT CONGREGATING
CROWDS SOME PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
DO THAT ANYWAY. IF YOU DO
PLEASE WEAR A MASK AND AS YOU
WEAR A MASK AND YOU'RE IN A
SITUATION OF GETTING ANIMATED.
A DEMONSTRATION RAP WHEREVER
YOU ARE. AS AS POSSIBLE THE
URGE TO PULL YOUR MASK DOWN AND
SHOUT SO PLANNED A DON'T GO IN
A CROWD PLANNED BE IF YOU DO
MAKE SURE YOU WEAR A MASK.
THANK YOU ASKING ABOUT TAKE
YOUR BACK. OUR NEXT WE GO TO MR
KINZINGER IN ILLINOIS. AND
MISTER CHAIRMAN I'M NOT NEEDED-
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
THANK YOU TO ALL THE GAS FOR
BEING HERE- IT'S WEIRD TIME AND
VERY IMPORTANT SO THANK YOU I
THINK YOU KNOW ONE OF THE
DISCUSSIONS THIS COMMUNICATIONS
AND- OTHER IT'S BETWEEN FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT STATE GOVERNMENTS
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS NONPROFITS
BUSINESSES. BUT ALSO-
INTERNATIONAL GOVERNMENTS AND I
THINK WE NEED A LOT MORE
INFORMATION EVENTUALLY ON WHAT
ARE THE CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY
KNEW WHAT THEY WITHOUT. AND
WHAT WE ONE BACK THEY HAD- AND
WHAT'S YOUR TO THAT MORE. MORE
INVESTIGATED WE'VE ALL SEEN THE
STORIES ABOUT PEOPLE WHO ARE
TESTING POSITIVE FOR THE VIRUS
MAY SHOW NO SYMPTOMS AT ALL AND
IN SOME CASES IT WAS ABLE TO
SPREAD. THROUGH ENTIRE
COMMUNITIES. WITHOUT KNOWING
THAT THEY MAY IN THAT SO WHY
DOC SATCHER MASK GIVEN THIS.
RATE OF THESE A SOME. A SYMPTOM
INFECTIONS HOW CAN ANYBODY TEST
TO PROVE OUR UNDERSTANDING. OF
THE TRANSMISSION OF COVID
NINETEEN AND BY DEFAULT. BUT
RATHER. WELL ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE NEED TO DO AND I THINK
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT AND IT
RELATED TO A PREVIOUS QUESTION.
ABOUT GETTING. THE KINDS OF
SURVEILLANCE STUDIES THAT ALLOW
YOU TO GET A MUCH BETTER HANDLE
ON EIGHTY THE REAL PERCENTAGE
OF A SYMPTOMATIC CARRIES BE.
THE RATE AT WHICH THEY INFECT
OTHERS AND A VARIETY OF OTHER
THINGS I MEAN THINGS THAT ARE
REALLY IMPORTANT QUESTIONS WE
LEARNED INTERESTINGLY. ACTUALLY
TO MY SURPRISE IS CONGRESSMAN.
THAT WHEN YOU LOOK AT A
SYMPTOMATIC INDIVIDUALS. PEOPLE
SYMPTOMATIC THE LEVEL OF IRISH
THAT MAY. IT IS ALMOST IN WHICH
IS ONLY COMMON TO A- BUT IT IS
IT IS A FOR. WHICH TELLS YOU
THAT THE DANGER OF
TRANSMISSIBILITY IS SUCH THAT
IT IS VERY IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND THAT AND A CHANCE OF
ON. A SYMPTOMATIC INFECTED
PEOPLE AND WHEN YOU DO GET THEM
YOU NEED TO IDENTIFY THEM I
SLIPPED IN CONTACT RACE. AND
QUESTIONS THAT WERE ASKED. I
DON'T KNOW WHEN HOURS SO WE'LL
GO TO THE TESTING ISSUE WE NEED
TO DO MUCH MUCH. BAILIFFS
TESTING. FORTY TO FIFTY MILLION
TESTS PER MONTH THAT WOULD BE
AVAILABLE AS WE GET INTO THE
LATE SUMMER AND EARLY FALL I'M
GONNA BE ABLE TO ASK SOME OF
THE QUESTIONS YOU PROBABLY.
ASKING RIGHT AND I JUST WANNA
GIVE ADDED IF I COULD JUST
BUILD ON THAT FOR A SECOND THE
FORTY TO FIFTY MILLION TECH I
SAID IT SEEMS WOULD BE AN
INTACT KNOWLEDGE E. AND THAT'S
NOT EVEN INCLUDE. LANKFORD
TOOLING BECAUSE FDA DID PUT UP
STANDARD FOR ABOUT. SO WE WOULD
EXPECT BASED ON PRELIMINARY
DATA WE HAVE THAT ON MANY TASKS
WE CAN AT LEAST PULL FIVE TO
ONE AND MAYBE UP TO TEN TO ONE
SO WHEN YOU DO THAT MATH THAT I
THINK WE- NEEDED VERY QUICKLY
BY ACADEMIC INSTITUTE. BY LAURA
BERGEN JAMES THAT NUMBER A
FIFTY MILLION GO UP BY FIVE
FOLD AT LEAST. A MONTH. GREAT
THANK YOU AND THAT'S WHAT'S
AMAZING IS FRANKLY AMERICAN
INGENUITY WHEN WE PUT OUR MINDS
TO IT SENIOR ADVANCES. AND
HOPEFULLY WHEN WE GET TO PLAY-
SEEMS SET TO BEGIN IN THE
PANDEMIC BOTH MY WIFE AND I
ACTUALLY EXPERIENCED WHAT I
THOUGHT WERE SYMPTOMS OF THE
NINETEEN. WE RECENTLY DECIDED
THAT WE'RE GOING TO GET A M.
BODY TEST I HAD DONE AND I
FOUND OUT THAT I WAS ACTUALLY
NEGATIVE FOR THE ANTIBODIES TO
DR REDFIELD. YOUR TEST. DAVE
THAT AT THIS POINT DON'T KNOW
THE PRESENCE ANTIBODIES
PROVIDES IMMUNITY TO THE VIRUS
SO WITH THIS IN MIND. HOW DOES
ANYBODY TESTING HELP IF. WE
DON'T KNOW IF IT PROVIDES
IMMUNITY TO THE VIRUS AND- WHAT
ARE THE BENEFITS OF AN ANTIBODY
TEST FROM AN INDIVIDUAL PATIENT
PERSPECTIVE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE QUESTION
CONGRESSMAN. I THINK RIGHT NOW
AT THIS STAGE I THINK IMPORTANT
AT THE INDIVIDUAL PATIENT LEVEL
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT IT MEANS
PARTICULARLY IN TERMS OF UNITY
DOCTOR. ACCUSED EARLIER. WHAT
IS. IN CANADA. THE FDA TEN THAT
YOU BEEN IN FACT IN THE PAST WE
DON'T KNOW THOUGH WELL THAT
MEANS IN TERMS OF IMMUNITY IT'S
VERY TO A- AT SENIOR IS IT'S
FOR SURVEILLANCE ADVANTAGE
RIGHT NOW WE'VE CONTINUED TO DO
SURVEILLANCE THROUGHOUT I DID
STATE'S VARIETY DIFFERENT
SYSTEMATIC COLLECTIONS WERE
DOING- AND IT ALLOWS US TO SEE
WHAT THE FULL EXTENT OF THE
INFECTION RIGHT NOW THE DATA.
LEVELS EVERY DAY I COMMITTEE
SECTION THAT CONTINUE TO BE
REFINED AS WE CAN IT EX OR AN A
TEST BUT I THINK IT'S MAJOR NOW
THE NUMBER THE SERVER ONCE.
YOUR BACK THANK. THANK YOU ANNA
AND THANKS TO REMIND EVERYONE
THAT YOU CAN SUBMIT A QUESTIONS
FOR THE RECORD TO THE TO THE
TEST WAS SET WITH THAT'LL OPEN
STATEMENTS THAT WILL BE
INTRODUCED FOR THE RECORD- SO
NEXT WE GO TO MISTER SARBANES
FROM MERRILL. THANK YOU MINS
CHAIRMAN CAN YOU HEAR ME WE CAN.
IT'S GOING TO THANK THE PANEL.
LAST MONTH THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION ANNOUNCED THE
LAUNCH OF OPERATION WERE SPEED
TO SUPPORT RAPID RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT OF COVID NINETEEN
VACCINES THERAPEUTICS
DIAGNOSTICS AND SO FORTH IT'S A
PROJECT THAT THE POST TO
COORDINATE EFFORTS ACROSS THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND ENGAGE
THE PRIVATE SECTOR. INCLUDING
AT TWO FIVE FOUR MINS COMBAT
VALOR BANK VACCINES ON TRYING
TO UNDERSTAND A LITTLE BIT
BETTER HOW THAT WORKS- START
THERE'S BEEN. RAISED ABOUT THE
VAN INCLUDING POTENTIAL
CONFLICTS AMONG ITS LEADERSHIP
A CONFLICT OF INTEREST A DOCTOR
PHALKE YOU HAD DECADES OF
EXPERIENCE LEADING PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS WITH
PHARMACEUTICAL MONEY. ALL OF
THE ACCE SCENES TRANSPARENCY IS
IMPORTANT IS IT NOT IN THESE
COLLABORATIONS. THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION THE OPERATION ONE
SPEED. IS A ENDEAVOR- THAT IS
OF A DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE HHS
LED BY THE SECRETARY ESPER
SECRETARY A SAUNA TO TRY AND
GET DIAGNOSTICS THERAPEUTICS
AND VACCINES DONE IN A WAY THAT
IS COORDINATED WITH THE MAXIMUM
SPEED POSSIBLE WITHOUT
SACRIFICING SCIENTIFIC
INTEGRITY IT'S DIVIDED UP INTO
THREE GROUPS. THE LEADER OF
THIS IS MY ON SEPT SO ARE WE A
PERSON WITH GREAT EXPERIENCE IN
INDUSTRY AS WELL AS GENERAL
PERNA WHO IS AN ARMY GENERAL
WHO IS VERY WELL VERSED AND
EXPERIENCED. IN SUPPLY CHAIN.
OF PROCESSES OF GETTING
VACCINES WHEN WE DO GET IT TO
BE PRODUCED TO THE LEVEL THAT
IS NEEDED AS WELL AS TO BE
DISTRIBUTED. EQUITABLY OUR
SYSTEM. SO IT'S EIGHT YEAH IT
LET ME ASK ME JUMP IN BECAUSE I
TO ASK DOCTOR. STAND IS SENIOR.
FDA OFFICIALS INITIALLY TAPPED
WE THE VACCINE DEVELOPMENT
UNDER OPERATION WORKS BE BUT
THEN LEFT THE PROJECT. OUT OF
CONCERNS ABOUT POLITICAL
PRESSURES TO IMPROVE VACCINE. I
ASSUME YOU AGREE THAT THE ROLE
AT THE A PLACE IN THIS HAS TO
BE ONE THAT'S NOT IMPACTED. ON
POLITICAL. I SURE AND THAT YOUR
AGENTS IS READY TO ADOPT THE
HIGHEST STANDARDS IN APPROVING
ANY VACCINE IS DEVELOPED UNDER
THIS INITIATIVE. THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION. IS VERY WELL
TAKEN AND I ASSURE YOU THAT WE
WILL RETAIN OUR REGULATORY
INDEPENDENCE WE WILL USE THE
TIME TO COME TO US AND WE'LL
USE OUR HIGH STANDARDS A TO
ASSESS THE SAFETY AND EFFICACY
OF THE VACCINE WE HAVE WORLD
CLASS EXPERTS WHO WILL CONTINUE
TO MAINTAIN THAT ONE POINT I DO
WANT TO MAKE THAT CLEAR SIR IS
THAT- WE DREW A VERY BRIGHT
LINE BETWEEN OPERATION MORE
SPEEDING. ALL OF OUR SPONSORS
DO NOT ENGAGE DECISION MAKING
THANK ON DECK TOMORROW THE
DOCTOR CABOT SONY WITH RESPECT
TO THOSE DECISIONS WE PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IS ALL. WE
IT CLEAR YOU KNOW SPEAK TO SAY
BECAUSE WE ADD MUST. CONTAIN
REGULATORY. AND MAKE THE RIGHT
DECISION FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE BASED ON SCIENCE AND
DATA. THANK YOU AND AGAIN I'M
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THE SORT
OF THE BOUNDARIES WERE REACH OF
THE OPERATION WORK SPEED.
AFTERWARDS SO- MY INITIAL SENSE
IS THAT IT WAS FOCUSED ON THESE
FIVE SELECTED COMPANIES THAT
ARE PURSUING VACCINE CANDIDATES.
I'M NOT ENTIRELY CLEAR MAYBE
THAT'S NOT RIGHT BUT I'M NOT
ENTIRELY CLEAR ON WHAT THIS
MEANS FOR VACCINE EXPLORATION
DEVELOPMENT BEYOND THAT. FOR
INSTANCE I'VE BEEN READING JUST
OVER THE LAST WEEK OR TEN DAYS
OR SO ABOUT THIS- ORAL POLIO
VACCINE OPPORTUNITY. MAYBE THAT
I HAS PROMISED MAYBE IT DOESN'T
BUT SOME INCREASE THEIR I GUESS
MAY BE WARRANTED IS THAT. I'D
LIKE TO GET THE PANEL'S
PERSPECTIVE ON WHAT YOU WHAT
YOU CONSIDER THOSE KIND OF
INCORPORATE ALSO. RAISING OR IS
THAT IS OPERATION ONCE WE
BROUGHT ENOUGH TO ACCOMMODATE
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS IN
ADDITION TO WHATEVER IS
HAPPENING WITH THE FIVE.
COMPANIES AND FROM WHERE YOU'RE
DIFFERENT AGENCIES SET WHAT'S
YOUR PERSPECTIVE UNDERSTANDING
OF THAT SO LET ME JUST I GUESS
GO DOWN THE LINE BACK TO READ
FEEL WHEN WE STARTED YOU AND
DOCTOR. AND I GUESS THAT. THIS
IS BECAUSE IS K. AS A- ERIC THE
ONLY THING I WOULD SAY IS IT'S
INTRIGUING IN TERMS OF THE
POTENTIAL OF WHAT WE CALL VIRAL
INTERFERENCE WITH THESE LIVE
VIRUS VACCINES WHETHER IT'S
FULLY OR MEASLES THAT THEY MAY.
IN OTHER ARE NEIGHBORS FROM
BEING TO STEP CONVECTION
INFECTION SO REALLY THAT'S THE-
HYPOTHETICAL I THINK IT'S
INTRIGUING OFFERED JUST THIS
PATHOGEN FOR OTHER RNA VIRUSES.
YEAH VERY QUICK I THINK YOUR
QUESTION WAS IS THERE ROOM FOR
OTHER OTHER OF OUR OTHER
VACCINES THE ANSWER IS YES
THROUGH MULTIPLE MECHANISMS
ANYTHING'S ON THE TABLE IT
COULD BE TO OPERATION WHAT
SPEED THEY COULD BE THROUGH A
NUMBER OF MECHANISMS. THAT WE
HAVE A SURGEON TO SHIP AT NIH
SO I CAN UNDERSTAND YOUR
CONCERN BUT THE DOORS ARE NOT
CLOSED TO OTHER CANDIDATES YOU
CAN BE ASSURED OF THAT SIR. I
UNDERSTAND FROM FDA'S
PERSPECTIVE WE ABSOLUTELY THE
DOORS ARE OPEN THERE AS WELL
WE'RE WORKING WITH MULTIPLE
DIFFERENT SPONSORS.
PHARMACEUTICAL COMPANIES AS
WELL AS OPERATION WORK SPEED WE
WILL LOOK AT ALL DATA THE COMES
ACROSS DOOR WILL PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO ALL.
WHO WANT TO DEVELOP A VACCINE
THERAPEUTICS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER GRIFFITH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN I GREATLY
APPRECIATE DR FASCINATED AND
THEN DOCTOR RECRUITMENT WHICH
ARE A LITTLE BIT ON THE SPOT
BECAUSE ON PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND
AS YOU MIGHT IMAGINE. A LOT OF
CONSTITUENTS ARE VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT WHAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING
IN THE SCHOOLS AND DUCK FAT SHE
EARLIER. MADE SOME STATEMENTS
WHICH LED ME TO BELIEVE THAT
YOU BELIEVE THAT AT NOT ONLY
NATIONALLY. BUT EVEN WITHIN A
STATE THE SIZE OF VIRGINIA- WE
PROBABLY OUGHT TO BE LOOKING.
REGIONALLY AND MAYBE EVEN-
LOCALLY AS TO HOW WE DO IT AND-
AND HOW THE FORTY YOU NEED THE
LATTER SAYING THAT CORRECTLY.
UNDERSTOOD ME CORRECTLY
CONGRESSMAN AND THAT'S THE
POINT I WANT TO MAKE BECAUSE
IT'S REALLY A SOURCE OF
CONFUSION IT'S NOT ONE SIZE
FITS ALL I THINK YOU HAVE TO
LOOK AT THE LOCAL LEVEL THE
COUNTY LEVEL. THE REGIONAL
LEVEL CITY LEVEL STATE LEVEL SO
WE OFTEN SEE IN AMERICA SHOULD
YOU OR SHOULD YOU NOT BE OPEN I
MEAN THAT'S ALMOST THE NON
QUESTION BECAUSE WITH SUCH A
LARGE TREE AND SO EVERY GENIUS.
SUCH A RANGE OF IN ANOTHER
VIRUS IN DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY. DR MOVIE BECAUSE IT
INCOME OF THE VIRGINIA THEY
OFTEN REQUIRE CITING. SITES TO
SEE TO DR FETCHING HIS
ASSESSMENT. YES IT NEEDS TO BE
A VERY A TARGETED
JURISDICTIONAL DECISION AND I
GREATLY APPRECIATE THAT BECAUSE
MY DISTRICT IS FOUR HOURS FROM
DC EVEN THE PEOPLE OFTEN THINK
I'M RIGHT NEXT DOOR AND THEN
THE DISTRICT STRETCHES FROM THE
VERY EDGE OF FOUR HOURS OF
ANOTHER. HOURS GOING WEST AND
IN THE HIS IS A IS LARGE THE
STATE OF JERSEY SO EVEN WITHIN
THE DISTRICT WE MAY NEED TO
HAVE SOME. ADDITIONAL REGIONAL
APPROACHES WOULD YOU ALL AGREE
WITH. INDICATE THAT IS. I CAN
YEAH HI ON IN A STATEMENT ON
MARCH. TWENTY TWENTY YOU
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
HAVING ACCESS TO VIRAL SAMPLES
IN ORDER TO SPEED UP THE
DEVELOPMENT OF TEST. YOU NOTED
THAT IN THE FUTURE. AND ARE.
AVAILABLE EARLIER TO COMMERCIAL.
WILL BE CRUCIAL TO THE POLLING
TEST QUICKLY. THIS WILL NOT BE
THE LAST TIME WE FACE RAPIDLY
SPREADING BACK. OF A VAN. CAN
ASSIST FOR ENDING VIOLENCE AS-
IN ACTIVE VIRAL SAMPLES BE
IMPROVED IN THE FUTURE FOR
QUICKER ACCESS. CONGRESSMAN
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION AND
I THINK THAT IS ONE OF THE
LESSONS LEARNT FROM. OF THIS
SITUATION WITH COVID NINETEEN
IS THAT ACCESS TO THE SAMPLES
IS VERY IMPORTANT. WE WOULD
WORK WITH H. THE CD. ATTEND
SURE THAT THOSE OF A IN JUST A
MAKE. WE FOR SEROLOGY TESTS
HAVE MADE A REFERENCE PANEL NOW
AVAILABLE TO DEVELOPERS
ACTUALLY FACILITATE THAT THAT'S
AN EXAMPLE OF WHAT U. S.
GOVERNMENT FDA NIH AND CDC
COULD. I THANK. AND APOLOGIZE
ADMIRAL JIRO DOES SAY CLOSE TO
CORRECT OR THAT'S GOOD ENOUGH
ALL RIGHT EARLIER THIS YEAR YOU
INFORM COMMITTEE THAT ENOUGH
TESTING SUPPLIES TO BE
DISTRIBUTED SO THE STATE'S
COULD TAKE THE RECOMMENDED 2%
OTHER POPULATIONS PER MONTH IT
NJ POP THE MARIST TREND
TRACKING CENTER DAY ONLY ABOUT
9% OF THE STATES ARE. IN THE
RIGHT MONTH WELL. PERCENT
TESTING THAN ONE. IS A
MINISTRATION INDUSTRY SUPPLIES
TO STATES AND IF SO WHY DO YOU
BELIEVE SOME STATES THAT HAVE
TESTING SUPPLIES ARE NOT
TESTING OR OF THEIR POP. THANK
YOU FOR THAT- AGAIN BEFORE THE
FULL STATE PLANS WERE JUST
RECEIVED IN THIS IS PART OF THE
P. P. P. FUNDING. ON THAT WE
WERE. PEOPLE DOWN THE CIVIL
WITH THE CDC WE SET CULINARY
TARGETS FOR EVERY STATE. BY
PHONE CALL EVERYTHING. WITH
SINGLE R. A STATE HELP. YOU ALL
JUST. ROLLIN MAY THE TARGET
ABOUT TWELVE. TEST RIGHT ENTRY
AND ABOUT ALL THE WERE DONE. ON
THIS IS WE VERY GOOD MANY OF
THE STATES. TRIED TO DO THREE
OR FOUR TIMES AND AS MANY TASKS
THAT THEY DONE CUMULATIVELY
THAT TIME THANK RON TRACK.
REALLY ON TRACK RIGHT NOW IT
VERY GOOD SOME STATES HAVE
UNDERPERFORMED. ON ESPECIALLY
BIG MOST OF THEM HAVE IMPROVED
THEIR PERFORMANCE IN JUNE- AND
OUR PRELIMINARY VIEW OF ALL THE
STATE PLANS THE GREAT MAJORITY
OF THEM I MEAN THE WELLMAN
GEORGE WERE. VERY GOOD TO. SO
GETTING THE- I LOOK. FORWARD I
YOU AND OF AT COME BACK TO YOU
WHEN WE FIRST STARTED THIS- YOU
KNOW WE NEWS ON THE TOUGH AND
THEY WERE. NEVER GOING TO GET
THIS PARTICULAR VIRUS WE TALK
ABOUT BENDING CURVE CAN SHAR
HOSPITALS READY ON YOUR
COMMENTS. VP FACE MASK AND
SUPPORT I BELIEVE THE THANK
THAT. WERE PROUD READ NOT.
READY AND HAVE WE NOT BE AT THE
CURB. I JUST THOUGHT I WOULD
NOT ONLY OVER INTENSIVE WE GOT
TO WEAR A MASK. WE DON'T WITH
THAT. THERE. NOW READY. YOU
MIGHT WANT SORRY SIR. YES WE
BEEN THROUGH IT. A WE'VE A- THE
PREPARATIVE NOW IS CLEARLY.
BLAH DIFFERENT DATA WAS IN THE
BEGINNING. AND SO WE'VE BEEN TO
CURB IN OUR HOUSE ALREADY A
YEAR BACK. THANK YOU NECK WE GO
TO. MR MCMAHON COMMON CAL.
WOULD YOU ON MUTE THANK THE
CHAIRMAN AND I THINK THE
WITNESSES UP TO YOUR- WORKING
IN IRAN EXPRESS YOUR EXPERTISE.
I DEALING DAMAGE ON. ALL OF. WE
CAN HEAR YOU. OKAY THANK YOU-
SO I'M LEAVING CONCERN ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S DECISION TO
AN EIGHTY NINE STATE'S
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
ORGANIZATION AND I'M NOT ONE OF
THOSE CONCERNED. ERIC AND
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION PRESIDENT
MOVE A SENSELESS ACTION. HELLO
AT SIGNIFICANT HARMFUL
REPERCUSSIONS NOW R. P. ON THIS
MOMENT. HEATERS BUT THE
PRESIDENT IS NOT ACTING OUTSIDE
ON PUBLIC GUIDANCE BUT IS
INSTEAD SKATEBOARDING THE W. H.
L. THE FOX BUSINESS INSIDER IN
RESPONDING TO THE COVID
NINETEEN AT THAT. ACCORDING TO
REPORTING ANY FEAR HE WAS A
SEASONAL WORK WITH W. H.
EUROPOL ON MOBILE HELP PROGRAM
WERE NOT CONSULTED OR ASKED FOR
IT IMPACT ANALYSIS. WHAT WILL.
WE CONSULTED ABOUT PUBLIC HELP
EFFECTIVELY STATES WITHDRAWING
THE DOUBLE H. O. YOU KNOW SO
WHAT WERE YOU RECKON. KERRY I
UP WE SAID WERE GOING TO A
BREAK AT ONE THIRTY SO EVERY
CAN THE RESTROOM WHATEVER FIFTY
MINUTES DR SHE HAD TO STEP OUT
SO I'M GONNA IS START AGAIN.
TEAM MEMBER HER. RESTROOMS AND
THEN THE STAR AGAIN WITH HER
THIRTY THEIR CRIMES. IS STANDS
FOR FIFTY MINUTES. OKAY. YEAH.
UHHUH UHHUH. YEAH.
YEAH OKAY.
YOU'RE RIGHT. ONE OF. THREE
YEAH YEAH RIGHT ONE. YEAH UHHUH.
ONE OF THE. RIGHT. UHHUH.
YEAH
YEAH.
UHHUH UHHUH. AT THE
BEGINNING OF. UHHUH. SO.
YEAH.
I'M NOT. YEAH. UHHUH. WE ARE.
VERY. YEAH.
YEAH YEAH.
ON. ALL.
UHHUH. ON.
YEAH.
YEAH I. OTHER
DAYS. RIGHT ALL RIGHT. YEAH. ON.
YEAH. YEAH.
YEAH.
MEDIA CALLED.
ON PERSONAL BUSINESS. DONALD.
YEAH.
UHHUH UHHUH.
ELECTIONS.
OKAY. YEAH ON. RIGHT.
UHHUH. NO ON. YEAH.
RIGHT.
YEAH.
UHHUH. UHHUH.
PARTNER.
ALL.
AND.
WE ARE ALL.
ALL.
YEAH. MEDIA
CALLED.
YEAH. YEAH. OKAY. ALL.
ALL RIGHT THE COMMITTEE WILL
RECONVENE. WE TRY TO GO AS
QUICKLY AS WE CAN. I APPRECIATE
EVERYBODY BEARING WITH US AND
IF YOU HAVE TO STEP OUT. PLEASE.
AND WE LEFT OFF WITH THE
CONGRESSMAN MCNERNEY JERRY
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO. REPEAT
YOUR QUESTION. AND ON MUTE OKAY
GERMAN- I'M SITTING ON A LOT OF
NOW I WANTED BUT THE CHAIRMAN
YOUR VIDEO FROM THE COMMITTEE
IS COMING UP I'M NOT SURE ON
FINANCING OR NOT BUT I'M
CONCERNED BY THAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP POSITIONS TRUMP MADE THE
UNITED STATES LISTEN. STATION
ON THE CONCERN. FOR THE
AMERICAN MEDICAL FOR EXAMPLE
CALLED PRESIDENT MOVE A
SENSELESS ACTION THAT WILL HAVE
SIGNIFICANT HARMFUL
REPERCUSSIONS NOW GONE FAR
BEYOND THIS PERILOUS MOMENTS.
IT DOES APPEAR THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS NOT ACTING ON
SOUND PUBLIC HEALTH GUIDE THIS.
BUT IS INSTEAD SCAPEGOATING THE
WHL. TWO IS A MOVE FAILURE
RESPOND TO THE- AGAIN CORY TO
THE FAIR. HE US AGENCIES THAT
WORK WITH THE W. H. O. ON HOLD
PUBLIC HELP US. WE'RE NOT
CONSULTED OR ASKED FOR
IMPACTING. ONE OF THE
PRESIDENT'S DECISION WHICH FROM.
K. WERE YOU ABOUT THE PUBLIC
FICTION PUBLIC HEALTH IMPACT
THE UNITED STATES TRYING ON THE
DAILY SHOW AND IT'S SO WHAT
WOULD YOUR RECOMMENDATIONS.
THANK I WAS NOT SPECIFICALLY
CONSULTED ALL ABOUT THE
WITHDRAWAL OF THE ATTEMPT TO
WITHDRAW. THE SITUATION WITH
MANY OF US IS THAT WE HAVE LONG
STANDING RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE
WHL THE N. I. A. IDEAS A
COLLABORATING CENTER I HAVE
AMID BRANDED OF UNDERSTANDING
WITH TED WROTE. MANY ARE UP
BITS OF INFORMATION THAT WE
DEATH DR REDFIELD I ON A WEEKLY
COAL AND SUPERVISED BY THE W.
H. WE GET THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK. TO THE MEDICAL LEADERS
IN THE VARIOUS RACE. SO WITH
REGARD TO WHAT. POLICY COMES
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE IS NOT
I'VE NOT BEEN CONSULTED ON AND
IT HASN'T REALLY IMPACTED THE
KIND OF INTERACTION I'M
INTERESTED NOT YET I CAN'T JUST
LIKE WATCHING YOU KNOW INTO A
SOFT PHONES COMING IN AND OUT.
OF COURSE. NOT LOSING FOR
DOCTOR REFUSE. ATTENTION PUBLIC
IMPACT OF THE- US WITHDRAWING
ON THE GLOBAL IN SOMEONE WE CAN
DO. ON WITHOUT EDGE AND NO
NATURAL SO HAS LONG HISTORY
WITH WORKING W. WE CONTINUE THE
COLLABORATION. WE'RE WORKING ON
BOTH POLIO ERADICATION ABLE
OUTBREAKS IN THE DRC INFLUENZA.
SURVEILLANCE ACROSS THE WORLD
SO WE CONTINUE WORKING AT THE A
TECHNICAL SCIENTIST TO
SCIENTIST LEVEL AND- AND SO WE
CONTINUE TO DO THAT. AGAIN I
COULDN'T HEAR THE RESPONSE- ON
THE COMMITTEE APPROVED THE
SITUATION ACCORDING TO DR SHE'S
ON A JOB TITLE DIRECTOR OF THE
HARVARD GLOBAL HEALTH
INSTITUTE. CALLING THIS
CRITICAL WILL HELP ANOTHER ONE
THE WORLD IS IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE ACADEMIC WILL HAVE OUTSIZED
CONSEQUENCES AND IT WILL
CERTAINLY MAKE. ALMOST EIGHTY.
WELL YOUR RESPONSE WILL HERE IN
THE UNITED STATES. I'M IF YOU
HAD WITH APPROVE HIS DECISION
TO WITHDRAW. YES I DO THAT'S
THE REASON WHY I'M SORRY YOU
DID NOT HEAR. MY EXPLANATION
WHAT I WAS SAYING IS THAT
DESPITE ANY POLICY ISSUES THAT
COME FROM HIGHER UP. IN THE
WHITE HOUSE WE AT THE REGIONAL
LEVEL CONTINUE TO INTERACT WITH
THE W. H. O. IN A MEANINGFUL.
ON A DEEPLY ON A DAY BY THIS.
REVEALED THAT THE- FORMING
WITHDRAWALS ON THE W. HOW
LITTLE THAT AFFECT. ABILITY
PROTECT AMERICANS. WE WILL AS I
SAID WE'RE CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH WHL ON OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
EFFORTS IN A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS- AND- IN
AGAIN THE EMPLOYEE THE
APPLICATION WILL BECOME YOU
KNOW. WHERE THERE'S COLLEAGUES
AND ABLE TO COLLABORATE AND
CLEARLY THERE CAN BE
LIMITATIONS ON OUR ABILITY TO
PROVIDE DIRECT FUNDING TO THE
WHL. WE HAVE THE LEGAL PROVIDE
FUNDING TO THE OPERATION. IS
AND SO CONTINUE TO HEALTH WORK
THAT WE NEED TO DONE. THANK YOU
DON'T REALLY FEEL. WELL AS A
MEMBER OF CONGRESS WAS SET. I'M
CONCERNED SCIENCE. CORPORATE
PURPOSES. WE MUST BE CERTAIN
CONSEQUENTIAL DECISIONS. WHEN
THE W. H. O. R. BASED ON SOME
ON PUBLIC HEALTH GUIDANCE NOTE
ON THE SORT OF. FOR STUDENTS
GAY. SIGN UP THE MOST TERRIBLE
AT THE TABLE THERE IS A GREAT.
THE KERR AND FUTURE PANDEMIC ON
CHANGE OTHER ISSUES CONCERN WE
MUST ON SCIENCE IN DECISION
MAKING REGARDING SCIENCE IS
DANGEROUS AND THE SERVICES OF
THE AMERICAN. WHICH ARE YOU.
THANK YOU MR MAKE NEXIUM MILLER
A YOU MR BRIDGET AND I WANT TO
THANK THE PRESENTERS FOR THEIR
TESTIMONY AND ALL THE WORK DO
ALL THE OF OUR CONSTITUENTS ARE
DOCTORS. THE HOT. IN THE SUN
COMMUNITY IS COVID AND RISK.
WHICH IN ON THANK GOD SIDE OF
THE CALL. TO RESEARCH
INFORMATION SHARING AND A SON
LIKE ANYTHING BEFORE IN HISTORY
CLINICAL TRIALS ARE PROVED-
TIME WELL LET'S FOCUS REMAINS
INTENT ON WEDNESDAY FIFTY.
RIGHT AND MANUFACTURERS
LEARNING FROM EACH OTHER.
JOINING TO GATHER AND FIGHT
AGAINST. TEEN. HEY IN
COLLABORATION WITH FRIENDS OF
CANCER RESEARCH TO ADVANCE
UNDERSTANDING COVID NINETEEN
THE FOCUS ON ANALYSIS OF REAL
WORLD DIAGNOSTIC. CALLED DATA
QUESTION DO YOU BELIEVE THE
SCIENTIFIC COLLABORATIONS WILL
LEAD TO LASTING CHANGES AND HOW
WE INNOVATE FOR DRUGS AND
VACCINES DRUGS AND VACCINES HOW
THE END CAN CHANGES AFFECT
RESEARCH INTO DISEASES OKAY ON
A SMALL TIMERS DISEASE ON A
DOCTOR FOR YOU OKAY. OKAY ALL
RIGHT. COMMISSIONER TEN THANK
YOU FOR HIGHLIGHTING THIS
REALLY IMPORTANT ENDEAVOR AND-
WITH THE REAGAN UDALL
FOUNDATION FRIENDS OF CANCER
RESEARCH SOME THIS EFFORT A
CHANCE TO REALLY ACCELERATE AS
THE NAME IMPLIES USED REAL
WORLD EVIDENCE ON IN OUR
DECISION MADE. UP UNDER THAT IN
OF RESEARCH POINT OF VIEW A
COUPLE OF POINTS I'D LIKE TO
MAKE CERTAIN I HAD THANK YOU
ONE IS WE REALLY CARE WE DO THE
BOTTOM CARE BECAUSE THE BOLTON
REMAIN IN CLINICAL TRIAL RAN.
THAT IT'S IMPORTANT TO IN THAT
LEVEL HOWEVER IN A ROW MOVING
IN LIKE WE ON THE COVID. WHERE
WE STATIONS ON THE DATA THAT
AISLE TO ASSIST. IN ADDITION
AFTERWARD AS THIS TO SAY. AS WE
AT THE ABOUT HOW TESTS WORK IN
THE WORLD ABOUT HOW TREAT ARE
ADMINISTERED VERY PRAGMATIC
DATA ALLOW THEN GO BACK AND
REVISIT THE DECISION TO MEET
NOTHING WRONG SIX THE REALLY
GOOD THING AS THE DOCTORS IN
THE- WHEN YOU'RE TAKING.
PATIENT YOU GET MORE YOU BACK
TO THE TWO. LAST FOUR BRIEFING
WE MAKE SO I THIS RATE UP. I'D
LOVE TO SEE IS TO OF IT AS A
MAN EARLIER WHEN ASKED QUESTION
AND WOULD LOVE THAT TO CONTINUE
THE CONVERSATION WITH CONGRESS.
A GOOD FAUCI WOULD YOU LIKE TO
RESPOND. YEAH I TOTALLY AGREE I
THINK THAT THAT WOULD WITH
DOCTOR ON AS MENTIONED THIS
THING THAT'S OVER IO WHAT WE
DO IT AND I. HM DICK. PROPS
WHICH IS THE GOAL STATE. OF
THOSE. VERY GOOD YOU I NEXT
QUESTION FOR DOCTOR REDFISH.
R-S.C COORDINATED WITH AGENCIES
SUCH AS THE ADMINISTRATION
COMMUNITY LIVING TO IMPROVE
EFFORTS TO PROTECT THE- WHAT'S
THAT A CD TAKE INTO FOSTERING
GROWTH RATE. THE BOULDER DURING
THIS DEMOCRAT THANK YOU
CONGRESSMAN THANK YOU CDC HAS A
LONG ESTABLISHED RELATIONSHIP
WITH THESE TO CONTINUE TO WORK
ON HEALTH AND WELL BEING
VERTICALLY THE ELDERLY ALSO
DISABILITY WE WORKING. TRYING
TO CROSS CLEAR- INFORMATION
FROM OTHER AGENCIES IN THE
MATERIALS- WE ALSO CDC'S
RIDGEDALE TO OBVIOUS A ARE
PLAYING. UP TO PROVIDE FOR
OLDER ADULTS SO WE CAN GET OUT
AND TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THEIR
DISTRIBUTION. I'M AND WILL
CONTINUE TO DO THAT ACTUALLY TO
GROUP IT WAS A HIGHLIGHT IN
TERMS OF THE ONE MILLION
CALENDAR TICKET. NOW. OKAY
THANK YOU CAN YOU. CROSS
COLLABORATE WITH THE IN THEN
TRY HELP FACILITATE THEIR
MISSION. EXCELLENT NEXT
QUESTION HI AGAIN DOCTOR READ
THROUGH GIVEN THE FACT THAT WE
CONTINUE TO LEARN ABOUT THE
VIRUS IN REAL TIME HOW OFTEN IS
CDC UPDATING ASKING GOD WHAT'S.
WELL IT TWO MEN WE RE POLL ARE
TESTED GUIDELINES LAST FRIDAY.
AND I KNOW AS WE WE'VE GOTTEN
SOME FEEDBACK STATE'S AS A AN
ARM- REGAN THAT'S GONNA COME TO
CLARIFY IF YOU USE ISSUES THIS
WEEK PROBABLY. AND THEN ON TOP
OF THAT BASS LINE. OUR POST
SPIN THE GUIDELINES FOR HIS
THAT YOU SO WE DID FIRST.
CRITICAL ON FOR WE DID NURSING
HOMES WITH MEDICAL THIS WEEK I
SUSPECT WE'RE GOING TO DO K.
THROUGH TWELVE WHEN HIGHER
UNITS. IS AT I SUSPECT. WE'RE
GONNA DO. THE BUSINESS'S SO WE
ARE TRYING TO ADD SPECIFIC
TESTING GUIDELINES THIS IS THE
SPECIFICS. AND THE- OBVIOUSLY
WHEN THERE'S NEW SCIENCE AND
NEW SITUATIONS WE UPDATE THEM.
IN IN SETTING I THINK YOU'LL
SEE THAT'S GOING TO BE A SERIES
OF TARGETED TESTING GUIDELINES
FOR UNIQUE SITUATIONS OR BE
POSTED OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL
WEEKS ON A REGULAR I PRETTY
THAT GO BACK MEASUREMENT YOU.
THAT NEXT MEMBER- IS THE
GENTLEMAN FROM VERMONT MR WELCH.
ON MUTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
I'M A REGULAR WALDEN. THIS FOR
YOUR PATIENCE AND FOR YOUR
EXTRAORDINARILY GOOD WORK. ON
IT I THINK IT'S FAIR TO SAY
THAT NOT A SINGLE MEMBER OF
THIS COMMITTEE. CRAP AS OF
DECEMBER LAST YEAR EVEN JANUARY
FEBRUARY HAD ANY NOTION THAT
THERE WAS THIS EMERGING THREAT
FROM THE CURRENT VIRUS. BUT ON
THE OTHER HAND LANDS. LIKE HELL
OF. ALWAYS IN THIRTY THINGS
THAT ESSENTIAL TO BE READY IS
PREPARATION IN TO RESCUE. I
WANT TO ASK A FEW QUESTIONS
OPERATION MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT THE NATIONAL SECURITY
COUNCIL HAVE A PLAYBOOK FOR
EARLY RESPONSE TO HIGH POINT
CONSEQUENCE EMERGING INFECTIOUS
DISEASES. AND THAT INDICATED
THAT WE SHOULD IN PREPARATION
NEWS WESLEY A FULLY DETECT
OUTBREAKS YOUR P. P. SECURITY
SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING AVOID A
GIVES THE DEFENSE PRODUCTION
ACT ARE ANY OF THE WITNESSES
ARE AWARE OF THAT REPORT HAVING
BEEN FOLLOWED. THIS IS FOR
TWENTY NINETEEN OR ON FEBRUARY
TWENTY JUST YESTERDAY NOW.
SOUNDS LIKE THE ANSWER IS NO NO
I I'M I'M NOT EXACTLY SURE WHAT
YOU'RE REFERRING TO I THINK
YOU'RE REFERRING. TO A DOCUMENT
THAT WAS PUT OUT. RYAN THE DICK
ABOUT THE RESPONSE BIG YES. YOU
KNOW IF YOU LOOK SUBSTANTIVELY
MUCH OF WHAT. THAT WAS IN THAT
DOCUMENT ACTUALLY- WAS
IMPLEMENTED WITH THE EXCEPTION
AS I THINK YOU'RE ALLUDING TO
IS THAT THE AMOUNT OF
STOCKPILED VP OTHER ITEMS THAT
WE NEEDED WERE NOT AT THE
LEVEL. THAT WE RESPONDED AS
EFFICIENT WAYS PRESS. RIGHT
RIGHT. IT WAS A REAL CLAIM THE
USE OF THE DEFENSE PRODUCTION
ACT ALSO. THE THERE HAD BEEN A
WHITE HOUSE GLOBAL PANDEMIC
RESPONSE TEAM THAT WAS
ELIMINATED IN MAY HAVE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. I THINK THAT THAT WAS
A GOOD DECISION FOR MANY BACK.
I'M TAKE I'M NOT THERE TO SEE
SEE YOUR RESPONSES BACK TAKE IT
THE ANSWER IS NO. IN THE TRAVEL
BAN THAT THE- EMPLOYMENT
JANUARY THIRTY ONE SO I
UNDERSTAND THAT ONLY APPLIES TO
FOREIGN NATIONALS COMING FROM
WUHAN. BUT NOT INCLUDE A
PERMANENT RESIDENCE OR FAMILY
MEMBERS ON. WE'RE OUT. AMERICAN
CITIZENS. COULD THAT
SIGNIFICANTLY LIMITS THE
BENEFIT OF THAT OUR TRAVEL BAN.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION MR
CONGRESSMAN IS RIDGEFIELD CDC-
YEAH CORY BRIEFLY IF YOU WORK
AS EITHER THOSE INDIVIDUALS
THOSE INDIVIDUALS IS AMERICAN
CITIZENS ARE AVOID COMING
AMERICA WELL UP THEY WENT TO
DAY QUARANTINE. AT THE CORE HE
WAS FORCED TO SURRENDER. ASK A
FEW OTHER QUESTIONS ABOUT
COMMUNICATION- I AM SURE THAT
EVERYONE OF YOU WHO WHO'S VERY
CAREFUL YOUR COMMUNICATE. RIGHT
NOW YES. WHEN THE PRESIDENT
SPENT ON FEBRUARY. TWENTY THREE
TWENTY TWENTY THE STOCK MARKET
IS STARTING TO LOOK VERY GOOD
IN THE CROWN OF. THE UNDER ALL.
IF ONE OF YOUR RECENT THAT WE
NEED RAISE YOUR HAND. N. ON
FEBRUARY TWENTY SEVEN I'M SORRY
WE DID NOT PROTECT. YOU COULD
YOU REPEAT THE CALL AGAIN. I
SAID IS THAT COMMUNICATIONS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT WE HAVE
BEFORE IS EXTREMELY GOOD AND
CAREFUL COMMUNICATORS WHICH I
THANK THEM. ON FEBRUARY TWENTY
THREE TWENTY TWENTY PRESIDENT
TRUMP INDICATED THAT THE STOCK
MARKET IS STARTING TO LOOK GOOD
IN THE VIRUS IS. UNDER CONTROL.
IS THE TABLE IN THE AGREE THAT
STATE IT'S SO GREAT YOUR HAND.
AND ANOTHER STATEMENT- WHAT IS
THAT. THE LEADER LISTEN TO ME-
YOU GOTTA GIVE THEM A CHANCE TO
RESPOND BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT HERE
DID YOU HEAR HIS QUESTION IF
YOU DON'T WANT ON THAT BUT I
JUST. ALL EVERYBODY RAISED UP
AS A NOBLE RAISES HAND UP. NEXT
ALL RIGHT. WELL FEBRUARY TWENTY
SEVEN PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID THAT
COVID NINETEEN WALKER'S
DISAPPEAR LIKE AMERICA. DO ANY
OF YOU AGAIN IF YOU AGREE WITH
THAT STATE. BY PRESIDENT TRUMP
AT THAT TIME SO RAISE YOUR HAND.
OKAY NO HANDS WERE RAISED PETER
MAX AND FINALLY THE PRESIDENT
TRUMP INDICATED ON MARCH NINE
IT THAT THAT COVID. MUST
APPROVAL TO THE COMMON FLU. I
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY DR FUNCTION
YOU'RE FEARFUL ABOUT THE FLU
MAKING THE SITUATION WORSE OKAY
DO YOU AGREE THAT THE
COMPARISON BETWEEN. ON SLOW.
YOU HAVE TO PUT YOUR MY CONTACT
INFO SORRY IS NOT THE COMMON
FLU. OKAY THANK YOU I SEE MY
TIME IS UP I YIELD BACK. ALL
RIGHT THANKS A LOT. MR JOHNSON
OF OHIO IS RECOGNIZED FOR FIVE
MINUTES. WELL THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND- RANKING MEMBER
WALL THEM AND TO OUR WITNESSES-
ESPECIALLY OUR WITNESSES TAKING
YOUR CRITICAL. AT TEN THE WORLD
RICHARD CALGARIANS OBVIOUSLY
YOU'RE NOT OUT OF THE WOODS. IS
BARRISTER AND SO YOU'RE STILL
WINDS UP. YOU KNOW I WANT TO
SHIFT YOUR A LITTLE BIT AND
TALK ABOUT SOMETHING I DON'T
THINK I'VE HEARD ANYBODY ELSE
TALK ABOUT YOU KNOW DURING THIS.
OPEN PANDEMIC AND THE
ASSOCIATED LOCKDOWNS AND
DISTANCE. DISTANCING ORDERS-
MANY VULNERABLE AMERICANS FOR
THE FIRST TIME. BECAME ISOLATED.
TO GET HEALTH CARE IN
SOUTHEASTERN OHIO WHERE I LIVE
IN ACROSS ROLL AMERICA
UNFORTUNATELY THIS CAN BE DONE
LD EVEN IN NORMAL TIMES. B. R.
A. I. PLUS DRIVE AWAY OR SO
DIDN'T GO UP AND CHECK FOR DAYS
BECAUSE AN ELDERLY PERSON MIGHT
ACT. ANALOG CLOSE BY TO DROP
THEM DIRECTOR. USING TELEHEALTH
CAN HELP ALLEVIATE THIS PROBLEM
TELEHEALTH HAS BEEN A PRIORITY
OF MINE FOR A LONG TIME AND
IT'S TAKEN ON A NEW SENSE OF
URGENCY WITH SO MANY. YOUNG MEN.
HE FINDING IT CONTENT HAZARDOUS
LEAVE THEIR OWN DID NINE. I'M
REALLY PLEASED THAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP AND HIS ADMINISTRATION
USE THE EMERGENCY AUTHORITY
THAT CONGRESS GAVE THEM. TO
REMOVE REGULATIONS AND RED TAPE
THREE. ROBUST I'LL TELL THE NET
RESULT. COUNTLESS HONORABLE
AMERICANS NOW HAVE ACCESS TO
THEIR BLOCKED. FROM SAFETY
THEIR OWN INSURING CAUGHT
BEFORE ESSENTIAL. YOU SHOULD
HAVE TO PAY. UNDER AFTER.
TAKING A OF THE SAFE NEW
SERVICES THEY LOVE THE
CONVENIENCE OF IT AND THE
IMMEDIATE ACCESS TO CARE THEY
TELL ME THEY DON'T WANT TO GO
BACK TO THE WAY THAT THAT WAS
BEFORE. I'M FOR MAKE YES ALL
AMERICANS ESPECIALLY THE MOST
VULNERABLE AMONG US AND SHOULD
ENTER FAB JETLINER SPENT WITH
YOU DO YOU BELIEVE THAT
TELEHEALTH PRACTICE THIS IS
VIRGIN. VISITS CAN BE
UNAFFECTED TO HOLD NOTHING GOOD
FROM PROTECT THEM HOLDING ITS
LOWS IN THE ON SEPT WAY OF
COVID NINETEEN. OR EVEN IN THE
FUTURE IN FACTORS TO SPEND.
MORE IMPLEMENTED BUT AS WE LOOK
FORWARD IN THE FUTURE I THINK
YOU'RE GOING TO SEE MORE OF
THAT NOT ONLY FOR THE REASONS.
YOU BRING UP GIVEN THE SPECIFIC
SITUATION WE'RE IN NOW BUT FOR
A VARIETY OF OTHER SITUATIONS
AND I THINK I WILL JULY. YOU
CAN. ON THIS. I WOULD I WOULD
JUST LIKE TO EMPHASIZE THAT AS
WELL IS THAT- I THINK WE
LEARNED TREMENDOUS LESSONS
ABOUT THE UTILITY OF A MEDICINE
LESSONS THAT MOST OF US THOUGHT
THAT WOULD BE THE- THREE WE'LL
JUST AT. OKAY WE COULD ANYWHERE
STEVE ONLY FIVE HUNDRED HEALTH
VISIT. HERE ON THE WAY OF APRIL
FIFTEENTH THERE WAS A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND OF THEM. ALL
WE SEE TELL HELP. THIS IS.
INSTRUMENTAL IN COMBATING OUR
BURGEONING S. U. D. ISSUES
PARTICULARLY WITH USED TO
SORTER- CALIPER SCRIBING
INCREASING ACCESS TO
BUPRENORPHINE SO- I THINK ALL
THIS- WITH THEM DAYS BEHIND HER
NAME THE END THAT THE WHOLE KEY
IS GETTING HELP TO PEOPLE WHERE
THEY ARE. AND NOT MAKE COME
MAJOR THREE POINT ARE IN MY
THEY REALLY EITHER. WE'RE ALL
VERY TO RESITA TELEMEDICINE
GONE FOR. OKAY ONE DR REDFIELD
YOU KNOW YOU'RE THE LAST MONTHS
WE'VE SEEN SITUATIONS WHERE. AT
RISK ELDERLY ISOLATED
INDIVIDUALS OF MASS REGULAR
DOCTOR APPOINTMENTS AND
PREVENTATIVE HEALTH SCREENINGS
AS ONE OF AMERICA'S LEADING
PUBLIC HEALTH EXPERTS CAN YOU
SPEAK BRIEFLY TO THE DAY HERE'S
TO. HELP IN IS LOOKING TO
CONTINUE MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT THE CHECK IN WITH
THEIR SPECIAL. CALLED DR. DID
YOU SHOULD DO SO OVER EXTEND
PERIOD OF TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH PROGRESS I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT YOU KNOW AS WE
DID. LIMIT OF CHARACTER LARGELY
THE PURPOSE WAS TO KEEP CERTAIN
JURISDICTIONS FROM OVER.
DISTANCING WITH HEALTH ARE
BEING BROADLY LIMITED ACROSS
THE NATION IF YOU POINT OUT
THERE REAL HEALTH CONSEQUENCES.
ON BILLION INDIVIDUALS- MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES- INDIVIDUALS
SUBSIDIES SERVICES BUT ALSO-
YOU KNOW INDIVIDUALS WE HAVE A
MARKED DECLINE IN CHILDHOOD
IMMUNIZATION MANY PEOPLE MR
PREPRINT PREVENTIVE MEDICINE
VISITS. MAMMOGRAMS ARE PAP
SMEARS YOUR CALL PLEASE SO IT
IS REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE GET
THE HEALTH SYSTEM BACK IN
OPERATION ON THE INNER AT HELLO.
IS A CRITICAL COMPONENT
SOMETHING. NEEDS THANK. AS FOR.
THE MISSION WE WORKED MORE OR
MOVE A DIZZY BASED TO A HEALTH
SO I THINK IT'S CRITICAL WE
SEEN AN INCREASE IN. IS SEEN IN
INCREASE IMPORT DIGNITY SELF
SERVICE A BACK IN UPPER. IN IN
WHICH THE AMERICAN PUBLIC CAN
ACCESS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
BY TIME IS EXPIRED SO MISTER
CHAIRMAN I YIELD BACK. THANK
YOU. THE NEXT IS- JUMP FROM NEW
MEXICO MISTER LU HAN ON MUTE
YOUR- YOUR CONNECTION THERE.
GERMAN DR REDFIELD UNDER
FEDERAL STATUTE THE CDC IS
REQUIRED TO TREAT TRIBAL
EPIDEMIOLOGY CENTERS AS PUBLIC
HEALTH AUTHORITIES AND CHERYL
OKAY DATASETS DIRECTOR LAST
WEEK YOU INDICATED IN WRITING
FOR THE DAY. TWO WHAT IS YOUR
GERMAN. HI MANNING ON YOUR
ARTWORK I APOLOGIZE UP DR
REDFIELD LAST WEEK YOUR STAFF
INDICATED IN WRITING THAT THE
DATA SHARING ISSUE. ORDER THE
POLITICAL WERE MERELY A
MISCOMMUNICATION WITH THE
SINGLE TRIBAL EPIDEMIOLOGY
CENTERS BUT THAT ISN'T TRUE. MY
OFFICE HAS CONFIRMED THAT THIS
PROBLEM BEYOND ITS USUAL CENTER
ON THE CENTER'S REPORT THAT
THEY HAVE ENCOUNTERED PROBLEMS
OBTAINING OTHER DATASETS FROM
CDC. ON COVID NINETEEN. AFTER
YOU'RE COMING TO WORK WITH EACH
OTHER TO TRIBAL AT. CENTERS TO
ENSURE THEY GET ACT CALLED
GIGGLED THE ENTIRE THEY ARE
ENTITLED TO UNDER LOCK. YES THE
INITIAL DID YOU BROUGHT UP WAS
OBVIOUSLY AT A SIGNIFICANT
MISCOMMUNICATION BUT YOU ARE
RIGHT THAT THERE IS STILL.
ISSUE TO BE WORKED OUT OUR TEAM
IS CURRENTLY WITH ON. THE
FEMALE G. CENTER. THAT YOU CAN
DIRECT YOUR STOP RIGHT HERE NOW
TO RELEASE THAT DATA IS THAT
SOMETHING YOU'RE PREPARED TO DO.
I DIDN'T HEAR IT SORRY I DIDN'T
HEAR THE QUESTION. DR REP YOU
COULD DIRECT YOUR STAFF RIGHT
HERE AND NOW TO THAT DATA TO
THE TRIBAL EPIDEMIOLOGY. IS
THAT SOMETHING YOU'RE PREPARED
YOU. ARE WORKING M. AS WE SPEAK
ONE OF THE KEY. MAN IS MAKES.
FOR THE DATE. THAT'S IN FACT
THIRTEEN ARE ARE WORKING TO
FINALIZE THAT AS SOON AS THAT
IS FINALIZED THE MAIN IN THE
SECURITY OF THE- WE'LL BE
TRANSPLANT. GONNA BE COMPLETE.
HOPEFULLY THIS WEEK WITHIN THE
NEXT WEEK ONE TO TWO WEEKS FOR
ALL TWELVE I RESPECTED
DIRECTORS. THANK YOU GOT. THE
REPORT OF THE COMMITTEE ON WHEN
THAT'S DONE THANK YOU- THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION FAILED TO
BRING COVID NINETEEN YOU THE
EARLY MONTHS OF THE PACK. EVEN
NOW LATER TESTING. WHERE NEAR
WHERE AMERICAN NEEDED TO BEAT
ON JANUARY THIRTY FIRST
SECRETARY HE'S ARGUED THERE
COVID NINETEEN A PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY. FIVE OR SIX. CLEARED
IT THAT NEED ATTACKS CAN HAVE
ATTACKS THEY'RE ALSO THEY THEM
OUT THERE BECAUSE WILL GET ON
THE SAME DATE FEWER THAN THREE
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED K.
COMPLETED IF NOT. I NEED.
PRESIDENT AT THE END STATES
WHAT'S I MILLION PER DAY ADULT
YESTERDAY ARE WEEK HAVE UNITED
STATES CONDUCTING FIVE MILLION
TESTS PER DAY. NO WE'RE NOT
WE'RE DOING ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND SINGLE TEST PER DAY.
THAT'S MY UNDERSTANDING ABOUT
HALF A MILLION TESTS NOW NEARLY
EVERY LEADING PUBLIC HEALTH
EXPERT AGREES THAT THE
CENTERPIECE RE OPENING THE
COUNTRY APRIL BY TESTING.
ELECTIONS ONE HEALTH EXPERT IS
THAT THE LACK OF TESTING HAS
BEEN NOT ONLY A PUBLIC HEALTH
CATASTROPHE IN THE U. S. IS
ALSO THE DIRECT CAUSE OF OUR
ECONOMICS CLOSE QUOTE I'M-
DONALD YOUR ART WEEK. OLD
PROPER PROMISES ON A- MONTHS
NOW AND EVERY TIME THEY COME UP
SHORT WHAT IS GOING TO BE
DIFFERENT MOVING FORWARD. THE
UNITED STATES TO GET TO THE
FIFTY MILLION. CONGRESSMAN BUT
I DISAGREE WITH YOUR QUESTION I
DON'T BELIEVE WE'VE COME UP
SHORT EVERY TIME WE ADD
SOMETHING SINCE MARCH TWELFTH
THAT BEEN VERY FORTHRIGHT.
ABOUT WHAT WE'RE GOING TO. THE
LIMITATIONS ARE I WOULD. HR AND
THAT WE'RE OUR POSSIBLE TO IN
THAT. RIGHT WE'RE DOING FIFTY
MILLION TESTS PER MONTH ALL WE
HAVE OKAY IT FOR MORE
INTERNATIONAL TO THE- SIX.
PERCENT WERE CERTAINLY. NOW
PERCENT STATE OF TENTACLE LAB
PRODUCER OF WHAT THEY'RE DOING
WHEN THEY'RE PROVIDING IT OTHER
GONNA DO IT AND HOW MANY SWAPS
ARE GOING TO BE THERE SO ON THE
CAMPAIGN. WILL BE THERE FORTY.
CAST AT. IN THE FALL AND I HAVE.
PROVIDE INTERNAL BY MATERIAL
AND HOPEFULLY WILL BE MUCH THAN
THAT WHEN WE HAVE PULLING ON
HER SOME OF THE NEW
TECHNOLOGIES FROM THE N. FROM
BAR THAT WE COULD MOVE INTO
THAT ROUND. THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THE LEADERSHIP
RESPECT YOU VERY MUCH THE
WINNER RESULTS THIS PRESIDENT
TRUMP PROMISED FIVE MILLION
TEST THEY VERY ON APRIL. ONLY
HALF A MILLION TEXANS. FALLEN'S
OF THEY CAN YOU KNOW WHAT THE
QUARTER WITH AND WITH I YIELD
WHICH- THANK YOU. NEXT HOWEVER.
FROM HIS. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
AND DOCTOR ON NUMBER MISTER THE
POINT THE FEDERAL AGENCIES AND
PRIVATE INDUSTRY TO STOP OUR
PROCESS FOR THE DEVELOPMENT
NINETY FIVE YEARS OLD MY
THIRTIES. RIGHT STARBUCKS.
FORTY THREE AND A HALF DAYS SET
UP ONE OF MY THREE MONTHS.
PROGRAM FOR C. TACTIC CALL. YOU
CAN ABOUT THE FDA ON THE BALLOT
NINE ERIC UNDER KLOPP WORKS
READ AND HOW DOES THAT F.
INTEGRATED ALL THINGS ON. THANK
YOU. QUESTION THE APPROXIMATELY
TEN WEEKS AGO FDA STOOD UP
BECAUSE HE TAPPED CORONAVIRUS
TRIPPING CELEBRATION PROPERTIES
YOU MENTIONED THAT WAS OF RIGHT
ISNS ONE IS WE INDEED SALARY TO
DEVELOPMENT IF THERE. I ON THE-
PEOPLE BUT DO YOU KNOW ROBUST
WAY LOOKED AT THE SCIENCE AND
DATA ON WE ARE TOLD GOTTEN
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER THAT AND AT
THIS POINT SENATE IS DOUBLE THE
NORMAL APPLICATIONS THAT WE
HAVE. RACE I'M- BECAUSE THAT WE
HI ON HAPPENING BASED UPON TIME.
AND HIGHEST PRIORITIES OF
SCIENCE. HELLO A CROSS OF A
MEDICAL PRODUCTS CHAPELIZOD US
TO PRIORITIZE HE AT THE SCIENCE
AND THEN ADDRESS THOSE
APPLICATIONS BECAUSE WE WANTED
TO DO. IS THAT WE INCREASE ON
THE APPLICATIONS. DRESSED
QUESTIONS HELP. FIFTY OTHER
POINT HERE IS THAT WE HAD
PEOPLE COME TO THE AT WHO NEVER
BOTH. DANCE WITH INDUSTRY WITH-
WITH SPONSORS WITH ACADEMIA TO
TRY TO HELP GET THROUGH THE
PROCESS A GREAT EXAMPLE OF WHAT
CAN BE DONE THE WORK WE DID
WITH AND I. TO GET AS OF YOUR
PROTOCOL RUNNING AND- IS
COMPLETED THE ULTIMATELY LED TO
AN EASY WAY. WE ARE WORKING
WITH OUR SPONSOR CERTAIN NOT
JUST OPERATION WORK SPEED BUT
WE ARE PROVIDING ALL SPONSORS
BUT INCLUDING OPERATIONS
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE WHAT ARE
THE TRIALS NEED TO BE DONE WHAT
ARE THE END POINTS THAT NEED TO
BE LAW AT OKAY. THE RATE THOSE.
THE DESIGN. AT OKAY THANK YOU
AFTER THE YEARS BUT THAT H. OF
WORK ROLL AS PART OF A WALK BE
EDITOR FOR CHURCH ALREADY
MANUFACTURING ASKED THE WOMAN.
FOR THAT MATTER. OUR EXANE A
CALL THANK YOU VERY FOR THAT
QUESTION VERY IMPORTANT BECAUSE
AND THAT WAS ONE OF THE THINGS
I REFERRED OUR ON AUGUST THAT.
THIS ONE OF THE VERY IN WAR
SPEED THAT THEY'RE IS THE
EMPLOYEE OF CONTRACTING ORGAN.
WHO ALREADY SCALING UP TO
DEVELOP VACCINES PARTICULARLY
THE FIRST ONE THAT I MENTIONED
THAT WILL GO INTO EFFECT THREE
TRUMP ALL JULY AS ALREADY HAD
CONTRACTED THROUGH HHS AND- FOR
THE PRODUCTION THE CONTRACTING
ORGANISED OF HUNDREDS OF
MILLION. COMMITTEE TWO TWO
VEHICLES AT THE END OF THE YEAR
IN THE FIRST. OF TWO TWENTY
ONE. OKAY YEAH THANK YOU OUT A
LITTLE CONFUSED AT YOUR OPENING
REMARK OR PREVENT HER ALONG I
CAN'T REMEMBER EXACTLY
EVERYTHING THAT I'VE HEARD
WONDERING ABOUT THAT'S THE LACK
OR- AND- ON I'LL GO BACK.
LOOKING LONG. YEAH HEY BOB
WORKS THE MASS WHEN IF OF KURTZ.
THIS IS A VERY ISSUE AND I
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING UP WE
HAVE A- ON EXIT WE REGULATE
ISSUES RELATED TO READ EMAIL
AND I TEND TO THE IN. HERE
WHERE DO CUSTOMER I HAVE A LOT
OF DIFFICULTY GIVE. AND HAVING
ACCESS TO THOSE SUPPLIES BOTH
PRESERVE THANK SEARCHES. OF
PHARMACEUTICAL PRECURSORS AS
WELL AS FINAL FISH FINISHED
FORM OF THE BUGS ON NTP SO.
MUCH WE WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON
THE COVID SYSTEMS BECAUSE MY
FACTION AND UPON OUR- THIS. YOU
TO HELP I THE MAIN IS THAT TO A
QUALITY PRODUCT WE VERY ARE
LEANING ON THEIR IS ONE OF OUR
MAJOR INITIATIVES FOR ADVANCED
ACTION PLASTIC MANY FACTORS IN.
VERY GOOD TO WORK WITH CONGRESS
ON THIS I THINK THIS IS A
PRETTY IMPORTANT ON. ON AND THE
MORE WE CAN DO CAPTION HOMES
AND PROVIDE THAT REDUNDANCY TO
THE SUPPLY CHAIN. RALPH WILL BE
IN THE- THANK YOU. OKAY I'M
THANK LAW SO DO. ALL TWO
BILLION TO TANGO OF NEW. UNMUTE.
THIS ATTACK ARE YOU MUTED. ERIC
YEP NOW WE CAN YEAH OKAY THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND THANK
YOU TO OUR PANELISTS. FOR ALL
THE ETHNIC STRAIGHT LAST ARE
PARTICIPATING IN A TELEPHONE
TOWN HALL WITH MY CONSTITUENTS
ARE. SIMPLE QUESTION RUBY
INSPECTED E. R. WHICH I HAD NO
GOOD ANSWER STRAIGHTFORWARD LET
GOVERNMENT IS. A MASK IN PUBLIC
WHITE IS PRESIDENT TRUMP
REFUSED TO WEAR WHAT SO AFTER
ABOUT SHE WAS SET THE RECORD
STRAIGHT WHAT DOES THE EVIDENCE
TELL US ABOUT THE BAND OF ASKED
FOR THIS CODE. WHEN IT COMES TO
TRANSMITTING CONTRACT COVID.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
CONGRESSMAN SO. ALTHOUGH WE
DON'T KNOW THE EXACT PERCENTAGE
WE CAN SAY VERY CLEARLY THAT
WEARING A MASK IS DEFINITELY
HELPFUL IN PREVENTING
ACQUISITION AS WELL AS
TRANSMISSION THE DATA. YOUR
WEARING A MASK AND IF YOU ARE
INADVERTENTLY NOT KNOWING
YOU'RE INFECTED PROTECTING YOU
FROM INFECTING ON OUT IS
STRONGER THAN EVER THAN THE
DATA THAT SAYS WILL BE
PROTECTED HOW. ONE AGREES IN
THE HEALTH SECTOR. BRING OF
MASKS IS BENEFICIAL IT MAY NOT
BE PERFECT AS WE OFTEN SAY
WHERE IT AND DON'T LET THE
PERFECT BE THE ENEMY OF THE
GOOD IT IS ALWAYS BETTER TO
HAVE A MASK ON. NOT BEST ON AT
ISSUE AND FOR. THANK YOU AND I
LISTENED EARLIER THE- IN THE
HEARING TO MY FRIEND. YOUR
PAPADOPOULOS SPIKE IN NUMBERS
IN TEXAS ERIC COULD HELP THE
THAT PRECAUTIONARY EFFORT COME
TO PRIME IMPORTANCE THEY CAN BE
DEFINED WRITTEN OR THEY CAN BE.
SHARED BY EXAMPLE AND SO- HI
FORTUNATELY WITNESSES TODAY
JAMES BELIEVE HE IS ABOUT THIS
EVIDENCE BASED RECOMMENDATION
YOU JUST DESCRIBED. L. AS
PROJECT IT. ARE YOU THERE
RATHER POP. PUBLIC ONLY IF YOU
TO BE SEEN ON CAMERA WHERE A
FACE. BUT LAST WEEK HE CLAIM
THAT SOME OF ARE MASS AS A WAY
TO SAY THIS OF YEAH NOW I THINK.
GET A LEAD. AT MORE OF CANARY
INSTRUCT. IS REQUIRE OF THE
PRESS AND A OF US A WE SHOULD
BE SETTING THE RIGHT EXAMPLE.
TWO AND THREE SO DOCTOR ARE
CHEAPER WHERE FACED. AT IS
AFTER TO POLICE THE OF MASK.
SEND THE WRONG MESSAGE ABOUT
THE ADVICE COMING. HELP EXPERTS
LIKE YOURSELF AND OTHERS WHO
ARE AFTER EXPERT TABLE. YOU
KNOW I DON'T THINK I CAN
COMMENT ON. WHAT WHAT THE
PRESIDENT'S- THE MULTIPLE
FACTORS THAT GO INTO THE
PRESIDENT'S NOT WEARING A MASK
CERTAINLY. I WEAR A MASK PUBLIC
ALL THE TIME NOT ONLY BECAUSE I
WANT TO PROTECT OTHERS AND TO
PROTECT MYSELF BUT ALSO TO SET
AN EXAMPLE SO I GUESS THAT IN
YOUR QUESTION. IT WOULD DIRECT.
RESIDENTS WAS A BASKETBALL IF
SO WHAT WOULD THAT YOU RECEIVED.
I HAVE NOT DIRECT HE
RECOMMENDED TO THE PRESIDENT TO
WEAR A MASK BUT I THINK IT'S
VERY CLEAR TO ANYBODY IN THE
COUNTRY. BECAUSE I TALK ABOUT
IT SO OFTEN OF THE IMPORTANCE
OF HAVING PHYSICAL DISTANCE
WITH ASKED AND IF YOU ALL ARE.
GOING TO BE EITHER BEYOND YOUR
CONTROL OF BY YOUR OWN CHOICE
IN A CROWD IT IS IN IF TO WEAR
A MASK AT ALL TIMES. THANK YOU.
YEAH I'M THIRD I THE RELEASE
DIED IT'S RECOMMENDING THE USE
A FACE MASKS OR FACE COVERINGS
IN PUBLIC SETTINGS SUCH AS
GROCERY STORES AND MORE
RECENTLY. YES BACKED UP DAYS
SUGGESTING THAT EMPLOYEES- THAT
WAS PART THAT HE WOULD. THEY
STOP. BOTH PROMOTING THEIR USE
WHEN IS TO RAISE IT OR ARE.
WHAT IS THE A AT A CULTURE
ARRAY JUST OR AT A RALLY SO
WHAT PROMPTED THE NEW FOR THESE
RECORDS. WHAT IS THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC NEEDS TO KNOW ABOUT THE
USE OF FACE MASKS AND WHETHER
AND WHEN. THAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE QUESTION
CONGRESSMAN I WANT TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS DR FAT SHE MADE. YOU
KNOW OUR RECOMMENDATIONS ARE
CLEAR ONE OF THE MOST POWERFUL
WEAPON. AGAINST THIS VIRUS. THE
WHAT FOR AND THAT IT SHOULD.
FACE COVERINGS AND OUR ABILITY
TO PRACTICE RIGOROUS HAND TIED.
ON CLUB LEVEL WE RECOGNIZE THAT
SYMPTOM TRANSFER YOUR PRE
SYMPTOMATIC TRANSMISSION WAS
STIFF AND- THAT'S WHAT CLEARLY
ONE. IN THAT ALL INDIVIDUALS.
WHERE IN ORDER TO YEAH OTHER
END OF IN CASE THEY WERE A
SYMPTOM AND WE CONTINUE TO
RECOMMEND THAT OF OUR RECENT
GUIDANCE ON ON MASS GATHERINGS
BEGIN TRYING TO ILLUSTRATE THE
IMPORTANCE OF TRYING TO
MAINTAIN SOME SOCIAL DISTANCING
AND THE WORST. AND IS THAT WHAT
YOU SAID VENT YOU'RE NOT GOING
TO MAINTAIN THAT DISTANCE IT'S
CRITICAL THAT YOU WEAR FACE
COVERING. WELL I THINK IT'S
UNFORTUNATE THAT LIKE SO MUCH
OF THE ADMINISTRATION'S
RESPONSE THE MESSAGE FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE ON YOUR MIND IT'S
COMING FROM PUBLIC HEALTH
EXPERTS. OR BUT THE MAYOR. WITH
THAT I GET BACK THERE WELL LIKE
THAT. THANK YOU MR TACO NEXT IS
THE MR FLORES FROM TEXAS. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN I WANT TO THANK
EACH FOR WHAT IS THIS FOR
APPEARING TODAY. RIGHT INTERNET
ACCESS IS A LITTLE BIT SPOTTY
TONIGHT SO HOPEFULLY ON TO BE
ABLE TO HEAR ME- A LOT. OF BRAG
ON THE MINISTRATION WITNESS
DISORDER HERE TODAY. FOR THE
RESPONSE TO THE SARS COPY TO.
SPREAD ALL GET WE HAVE A SERVER
NEVER KNEW THERAPEUTICS UNDER
WAY WITH GO SEVERAL BACK ARE
ABOUT. WE'VE HAD HUGE CHANGE IN
THE SUPPLY OF JUST MATERIAL PP.
ON THEM. ON THE REGULAR
RESPONSE DEAL WITHOUT CLEARING
OUT THE ROADBLOCKS THAT WOULD
TYPICALLY UP IN. POLICE BEEN.
OKAY GREAT EXAMPLE IS THE HUGE
EXPANSION IN TELEMEDICINE.
WHICH IS. IN. LASTLY WE-
DESPITE SOME OF HISTORY TO
PROMOTE THEIR PRE. DR BALAJI
MADE A UP A PRETTY. ON IT THE
STATEMENT- EARLIER IN THIS
HEARING WAS TALKING ABOUT. THE
REASON THAT THINGS ARE
DIFFERENT REGION BY REGION AND
I'D LIKE TO TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE RESPONSES THAT WERE
DONE REGION BY REGION AND SO
HERE ARE SOME STATE LEVELS THE
STATE'S NINETEEN IS IN CUSTODY.
YORK STATE HAS 6% THE POPULISTS.
BUT 22% OF THE TOTAL U. S.
DEATHS. MICHIGAN HAS 3% OF THE
US POPULATION BUT IT HAS ABOUT
5% OF THE W. YES. IF YOU LOOK
AT MY HOME STATE OF ISRAEL AND
PERSONAL POPULATION LONELY
WORSEN THE DEATHS. THEY GET
EASIER SPOT RAZOR OF YET. THE
TOP SEVEN STATE IT'S SO THERE
REPRESENTS A PERCENT OF ALL THE
ARE IN BY THE GOVERNORS. WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE US THE CASE IS
THE DEATH YORK STATES BUT RIGHT
OF SIX PER EMISSION MICHIGAN'S
IS NOT PERCENT. RESPECT IS 3%
SO WHAT CONCERNS MAYOR THE
STARK DIFFERENCES IN THE
TELEGRAPH IN SOME STATES
PERSPECTIVE DOUBTS THERE
PERCENT POPULAR. IT'S OBVIOUS
THAT SOME GOV MADE BEST. BUT
WHEN I MUCH OF THAT TO.
INTERESTING THE SPREAD OF SARS
TWO. IT'S INTERESTING THAT
WHILE THOSE GOVERNORS WERE
COMPLAINING ABOUT PRESIDENT
TRUMP THEY WERE IGNORING. THEIR
OWN POPULATIONS. SO WHITE I
THINK WE ARE TALKING. OUR
ELDERLY AT RISK POPULATION WHO
CONTRACTED COVID NINETEEN LET'S
START WITH THE STATS. IN
MICHIGAN NINETY NINE AND THE
SEVEN. IN TERM CARE PRESS.
THREE IN YOUR THAT NUMBER WAS
SIXTY TWO HUNDRED IN FLORIDA
THAT NUMBER IS ONLY SIXTEEN
HUNDRED THIRTY SEVEN IN THIS IS
DESPITE THE FLORIDA HAS A LONG
TERM CARE POPULATION. BOTH
MICHELLE. WORK IN MICHIGAN
STATE OFFICIALS DECLINED A
PROPOSAL TO USE NEW VACANT
UNLICENSED FACILITIES TO HELP.
PATIENTS WHO TESTED POSITIVE
FOR COVID NINETEEN. INSTEAD
MICHIGAN BUT THOSE GRETCHEN
WHITMER SIGNAL. NURSING HOMES
WITH OTHER UNAFFECTED BY. IT IS
PREVIOUSLY IN HIS HEARING NEW
YORK THE TO HELP DEPARTMENT
NURSE HOMES OF REHAB CENTER
STATE SEPT COVID PATIENTS WHO
WERE DISCHARGED FROM HOSPITALS
THIS LED TO MORE THAN FORTY
FIVE HUNDRED PATIENTS
SUGGESTING POSSIBLE NINETEEN
BEING BACK AT LONGER. THESE TO
FLORIDA WERE STATE ON A PARTIAL
AGENCY. OKAY DON'T TREAT
PATIENTS WITH COPD NINETEEN. SO
MARK. FOR DOCTOR VETERANS BACK
RIP IMMERSE. IS A NEW THERE BE
CURED GROUP OVER HIS LONG TERM
CARE FOR COMPARED EITHER
MICHIGAN'S OR DO YOUR- THE LONG
TERM CARE. OR DO YOU OUR- SO
CAN YOU TALK ABOUT THESE
APPROACHES ELDERLY CARE AND
PUTTING COLD THANK YOU POSTED
THANKS IN OUR HOMES WITH DONNA
NATIONS WOULD GET. YOU WERE THE
TO STAY AND BEST OF OUR SENIORS
SO DOCTORS. WELL OBVIOUSLY WITH
YOU PUT SOMEONE. WHO IS A
POTENTIALLY INFECTED PATIENT.
INTO A NURSING HOME THERE'S A
RISK OF THERE BEING SPREAD. OUT
I THINK. YOU GAVE A LOT OF
DATA. IN A LOT OF SITUATIONS IN
WHICH THERE REALLY WAS A MOVING
TARGET AND WHETHER OR NOT THERE
REALLYAS. A CITY TO THE
VISUALS AND SO I REALLY FEEL
UNCOMFORTABLE IN COMMENTING
THAT THAT WAS HAVING TROUBLE
FOLLOWING EACH AND EVERY ONE OF
THE- OF THE OF THE DATA POINT
YOU WILL GET BUT- NOT ANY. ON
SEPTEMBER ELEVENTH. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IN TWO TO
FOUR. FOR AND WE'RE WORKING TRY
TO UNDERSTAND THE- THE MULTI
VARIANCE IF YOU HAVE POINTED
OUT THAT AT LEAST ON THE CASES.
OF HAS BEEN DIFFERENTIAL. BODY
BOTH IN DIFFERENT JURISDICTIONS.
AS WELL AS IN THE TERM CARE
FACILITIES IN DIFFERENT
JURISDICTIONS. AND REALLY LOOK
AT MULTI FACTORS JUST EIGHT.
THAT IF THEY ARE CONTROLLED FOR
WELL YOU NEED TO KNOW. LEADER
POINT. THEY ARE LOOKING AT IT.
THIS I'M NOT CERTAIN WHICH HAVE
PRO TO DEAL WITH NUMBER MANY
THANKS WERE TO YOUR DOCTOR FOR.
THIS THE WORST THE I DON'T
THINK ON THE- TO EVALUATE THAT
THAT IS NOT IN MY PURVIEW OF
ANYTHING I'M RESPONSIBLE. I
WOULD JUST SAY THAT. BE A
CONGRESSMAN IF YOU LOOK AT IT
AS I SAID BEFORE CONSEQUENCES
AND IMPACT ME. CONSEQUENCES AND
IMPACT IS OBVIOUSLY ONE ONCE
ELDERLY AS YOU POINTED OUT
THAT. THERE SHOULD. CLEARLY
WELL I'M NOT WILLING TO ENTER
SPECULATE ON WITHOUT DOING
CONTROLLING FOR THE DIFFERENT
VARIABLES THAT WE HAVE
INDIVIDUALS WITH THE SEC THE
EXTENT OF COMORBIDITIES. THOSE
TWO NURSING HOMES THAT THE I
THINK THAT INVESTIGATION. WILL
BE COMPLETE AND WILL BE
UNDERSTANDING OF WHY THERE IS
DIFFERENTIAL MORTALITY IN
NURSING HOMES AS WELL AS LONG
AS THERE'S DIFFERENTIAL TELL IF
INSURERS RESIST YOU POINT.
THANK YOU MINS WILL IS. THANK
YOU LAST YOU TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION SO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR BACK NOW WE GO TO IOWA MR
LOEBSACK. ANOTHER RIGHT THANK.
I SHOULD BE A MUTED ON MY ON
THE OTHER YEP YOU'RE GOOD. OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU GENERAL
BLOWN AND- A TEAM MEMBER
WALDEN- UP WITH US ON. THIS
IMPORTANT HEARING TODAY AND I
WANT TO THANK ALL THESE
WITNESSES FOR. EXPERT TESTIMONY.
SEVERAL MONTHS EUROPEAN FOLKS
TO LEAVE THE THROUGH I HAVE
CLOSE THAT IN THE SPRING OF
WOULD BE HERE TO. WELL YOU JOIN
THE PANEL BELIEVE THAT CONGRESS
NEEDS A FOR UNDERSTANDING.
BOBBY ADMINISTRATOR. SOURCE
NEEDS OF HOT LITTLE. BUT SINCE
SHE IS NOT HERE TWO OF THE
PEOPLE FOR ARE AS THE IS
SECRETARY FOR HEALTH I THINK
THE TERM ON A DOCTOR THAT YOU
KIND OF ANSWERED THIS QUESTION
ALREADY. BUT ARE. DO YOU
BELIEVE THAT OUR HEALTH CARE
GROUP. THERE'S FRONT LINES WITH
A HOUSE I HAVE THE PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT SUPPLIES
AND RESOURCES THAT THEY NEED
TODAY AT THIS PARTICULAR MOMENT.
TWO TODAY AT THIS PARTICULAR
MONTH. THEY HAVE THE SUPPLIES
THAT THEY NEED AT AND LET ME
TELL YOU WHEN WE GET A REPORT
OF A NURSING HOME OTHER FIT
BODY THAT'S THEY DON'T.
LITERALLY WE CALL THIS IS IN I
UNDERSTAND WHAT THEIR NEEDS ARE
SO ON AT THIS POINT IN TIME I
THINK WILL MEET THOSE NEEDS
AGAIN THE CHALLENGES ARE IF THE
FIRST. PERSON OR WE HAVE A
SECOND WAVE ON TO BE ABLE TO
MEET THOSE AND THAT THE SNS TWO
POINT OH A MAKE SURE WE AT
LEAST NINETY DAYS YES SIR. ONE
TWO FUTURE IF YOU WILL BUT
BEFORE IT THAT DO WANT TO ASK
ON THE PANEL WHETHER HE AGREES
THAT IT IS LIKELY THAT WE WILL
IN FACT SEE A SECOND WAVE AND
OTHERS A LOT RIGHT NOW WHETHER.
THE FIRST WAVE. SURE
DISPROPORTIONAL ON THE
DIFFERENT REGIONS ARE AT
DEALING WITH THE DEATH IN
DIFFERENT WAYS ON OUR FEELING
DIFFERENT AFFECTS ON IT AS WELL.
WHAT IF I COULD JUST GO DOWN
THE PANEL BEGINNING WITH DOCTOR
REFUSED ENTRY A SIMPLE YES
ANSWER DO YOU BELIEVE THAT IT
IS LIKELY THAT WE WILL SEE A
SECOND. RIGHT YOU FOR. YEAH
IT'S HIM I AM I'M NOT SURE I
WOULD CALL THE WAY BUT I WANTED
TO MAKE IT CLEAR WE ARE GOING
TO EXPERIENCE SIGNIFICANT
CORONAVIRUS. IN IN THE FALL
AFTER TWENTY TWENTY OKAY TWENTY
ONE. THANK YOU DR VOTING. THIS
CERTAIN WHO WILL BE CORONAVIRUS
INFECTIONS IN THE FALL AND
WINTER. IRIS IS GOING TO
DISAPPEAR IT'S- THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THAT ALL OUR DOCTOR
HAN. I'M GOOD WITH TECH AS
VALJEAN REDFIELD. THANK YOU A
LOT ABOUT THE LAST OF TO DRAW A
LITTLE BIT OF THE OF THE AISLE
PLACED ON FALLEN. BECAUSE I DO
WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT GOING
FORWARD. EIGHT SHOPS. FOR
TAKING TO HELP HOSPITALS AND
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS PREPARE
FOR ALL POTENTIAL OR PERHAPS A
LIKELY IF YOU WILL SECOND WAY
SURGEON CASES ON THE COMING
MONTHS. DR DRIVE OKAY R. THANK
YOU I DON'T WANNA TAKE UP ALL
YOUR TIME BECAUSE IT'S REALLY
EVERYTHING FROM. OUR
UNDERSTANDING WHAT THE NEEDS
ARE TO UNDERSTANDING SUPPLY
CHAINS DOWN TO THE INDIVIDUAL
HOSPITALS DO IT LIKE I SAID
WHEN WE STARTED OUT IT WAS
IMPOSSIBLE. TO KNOW SUPPLIES
WITH YOU JACK LEE WHAT THEM
BEING USED. WOULD GO THROUGH
THAT ALL WAY TO THE THERAPY.
ROYDS HOPEFULLY PLASMA ALL
THESE THINGS AND EVERYTHING IN
BETWEEN- IT'S REALLY ALL HANDS
ON DECK AND OUR TASK FORCES.
ARE STILL OPERATIONAL IN THE
HOSPITAL INSTEAD FORCED. THAT
IT ONLY DEALING WITH IT BUT IF
THIS HAPPENS AGAIN WE DON'T
WANT OUR IMMUNIZATION
DEPARTMENT WE DON'T HER
MAMMOGRAMS. ON OUR- CANCER THE
POINT. IS THE- VICTIMS OF THE
COVID RESPONSE. JUST LIKE COVID
TIONS WERE SO DIFFICULT. OKAY
WELL WHAT DO UNDER YOUR-
SPECIAL WHEN THEY COULD. ONE
CONCERN BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO BE
READY FOR COVID. AND WE DID
PASSED ALL OF. CONGRESS
OBVIOUSLY PROVIDE A HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND FIGHTERS
RESPONSES IN LOST REVENUE. WHAT
IS THE STATUS DR DRIVE THE NEXT
APPLICATIONS REMAINING FUNDING
THAT IF HE DISTRIBUTED THE
PROVIDER FUND. I SORRY I HAVE
TO TAKE THAT ONE FOR THE RECORD
BECAUSE EQUATORIA ON THE PEOPLE
ON THAT AT A REAL. BUT WE'LL BE
HAPPY TO SUPPLY THAT HE TO
YOUTH. FORTY THAT'S MY TIMES
ARE. ABLE THANK YOU ALL THANK
YOU DR DRE ON THANK YOU MA'AM
FORM THEY GO BACK MR CHAIRMAN
BEFORE YOU PROCEED YES I DO.
YOUR ON SOCIAL MEDIA ABOUT
DOCTOR. STRANGE S. ON THE END.
THERE A. DO YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENT. LOG I'M IN A WASHING
NATIONAL FAN SO I THOUGHT I
WOULD UP THIS A LITTLE BIT
PUTTING ON MY WASHINGTON
NATIONAL MASS. OKAY. THANK YOU
TO THE NEXT. THIS IS BROOKS.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND-
THANK YOU ALL SO VERY MUCH
GOTTEN IN THINKING ABOUT THAT
THE NATURAL THAT WE MISSED ALL
OF THEM WILL. FALL A- LITTLE
BIT ABOUT WHAT. TESTED WITH
RESPECT TO SUSTAINABILITY OF
FUNDING- DR REDFIELD- I THINK
FOR DECADES WE HAVE UNDER
INVESTED. IN OUR NATION'S
PUBLIC HEALTH STRUCTURE CAN YOU
TELL US WHAT IT IS WE NEED TO
DO ON ALL MENTION THIS STAIN.
BOB TALK WITH US WHAT'S WOULD
BE VERY. NOT JUST FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT STATE AND LOCAL WHAT
WE NEED TO DO I TO ROUTE TO
REALLY THINK ABOUT- OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE IN THIS
COUNTRY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CONGRESS WOMAN ITSELF ON POLL.
AND I'VE SAID. THIS IS THE TIME
BECAUSE FOR DECADES WE HAVE
UNDER INVESTED IN WHAT I CALL
THE CORE CAPABILITIES PUBLIC
UPDATED DATA ANALYTICS AND
PREDICTIVE DATA ANALYSIS I
WOULD FOR RESILIENCE PUBLIC
HEALTH WORK FOR. EMERGENCY
RESPONSE FOREMAN AND- YOU'RE
THE AROUND THE NOSE ALL THE
THINGS THAT YOU THINK EVERYONE
STATE LOCAL AND FEDERAL OUGHT
TO BE IMPOSED AGAIN IN HIGHER
LEVEL AND WE NEED TO DO IT IN
WELL. WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT IF.
THE I PROBABLY SPEND CLOSE TO
SEVEN TRILLION DOLLARS. RIGHT
BECAUSE OF ONE LITTLE VIRUS
THAT CAME WHICH WE RECOGNIZE
VERY EARLY WE USE THE CAPACITY
THAT WE HAVE AND YOU KNOW I
SAID YOU KNOW THE CRITICS WILL
BE THERE WILL DO THE POST ORDER
MORE DAY WE WILL. THE WEEK. R.
S. OKAY NOW IT'S TIME IT'S GOOD
CHOIRS A SUSTAINED INVESTMENT
IN IN TERMS OF THE CORE
CAPABILITY MANY OF YOU MAY NOT
KNOW THE NUANCES OF STATE
FUNDING FOR THE EIGHT THE IRA
SHE BUT THERE OR FOUR. THREE
TWENTY BE A PROVIDED BY TIME.
WE NEED PUBLIC HEALTH FUNDING
IN MANY NUMBER RIGHT NOW THAT
CDC PROVIDE UP 270% OF THE POLL
ONE FOR STATE. WHO WELL PUMP
STATION SOMEBODY WE GOT OF
INVESTOR IN THAT IN A STATE OF
WAY WITH PURPOSE THAT THAT'S
CORE BASE FUNDING AND MY
STATE'S ALSO INVESTED- LEVELS
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT I THINK
YOU SAID THAT THERE THIS NEEDS
TO BE A SHIP RIGHT. ALL THE.
PUBLIC HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE
ACROSS THIS NATION WOULD JUST
CRASH. AND RIGHT NOW THE
BACKBONE OF AND WE WILL EACH
SHOULD BE A PARTNERSHIP THANK
YOU WANT TO TALK TO A DOCTOR
DONALD BUT ABOUT OPERATION
WORKS. REALLY LIKE IT AFTER
IT'S A GROUP PROJECT WE ARE THE
UNITED STATES IS THE GLOBAL
LEADER IN VACCINE DEVELOPMENT-
BUT I TO TELL YOU. BECAUSE WE
ARE WORKING AT WORK. AND YOUR
COMPANIES THAT YOU'RE WORKING
WITH ON ALL OF THE AGENCIES AND
I THREE ONE. WORKS IT WORKS.
THERE MANY. SIR SCENES AND
EFFICACY AND THAT WHEN WE TO
THE POINT HOPEFULLY IS AT THE
END OF THIS YEAR OR NEXT YEAR
WHERE ONE OF THESE EX AND GET.
I'M YOU WHAT TELL THE PEOPLE ON
THE WORLD IN WAYS BACK THE
EFFICACY IN THE STATE THAT
WE'RE TAKING TO. THE THAT FOR
EVERYONE TO USE AND HE COMES ON
BROOKS REALLY APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION DR FAUCI CERTAINLY AS
A WORLD EXPERT CAN SPEAK TO
VACCINE DEVELOPED I CAN TELL
YOU FROM THE REGULATORY PROCESS
D. A. WE HAVE WORKED IN EXPERT.
ONE OF EX. EFFICACY THANKS TO
FDA THE WORLD LOOK TO YOU
ACTUALLY MAY THOSE S. WHAT I
CAN PROMISE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ON WE WILL WORK WITH COMPANIES
WE WORK WITH OPERATE FEED TO
PROVIDE THE SENSE OF THE
STUDIES DONE WRITING FOR ME BUT
WE- LOOK AT DATA WILL MAKE IT
IN THE BEST INTEREST OF THE
WITH SAFETY. WE USE THAT.
ACTUALLY GUESS THE START YOU
BEFORE GOING TO TURKEY SIDE SO
DO YOU LIKE TO SAY YES CAN
PEOPLE I THINK THAT THAT ON SET
VERY WELL BUT I JUST WANT TO
EMPHASIZE YOU KNOW IT WAS GOOD
INTENTIONS ABOUT USING THE WORD
WAR II BUT I'M- CHANGE THE- YOU
KNOW THE PEOPLE THINK IT'S-
GORSUCH. EIGHT IT THERE ARE
RISKS BUT THE RISKS ARE. SIX
AND THAT'S WHAT PEOPLE NEED ON
THIS THAT NOT COMPROMISING THE
SAFETY. THE COMPROMISE OF
SCIENTIFIC INTEGRITY WHEN YOU
DO A VACCINE ON THE NON
EMERGENT CONDITIONS THERE ARE
VARIOUS STEPS AND COST
COMPANIES MAKE INVESTMENTS AND
THIS WHAT THEY DO IS THEY DON'T
MAKE AN INVESTMENT IN DEPTH
UNTIL THE BRITISH STEP. FOR THE
NEXT. MOST IMPORTANT STEPS IS
WHEN YOU START REP YOU KNOW
GEARING UP TO MAKE MANY MANY
DOSES YOU'RE NOT GOING TO MAKE
AN INVESTMENT. IN A MORE
DOLLARS TO PRODUCE DOSES UNLESS
YOU KNOW WHAT WORKS SO WITH
THIS PARTICULAR RAMPS WE'RE
GOING TO ASSUME IT'S GONNA SO
WE'RE GONNA PUT VESTMENTSOME REM
JUST WORRIED THEY WERE MAKING
ALL THESE PIE IN THE SKY PUBLIC
HEALTH PERFECTION
RECOMMENDATION THAT HAVE NO
CHANCE IN HELL OF ACTUALLY
HAPPENING IN THE GLOBAL LEVEL
THEY DON'T HAVE THE MONEY. AND
WITH HUMAN NATURE SPECIAL
CHILDREN LOOK AT ADULTS ARE
MUCH BETTER FROM WHAT WE CAN
SEE AROUND THE COUNTRY THE POOR
CHILDREN WE HAVE HAVE.
MEDICATIONS I THINK THERE ARE
REALISTIC WHAT'S THE INCIDENCE
RATE OF THIS DISEASE IN
CHILDREN. WE STILL DON'T KNOW
THE INFECTION RATE IN CHILDREN
BUT WE KNEW WE ALWAYS KNOW WHEN
ONLY. LESS THAN 2% WHEN YOU SEE
A DOCTOR OUT SHE MAKES THE
CORRECT. COMMENT THAT BUT THEY
CAN INFECT OTHERS IT WOULD SEEM
TO ME A SMART USE. OF OUR
PRECIOUS DOLLARS I MEAN YOU
TRUMP SEVEN TRILLION DOLLARS WE
DON'T HAVE SEVEN TRILLION
DOLLARS DR. YOU KNOW. OVER
THREE TRILLION DOLLARS WHICH IS
TWICE WHAT WE SPEND IN A YEAR
WE DID THAT ONE BODY MONTHS.
FOR GOOD REASON AND HOPEFULLY
ON YOU GUYS ARE SHOWN AS GOOD
RESULTS AND I APPRECIATE THAT.
BUT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
CITIZENS UP AREN'T WITHHOLDING
JOHNNY AND SUSIE FROM GOING TO
SCHOOL. BECAUSE THEY THINK YOU
KNOW THIS OVER A MONTH AND A
HALF TO MY TO THE PRESENT ALSO
THAT'S WHAT YOUR WORD TALENT UP
THERE GETTING THAT IMPRESSION.
THAT'S WRONG AND IF YOU HAVE
KIDS GOING TO SCHOOL. ON THE
BRIDGE. THE WAY GIVE GET A
GREAT SONOMA AND WITH YOUR ICE
MOMS IN. THE KIDS GET NO
EDUCATION. AND I WOULD LIKE IS
THAT PORTER. THE END OF WHAT
YOU SAY IS WE TO USE ON. TO WE
HAVE NOW. WHICH WE DIDN'T HAVE
THE AS YOU KNOW C. NOT. GLOW
SCHOOLS YES SIR OKAY THANK YOU
AND WE DIDN'T READ. IT WE
DIDN'T THINK WAS A ONE SIZE
FITS ALL WE CLOSE SCHOOLS YOUR-
BY JURISDICTION ON THE ISSUE IN
THE SCHOOL. I DO THINK WE HAVE
TO FOCUS AS WE- IN THE FALL
NOW. LISTEN CONSEQUENCE. OF
FIRE DONALD CONCERT. OR
MORTALITY. AND HOSPITALIZATION.
AND RIGHT AND I CAN'T WE YOU
SEE THAT YOU'LL SEE THE
DIFFERENT RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
THE JURISDICTIONS WILL COME TO
RISE AND THERE'S A SAID I'M-
PRETTY CONFIDENT WE'RE GONNA BE
OPEN IN OUR SCHOOLS AND YOUR
COMMENTS WHICH DO. WE NEED TO
OPEN OUR SCHOOLS WITH THE
REALITY. OF HOW WE EXPECT THE
SCHOOLS TO ACT BASED ON THE
CONSEQUENCES OF WHAT WE THINK
THIS VIRUS IS GOING TO PAY FOR
THOSE. THOSE INDIVIDUALS IN
SCHOOL. IT DOESN'T MEAN WE
DON'T HAVE TO BE VIGILANT ABOUT
PROTECTING THE VULNERABLE IF
YOU NEED TO WORK ON THAT. IN
THOSE FAMILIES BUT NOEL NO
LONGER DOES THAT MEAN IF THE
DOWN SCHOOLS SHUT DOWN YOU KNOW
THE- THE ECONOMY IT MEANS WE
HAVE TO FOCUS ON HOW TO PREVENT
THE CONSEQUENCES. OF THIS.
THANK YOU VERY I'M SORRY FOR
THE OPEN MY- THANK YOU YOUR
BACK. I NEVER GO AN- ALARMIST
HUDSON. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU FOR ALL THIS HERE
TODAY MEDIA SUCH AS THE STEAM
WHAT IS PANEL I DON'T TO
DISAPPOINT YOU. SHOULD ALL WORK
WE'VE DONE TO WE ONLY HOPE
EPIDEMIC. THANK YOU AT ALL OF
THIS WHEN THIS IS. FOR TAKING
TIME OUT OF YOUR VERY BUSY
SCHEDULE THE WHAT'S YOUR- I
PERSONALLY GET A LOT OF CREDIT
ON A CORONAVIRUS RESPONSE TO
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP. IT
INDIVIDUAL ON THE PANEL WHO
WORKED TIRELESSLY TO GET US TO
WHERE WE ARE. THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION'S TAKING
DECISIVE ACTION EARLY AND
OFTEN. THAT THIS VIRUS TO KEEP
US SAFE. ELEVEN DAYS AFTER THE
FIRST CASE IN UNITED STATES ARE
THE TRUMP DECLARED HEALTH
EMERGENCY AND RESTRICTING
TRAVEL FROM CHINA. AND HE
FORMER NATIONAL COMPOSER RISK
OF INFECTION. HELLO WATSON TWO
MONTHS AFTER THE FIRST
CONFIRMED CASE ON THE TRUMP
DECLARED A NATIONAL EMERGENCY.
J. GOES FAR TESTING CAPACITY.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION HAS
GONE FROM A FEW THOUSAND TESTED
A MARK. CLOSE TO HALF A MILLION
TEST A DAY DO YOU ANTICIPATE
BEING ABLE ON FORTY TO FIFTY
BILLION TESTS AMONG. AT FOR
WHAT WE DO ABOUT LAST YEAR THIS
IS NOT COMMITTING OR EFFORTS
MADE ON E. WITH PRODUCT RICH
AND THEN LATER THE WALL PRIVATE
TO GROW MARKET PASSED. AS WE
ALL GRAPPLE WITH THE
CORONAVIRUS OUTBREAK ALL HAD TO
KNOWLEDGE A LITTLE KNOWN ABOUT
IT. EVEN MONTHS AFTER TORONTO
WE'RE STILL GRAPPLING QUESTIONS
SUCH AS HOW AND IF WE WILL
TAKE. OUR MUSIC CAN DEVELOP
CORPORATE ANTIBODIES AND WHAT
IF ANYTHING HAPPENED THAT. MAKE
UP SAYS ABOUT OUR LONG. IT'S
WHAT HAS CLEAR THE- ON THROUGH
ALL THIS AND- ARE NEEDED FOR
DATA. IN FULL PICTURE FROM THE
DAY IS. TO MONITOR BECAUSE
DISPARITIES. IF YOU LOOK AT
CASEY REPORTED OPERATION ON
COUNTY IN MY DISTRICT THERE
WERE SEVENTY ONE WHITE
INDIVIDUALS TWO HUNDRED AND TWO
ASKING AMERICAN INDIVIDUALS BUT.
NINE SIX HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT
ON LONG. AND HELP YOU LAST THE
DISPARITY BECAUSE NINETEEN IN
MY DISTRICT FIFTY SO PERCENT
BECAUSE NINETEEN CASE A KEEP
YOUR ROUTE KEEP YOUR VALLEY
HOUSEHOLD SALES. ERIC DESPITE
IS THIRTY FOUR POINT 9% COUNTY
POPULATION. WE HAVE AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE SO THAT WE CAN ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE CONGRESS WOULD
REQUIRE NEW REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS ON THE PAYCHECK
PROTECTION PROGRAM AND
HEALTHCARE INFORMATICS. LABS
ARE REQUIRED TO SUBMIT TO THE
CDC ON THE ACTOR'S HELP US
UNDERSTAND OUR WHERE THE VIRUS
IS SPREADING WHICH IS RACE
NESTLE AND AGE SEX GEOGRAPHIC
REGION WORLD FACTIONS. ONE
MOSTLY LABORATORIES ARE NOT ACT
INTERACT WITH PATIENT. IS
MAKING IMPORTANT SURE ALL
PROVIDE ARE FULLY ON COLLECTING
THIS DATA. TWO PAYMENTS
COMPLETE DEMOGRAPHIC
INFORMATION AT WORK WHAT
ACTIONS CAN YOU TAKE. AN ALL
INCLUSIVE POSITIONS OFFICES
**** NOTED TO COLLECT. ALL THE
DEMOGRAPHIC DATA. YES WE FEEL
VERY COMFORTABLE- BUT WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE OUR EFFORTS
TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE.
DOES KNOW THIS IT WAS GUIDANCE
THAT WAS PUT OUT IN AND AGAIN
AS YOU SAID IT IS IT IS
ESSENTIAL. ON ONE FOR ALL- THE
PPP DID AUTHORIZE THE SECRETARY
TO MAKE THIS THERE WERE NO
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISMS IN PPP.
SO WE ARE ENFORCING PRESS.
THROUGH EMERGENCY USE
AUTHORIZATION ENFORCEMENT OF
THE LABORATORY TESTS. SO I JUST
WANT TO PUT THAT JUST FOR YOUR
FOR YOUR INFORMATION. YES I AM
ABSOLUTELY COMMITTED TO
AGGRESSIVELY GETTING THIS
INFORMATION IT'S NOT ONLY
AFRICAN AMERICANS AFRICAN
AMERICAN SUFFERED HOLD WITH Z.
LATINO AMERICA ARE ALSO AT VERY
HIGH RISK AND THE HIGHEST RISK
OUR- NATIVE AMERICANS AND
ALASKA NATIVES WHO ARE SUFFER
EVEN HIGHER RATES ALL THESE ARE
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO US. YES
SIR THANK YOU. AS I NOTED
EARLIER THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION HAS GREATLY
INCREASED OUR TESTING. ONE AREA
THAT HAS HAD IT CERTAINLY DOES
THIS ROLLICKING TESTING
SOMETHING THAT COULD HELP US
TREMENDOUSLY IF WE REOPEN THE
KIND OF PEOPLE MOVE BACK TO
WORK COMMISSIONER ON IN RECENT
MONTHS WE SEE A LARGE NUMBER OF
SEROLOGY TESTING ON THE MARKET.
SO DECISIVELY NOT ACTORS OTHERS
YEAH HAS TAKEN ACTION TO REMOVE
SEVERAL OF THESE HOUSE FDA
INSURING ON ALCOHOL IS WRONG US
AVAILABLE US MORE. CONGRESSMAN
THANKS FOR THE QUESTION AS I
YOU KNOW. WHEN WE OUR RIDGE
SUCH. WRECK FOR. RUNS TESTING.
IT WAS NOT KNOWN COMPLETELY HOW
THE TEST WOULD BE USED AND WHAT
THE OPERATING CHARACTERISTICS
OF THEN WHAT ARE. OUR GUIDANCE
ALLOW THESE TO BE USED IN A
REAL WORLD SETTING AT THAT TIME
WE REQUIRED THE MANUFACTURERS
TO CERTIFY THAT THE TESTS HAVE
BEEN VALIDATED. WE FOUND THAT
IN SOME CASES THAT
CERTIFICATION WAS NOT CORRECT.
SO WE DEVELOPED A PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE NATIONAL TWO TWO NCAA.
DO YOU DO US GOVERNMENT IN AN
INVALIDATION AND AS YOU
PROBABLY KNOW SIR- OVER TWENTY
OF THOSE TESTS HAVE BEEN TAKEN
OFF THE MARKET. WE HAVE SOME
TWENTY REQUIRE THAT ALL
MANUFACTURED HI THIS WITHOUT
MANUFACTURING DATA AND IF THEY
DON'T THEY HAVE TO BE REMOVED
FROM THE MARKET WE CONTINUE TO
LOOK INTO THAT I'LL CONTINUE TO
FALL APART. FIRED SONG WAY UP.
I NEED WE GO TO MR KENNEDY AND-
ON MUTE. JERRY THERE. IF YOU'RE
ON MUTE. IF ON THE. SURE YOU
HAVE TO ON MUTE. I THINK IS
THERE OF A- IF YOU'RE STILL.
JOE. EIGHT HUNDRED AND. MR
KENNEDY YOU'RE SPEAKING BUT WE
CAN HEAR YOU. HIS ARE YOU THERE.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA GO ON
WE'LL COME BACK TO MR KENNEDY
NEXT IS- MISTER CAR ON THIS.
THE CARD IS ON MUTE. MAYBE IT
IS A TECHNICAL PROBLEM OF ANNA.
THERE YOU GO CAN YOU HEAR ME
NOW YES. YOU DON'T RECOGNIZE AT
MINUTES. THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU TRUMP ALONE AND
RANKING MEMBER WALDEN FOR
HOLDING THIS IMPORTANT HEARING
AND THANK YOU TO THE EXPERT
WITNESSES THAT WE HAVE BEFORE
US AND THAT WE ALL APPRECIATE
ALL THE WORK WE WERE ABLE TO DO
WHEN YOU'RE NOT. DOING FEBRUARY
THERE'S STEADY. RECORDS AND-
FOR DISEASE CONTROL AND
PREVENTION OTHERWISE KNOWN AS
THE CDC. INSIDE LINE. IT'S
EXPERTS. HAVE BEEN OVERRULED
AND- IN THE MIDST OF A
PANDEMIC- THIS IS UNACCEPTABLE.
DR REDFIELD EARLIER THIS MONTH
YOU EXPRESS CONCERN THAT THE
CDC'S PUBLIC HEALTH MESSAGES ON
COVID NINETEEN. WHAT'S
RESONATING WITH THE PUBLIC. DR
REDFIELD. WHY HASN'T THE CDC
HELP REGULAR MEDIA BRIEFINGS.
DURING THE PANDEMIC. THE CDC
HAS DONE DURING PAST. CRISES
OUT WHERE CAN PROVIDE CLEAR
EVIDENCE BASED. PATIENT
DIRECTED A POP BUT I WOULDN'T
BE A CAN ASK QUESTIONS. IS IT
POSSIBLE LACK OF REGULAR.
DIRECTION CDC. HAS BEEN
CONTRIBUTES. IN ABOUT HOW TO
BEST PROTECT THEMSELVES IN THIS
HELP AND DEMOCRATS. THANK YOU
FOR MUCH MR CONGRESSMAN THE CDC
HAS COMMUNICATED IN DIFFERENT
WAYS- CLEARLY- FIRST AND
FOREMOST WE PUT ON OVER FIFTEEN
HUNDRED GUIDANCE OR- EXCUSE ME
DOCTOR DR REDFIELD THE
PRESIDENT HAS PROVEN VERY VERY
CLEARLY WHEN YOU GET A KIND OF
A PODIUM. AND YOU ACTUALLY HAVE
A PRESS CONFERENCE. YOU HAVE A
HIGHER LIKELIHOOD YOU CAN REACH
MORE PEOPLE MY SPECIFIC
QUESTION IS. AREN'T YOU HAPPY
MORE OF THOSE PRESS CONFERENCES
LIKE THE CDC HAS DONE
PREVIOUSLY AND I WAS TRYING TO
ADD THAT THROUGH OUR THINGS
WE'VE HAD ABOUT WE REACHED ONE
FIVE. SO WE HAVE THEIR CUP IS
WITH A LOCALS TERRITORIAL
TRIBAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS EVERY
WEEK. ALMOST AND EVERY DAY WE
HAVE SPECIAL CONFERENCES
REACHING OUT TO SPECIAL
INTEREST GROUPS WHETHER IT'S
BUSINESS FAITH COMMUNITIES- AND
SAID WE HAVE ALSO HAD THE-
CONFERENCES YOU KNOW AND WE
REINSTITUTED ARE. NOW BITE
WEEKLY PRESS CONFERENCE WITH
THE OPEN PRESS- AND SO I DO
THINK THAT CDC DOES CONTINUE TO
COMMUNICATE BUT MORE AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL THEN LET'S SAY AT
THE NATIONAL LEVEL THANK YOU DR
REDFIELD YOU ACTUALLY ANSWERED
MY QUESTION AND I APPRECIATE
ALL THE- WORK YOU'VE BEEN
DOING. BUT ASKED CDC HAS. BASED
ON PREVIOUS. ISSUES WE'VE HAD
HEALTH CRISES AND I HOPE THAT
YOU'RE ABLE TO CHANGE THAT AND
DO CONTINUE DOING YOUR LOCAL
BUT ACTUALLY BE MORE PRESSING
NATIONAL. THE BIGGEST ON THE
NATIONAL STAGE HAS BEEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND IT'S
THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT HE'S
MISLED THE PUBLIC CERTAINLY
WITH HIS AXE IS WORDS. ON
WEARING ASKING REFUSES. AND
KIND OF PUBLIC BODIES NOT DO
THAT IN FEDERAL AND FEBRUARY DR
MR YAHOO THE CD ONE US THAT
THAT VIRUS COULD POSSIBLY CAUSE
SEVERE DISRUPTION TO OUR
EVERYDAY LIFE. SHE WAS RIGHT
YES SHE WAS CONTRADICTED BY
BOTH THE PRESIDENT AND
SECRETARY ISAR AND APRIL DR
REDFIELD. FIRM SECOND WHERE THE
VIRUS IN THE FALL. BE DIFFICULT
AND PRESIDENT TRUMP IMMEDIATELY
CONTRADICTED U. S. TIME OUT.
SAID YOU MAY EVEN HAVE GROWN UP
COMING BACK AND COOK. RIGHT DO
YOU BELIEVE PUBLIC HAPPENED PRE.
AND STATE AND LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICIALS BETTER
SUPPORTED THE BASES AND
DEMOCRAT CDC ANOTHER PUBLIC
HEALTH EXPERTS NOT BEEN IGNORED
OR CONTRADICTING AT THE
NATIONAL LEVEL RIGHT THE
PRESIDENT COUNTRY DO YOU IN
REAL. WELL I THINK ON BEEN
OBVIOUSLY WE CONTINUE TO TRY TO
GET OUR MESSAGE OUT I THOUGHT
DOCTOR MISSING J. OBVIOUSLY DID
A- A SERVICE IN IN IN IN. IN
HER PERSPECTIVES AT THAT TIME I
MEAN IN IN PEOPLE UNDERSTAND
WHAT. COULD BE ON THE HORIZON
WHICH OBVIOUSLY EVENTUALLY WAS
ON THE HORIZON I'VE TRIED TO DO
THIS IS. TO MAKE IT ERIC. THIS
THIS. AND WINTER IS GOING TO BE.
AND WE NEED TO BE PREPARED FOR
THAT. THANK YOU DR REDFIELD AT
THE END THANK YOU FOR
COMPLIMENTING. THEM OUT DR
MESSING EIGHT WORK FOR HER
BRAVERY ON HER WILLINGNESS TO
SPEAK UP AT THE MOMENT. IS
NECESSARY. I GENTLEMEN THAT WE
HAVE A PROBLEM RIGHT NOW THAT
OVER A HUNDRED TWENTY LIVES
LOST IN THE UNITED STATES ON
THE COVID NINETEEN AND YET THE
PUBLIC IS STILL NOT ON THE SAME
PAGE AS THEY SHOULD BE WHEN IT
TO HOW TO PROTECT THOUSAND MISS.
AND SO WHAT I HOPE AND PRAY IS
THAT THE CDC MAKE ITS PRESENCE
MORE AWARE AND MORE CLEAR WITH
EVIDENCE BASED ADVICE TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND THEN ALSO I
GOT A WHOLE BIT I NOT QUITE. AS
TO THE LEADING SUCH AS TOUTING
THE FACT THAT PPP P. P. EASE
HAVE BEEN PROVIDED TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE TO THE TUNE OF.
THERE WHEN IN FACT. HE RECORDED
THAT IDEALLY WE SHOULD BE IN
THE BILLIONS OF PEOPLE AND I'M
GONNA ASK THOSE SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS SO THAT THE POPE
PUBLIC IN HERE THE ANSWERS AND
WE CAN HAVE IT ON THE RECORD OF
THIS MIKE EXPIRED AT. THANK YOU
NEXT WEEK TWO MR WALBERG
COMMISSION THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND THANK THE PANEL
FOR A- STICKING WITH THIS
LENGTHY PERIOD OF TIME AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK WHETHER
WE AGREE OR DISAGREE. WHAT KIND
OF LEARNING TOGETHER CURRENTLY.
BUILDING ON THE FLY TO SOME
DEGREE AS WE'VE DISCUSSED
ALREADY AND AS YOU KNOW THERE
WERE A HANDFUL FIVE STATE'S
EXACT. INCLUDING FROM MICHIGAN-
WHERE MY GOVERNOR. ORDERED
REQUIRED THROUGH AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER NURSING HOMES TO MID
COVID NINETEEN POSITIVE
PATIENTS BACK IN THEIR
FACILITIES. THIS PROVED TO BE A
TERRIBLE POLICY AS WE FOUND OUT
WITH SAID THE CONSEQUENCES FOR
SENIORS WITH ALMOST TWO
THOUSAND NURSING HOME RESIDENTS
AND MICHIGAN HAVING DIED THAT'S
ACCOUNTING FOR ONE THIRD OF OUR
STATE'S COVID. NINETEEN DEATHS.
DR REDFIELD- SOME OFFICIALS IN
THE FIVE STATES THAT ISSUE
THESE EXECUTIVE ORDERS HAVE
INDICATED THEY WERE FOLLOWING
GUIDANCE FROM ADMINISTRATION'S
WHAT GUIDANCE AND USE THAT TERM
EXPRESSED LEE EARLIER ON I
APPRECIATE IT. BECAUSE I THINK
THAT'S WHAT WE DO GIVE THE
FEDERAL WHEN WE TALK THIS IS
WHAT GOD INSTEAD HHS AND CDC. A
REAL PEACE AS IT RELATES TO
ADMITTING CALL PATIENTS IN A
NURSING HOME AND SECONDLY.
OBJECTIONS ARE STATE'S TO
FOLLOW GUIDANCE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH GRETCHEN FOR THE QUESTION
IMPORTANT QUESTION SHE SHE DID
IN FACT IN DOZENS ACTIVE
GUIDANCE FOR NURSING HOMES. THE
GUIDANCE THAT YOU'RE REFERRING
TO WAS GUIDANCE THAT WAS
GROUNDED IN. THE FACT THAT SOME
SITUATIONS WHERE THE NURSING
HOMES WERE REFUSING TO TAKE ANY
COVID PATIENTS AT THE TIME. SO
THE CDC DID ISSUE A SERIES OF
IMPORTANT PRE REQUISITES AT THE
NURSING HOME HAD TO HAVE IN
PLACE IN ORDER TO ACCEPT THESE
PATIENTS THAT THEY HEADS
EMITTED TO THE HOSPITAL BACK.
THEY CAME BACK FUNDAMENTAL OF
IT WAS THAT THEY HAD THE
APPROPRIATE FACILITIES THE
ISOLATED INDIVIDUAL THEY HAVE
THE APPROPRIATE FACTS AND
CONTROL. FAST EASY TO MAINTAIN
THAT. REALLY WAS NOT SAYING YOU
HAVE TO TAKE SOMEBODY BACK IT'S
THAT YOU HAVE TO OPEN TO TAKING
CARE COVID PATIENTS PROVIDED
THAT YOU HAVE THE CAPACITY TO
DO IT CORRECTLY. ERIC IS A KEY
THING INCORRECTLY AND SO THAT
THAT PATIENT DOZENS OF THE
INFECTION THE OTHER INDIVIDUALS
AND I THINK SOME OF THE- MOST
SPEECHES THAT WE READ IN THE
PRESS FAIL TO UNDERSTAND THAT
IT'S TO DO IT CORRECTLY IS YOU
KNOW OVER HALF OF THE NURSING
HOMES IN THIS NATION RIGHT NOW
OVER SEVEN THOUSAND NURSING
HOME THIS NATION'S HAPPY. COVID
PATIENT IN. SENATE HOW TO DO IT
CORRECTLY AND SAFELY AND SAVE
THE LIVES HERE ON STABILIZED
AGAINST ON THE DATE AS WELL
SOMEONE ASK YOU WHAT ARE THE
OBSTACLES COLLECTING. AND
REPORTING THE DATA THAT YOU ARE
NOW REQUIRING. IN MY GOVERNOR'S
FINALLY STARTED TO PUT OUT.
WHAT ARE THE OBSTACLES TO
COLLECTING AND REPORTING THIS
DATA PARTICULARLY AMONG. YEARS
LIVING IN. HOMES AND WHAT
ELSE'S CC. ALREADY TAKEN TO
IMPROVE DATA ACTION FROM THE
STATE'S CMS SAYS NOW REQUIRED
IF YOU KNOW THE NURSING HOMES
ARE. HOPING THERE. WILL TO. D.
IN CDC DID ON THE SEE. HIM AT
DOUBLE. RIGHT AS WE SEE MAY I'M
MAJORITY OVERNIGHT PERCENT
NURSING AND IT'S I THINK IT'S
NORTH OF EIGHT I THINK WE'RE
ALMOST AT. ITS EIGHTY AND
NINETY PER OR ACT ROOT THROUGH
A OUR SYSTEM ALREADY SINCE THAT
REQUEST IS REQUIRED A COUPLE
WEEKS AGO. AND WE'RE WORKING TO
GET ALL 100% OF THE NURSING
HOMES TO BE REPORTING AS
REQUIRED BY CMS. AND THE DATA.
IT ALSO WAS COMPLEMENTED
MENTIONED EARLIER ABOUT THE
ETHNIC GROUPS- AND DATA. DATA
ACTUALLY COMES IN ORIGINALLY
WITH NOW ALL TESTING YOU ALL
HAVE HELPED US IN THAT NOW ANY.
ESSENCE ON COVID STICKER AS- OF
KEY DATE POINTS INCLUDING. BE
AND RIGHT SO THAT WE CAN
MAINTAIN THAT FOR ALL BASES
ACROSS COUNTRY SENATE- NURSING
HOME OR NOT. THANK YOU WE HOPE.
IT HELPS LANKFORD THREE CORE
THAT I HAVE FOR YOU REALLY.
TODAY UNIVERSITY OF MICHIGAN
ANNOUNCED PLANS FOR FALL
SEMESTER CONSISTED OF MIXTURE
OF IN PERSON AND REMOTE
CLASSES. AS SCHOOLS PREPARE FOR
THE FALL SEMESTER. ONE FACTOR
SHOULD THEY BE CONSIDERING AND
THINKING OF HIGHER EDUCATION
HERE. WHAT DO WE KNOW ABOUT THE
TRANSMISSION OF COKE YOUNG
ADULTS THAT WOULD HELP INFORMED
DECISION TO REOPEN COLLEGES
UNIVERSITIES. AND THIRDLY
SHOULD RESULT IN A DIFFERENT
FOR A SCHOOL LIKE UNIVERSITY OF
MICHIGAN- VERSUS THE SCHOOL
LIKE HILLSDALE COLLEGE DISTRICT
WITH WITH. EIGHTEEN HUNDRED
STUDENTS. UNITY YEAH. ALL
POINTS AT. IT ONE IS A GOOD
PROBABLY ON INTO EACH OF THE
QUESTIONS YOU REALLY HAVE TO
CONSIDER WHAT THE STATE OF THE
EPIDEMIC IS IN PARTICULAR PLACE
AT NOW IF YOU HAVE VERY VERY
FEW CASES LIKE IN A SMALL
COLLEGE IN THE COUNTY I THINK
CAN BE A VERY LITTLE ON THE
OPENING WHAT SCHOOL DOING IT
DOING IT ERIC GAVE WAY. TO TRY
AND MAKE SURE BUT THAT THIS
SEPARATE ENOUGH THAT YOU HAVE
SITUATIONS WHERE FIRST OF ALL
MASKS SHOULD BE DONE AT ALL
TIMES. WITHOUT EXCEPTION. THE
PHONE BILLS YOU'VE GOT TO ALLOW
BOTH FACULTY AS WELL AS
STUDENTS WHO ARE IN THAT
CATEGORY OF UNDERLYING
CONDITIONS TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
THE CAPABILITY OF EITHER
TEACHING OR LEARNING ON LINE
YOU HAVE TO HAVE THE CAPABILITY
OF WHEN YOU GET INFECTED
STUDENT WHICH YOU INVARIABLY
WILL NO DOUBT TO BE A MOVE THAT
STUDENTS TO A SAFE COMFORTABLE
PLACE FOR THE PERIOD OF TIME
AND THEY CAN GO BACK IF YOU.
THE HAVING THIS IS A MAKE THE
WHOLE THING PORT THAT'S JUST A
FEW OF THE THINGS WE NEED TO
BUT IMPORTANTLY YOU'VE GOT A
LOOK AT WHAT THE STATUS IS AND
YOUR PARTICULAR SITUATION THE
OTHER THING IS PEOPLE WHO WORK
WITH THE STUDENT'S NAME THE
PEOPLE WHO FEED THEM PEOPLE
CLEAN THEY NEED TO BE THE
TENSION TOO BECAUSE OFTEN. WHO
WE NEED IN. AND THEN INFECT THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE IN A MUCH
LARGER GROUP. THANK YOU ARE YOU
BACK THANK YOU WE'RE GONNA GO
BACK NOW TO MISTER KENNEDY. OUR.
WE CAN HEAR YOU. INSTRUMENT
THAT YOUR POLITICIAN AND ACT
RUSSIA BEFORE AND- WITNESSES
FOR BEING HERE GERMAN THANK ON
INSURANCE AND THE WINNERS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE AND YOUR-
ADMINISTERED ALONG TO THE
AFTERNOON. I'M GONNA START THIS
IS NOT ABOUT A MONTH AGO- I HAD
BEEN. IN CHELSEA MASSACHUSETTS
COMMUNITY ON JUST OUTSIDE OF
BOSTON THAT WAS. AT THE RATE OF
INFECTION ROUGHLY SIX TIMES
HIGHER THAN THE STATE AVERAGE I
WAS DELIVERING MEALS ADDING.
NON PROFIT LOCAL NONPROFIT
THERE WAS TWO LINES LONGER THAN
I'VE EVER SEEN ANYWHERE IN THE
WORLD. ON MY WAY OUT OF THE
COMMUNITY CALLED OF THE HEADS
OF THE LOCAL COMMUNITY HEALTH
CENTER AND ASKED WHAT ELSE THEY
COULD NEED THE NEED FOR HEALTH.
THE INDIVIDUAL I SPOKE WITH DID
RECENTLY RECEIVED SOME MAPPING
SOFTWARE AND THEY WERE LOOKING
FOR COOL SPOTS. IN COMMUNITY
NINE. ASKING WHY COOL SPOTS OF
HOT SPOT POLICING NO WE KNOW
THAT EVERYBODY'S BEEN EXPOSED.
THE SCHOOLS HOUSES WHERE WE
HAVEN'T BEEN TESTED. YOU KNOW
THE BIGGEST CALLS BUT ONCE. THE
PUBLIC HOUSING FACILITY. AND
OTHER PEOPLE. I'VE BEEN TESTED
FOR. CANCEL COMPLETE REPAIR OUR
NATION FOR THIS PANDEMIC THAT
WILL CONTINUE USE LARGE MADE UP
OF PEOPLE THAT ARE GOVERNMENT
OUR SOCIETY HAS DEEMED TO BE
ESSENTIAL. THAT WE REQUIRE TO
BE ISN'T. AND THEY WERE LEFT IN
THEIR WAKE WITH NO HELP AND NO
MORE. JUST DAYS AGO. PRESIDENT
TRUMP STOOD UP FOR THE MAYOR TO
PUBLIC AND TOLD US THAT HE
ASKED HIS ADMINISTRATION TO
SLOW PROTESTS DOWN BECAUSE OF.
WHAT THEY REVEALED CONCEPT HAS
WORK CELEBRATING. TELL TO HIS
POLITICAL SURVIVAL AND NOEL.
THAT TRANSMITTED THAT TESTIMONY
THAT HIS STATEMENTS HERE WERE
NOT TRUE ALTHOUGH THE PRESENCE
IS ALSO COUNTRY BETTER GAMES
AND SHE- MY- PEOPLE. ARE PEOPLE
IN CHELSEA. MADE ME BLACK AND
BROWN MEN WOMEN CHILDREN THIS
MINISTRATIONS FAILURE TO TEST
WAS NOT DRUNK. CONDEMNING
TWENTY THOUSAND PEOPLE HAVE
DIED OVER TWO MILLION THAT ARE
SICK AND FORTY FIVE MILLION
AMERICANS ARE OUT OF. INTO THIS
CRISIS IN IN HIS BEST PLAN TO
CONFRONT THE RACIAL INEQUITY SO
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IS
COLLECTING LONG OVERDUE
DEMOGRAPHIC DATA. YES WE NEED
THAT DAY. WE KNOW THAT BLACK
AND BROWN PEOPLE ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY ARE MORE THAN TWICE AS
LIKELY TO DIE AS THOSE WERE
WHITE FROM THIS VIRUS IN MORE
THAN SIX TIMES AS LIKELY. BLACK
AND IN WASHINGTON DC IN
MASSACHUSETTS THE POTTERY
ARMONK BLACK AND RESIDENTS IS
THREE TIMES HIGHER THAN FOR
BLACK RESIDENTS. SO YES WE NEED
MORE DATA BUT ONLY BECAUSE THE
MISTREATMENT MONTHS IGNORING
THE ATTITUDE HAVE TRIED WARN US
ABOUT THE FIRST. THE ACTION. IS
TAKEN TO CAN THE SENATE GOT
RICHARD STARTED YOUNOT WITHDRAWT
WELL OVER TWO THOUSAND SITES
WE'RE JUST TRANSITIONING THOSE
THIRTEEN. AT MOVE VERY QUICKLY
BREAKING HIS MIND I DON'T HAVE
MUCH TIME HERE BUT AND- WE
HAVEN'T SEEN FOR COMPLAINING
RECKONS LOSE THEIR JOBS. AND
YET WE HAVE AN ADMINISTRATION
THAT CONTINUES TO PUSH THE NEED
FOR WORK REQUIREMENTS FOR
INDIVIDUALS ON MEDICAID. AND
YES LET'S START WITH BACK AND
DOCTOR COUNTRY DO YOU BELIEVE
THAT IMPLEMENTING WORK
REQUIREMENTS IS GOING TO.
MEASURES STOP THE SPREAD OF. WE
REALLY HAVE TO LIVE YOU TO.
STATE I DIDN'T GET TO COME IS
ABOUT WORK REQUIREMENTS. YOU
KNOW THAT FORTY FIVE MILLION
AMERICANS HAVE LOST THEIR JOBS
IMPLEMENTING WORK REQUIREMENTS
EFFECTIVELY. STOP CREDIT
CORONAVIRUS. SURE I'M QUALIFIED
TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION I I'M
I'M REALLY NOT THE JOURNAL.
ELECTIONS RESPECTFULLY. I
DIDN'T EVEN HITS OUR I'M SORRY
BUT I REALLY DIDN'T EVEN HEAR
THE QUESTION OR UNDERSTAND IT
YEAH I I'M NOT SURE WHAT IT
WOULD BE. OKAY LET ME COMPARE
FIVE IF IT'S GONNA BE ONE
MINUTE. GIVEN THAT SIXTY FIVE
MILLION PEOPLE HAVE LOST THEIR
JOB. AND THE ADMINISTRATION
STILL CONTINUES TO ORDER IN
TRYING TO IMPLEMENT WORK
REQUIREMENTS. TATIAN UPWARD
REQUIREMENTS HE WILL CALL AT
STOPPING THE SPREAD OF RIGHT
YES. RIGHT I DON'T KNOW FOR
YOUR MIKE WAS IN BUT YOU SAID
IT WOULD BE A PROBLEM. THANK
YOU FOR. ALL RIGHT. GO NOW FROM
MASSACHUSETTS TO SAVANNAH MR
CARTER. WE AND THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE WE APPRECIATE IT
DOWN THE MIDDLE SECTIONS DONE
AN EXCEPTIONAL JOB IN MY
OPINION. REACHING TESTING OVER
THE PAST SEVERAL MONTHS AND I
KNOW THAT IT IS OUR DESIRE
DONALD J. DIDN'T ASKING IF WE
DID IT WOULD LEAVE IN TEST
PERMIT BY SEPTEMBER IN ORDER TO
DO THAT WE GREATLY NEED TO
EXPAND TESTING. I SAID THAT IN
ORDER TO ROLL OUR COMMUNITIES.
WE NEED ROBUST TESTING SECONDLY
NEED PERSONAL RESPONSIBILITY
THAT IS FOLLOWING THE ADVICE OF
MEMBERS OF THE CORONAVIRUS
PASSWORDS AND MAKING SURE WE'RE
WASHING OUR HANDS WEARING MASK
IT'S THAT RICK SANTORUM. ON
ANIMAL GEORGE EARLIER YOU YOU
SAID THAT 90% OF AMERICANS LIVE
WITHIN FIVE MILES OF THE
PHARMACY ARE PROCESS AND IF I
DON'T NEED TO PROTECT YOU BUT
IT'S ACTUALLY. LET THE
PHARMACIST MAKING THEIR THE
MOST EXTENSIVE WILL HELP YOU
FOR OUT THERE IT WOULD ASK YOU
HEAD YOUR OUT TALK ABOUT THIS
MANY TIMES THANK YOU MINISTRY
SHOULD YOU LEARN THIS IS THE
FIRST OF PERSONNEL THE PERFECT
FOR EXPANDED TESTING ESPECIALLY
COMMUNITY PHARMACISTS CAN HELP
RULE AND A CLEAR UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES I KNOW. I HAVE. I
MADE IT TO WHERE THIS CAN
PROVIDE THESE BEST BUT NOT ALL
FORMS AND WHAT I GETTING A IS
IF CAN GET. TO WHERE THEY
COMMUNITY IN THE UNDER THE RULE
IN THE MEDICALLY UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES THE PHARMACIST
THERE WOULD BE ABLE TO DO IT AS
WELL L. THANK YOU CONGRESSMAN
MARK. YEAH THANK YOU
CONGRESSMAN AND YOU KNOW HOW I
FEEL ABOUT THIS I THINK FORMER
SISTER. ONE OF THE MOST UNDER
YOU DON'T IS PERFECT ON THE
COUNTRY- FOR THEIR TRAINING AND
THEIR EXPERTISE AND ALSO. THEIR
TRUST FROM THE POPULATION AND I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO PUT AN
EXCLAMATION POINT BEHIND
EVERYTHING YOU YOU HAVE SAID.
IN ORDER TO WORK WITH THE
INDEPENDENT PHARMACIST EVEN
MORE THAN THE- RETAIL
PHARMACIST AND I'M SOR I KNOW
THIS IS YOUR WORLD BUT THERE'S
A GROUP THIRTEEN OR- THAT'S-
INTERMEDIATE. WE NOT THAT WILL
WITH TO MAKE SURE THAT WE COULD
BE MORE MORE. OF THE
INDEPENDENT PHARMACIST UNDER
CONTRACT- TO OUR OF COMMUNITY
BASED TESTING PROGRAM BUT I'M
ALL ON BOARD. ON WHETHER IT'S
TELEHEALTH PHARMACIST COMMUNITY
HEALTH WORKERS. WE NEED TO GET
HEALTH INTO THE COMMUNITY AND
PHARMACISTS ARE A GREAT WAY TO
DO THAT. THANK YOU AT THAT
MOMENT AND I'VE ACTUALLY- I'VE
SUBMITTED BILL TEXT AT THAT
WOULD DO JUSTICE THAT ALL THE
PHARMACIST ON BOARD FOR. ON
BOARD WHERE THEN IT'S OVER TO
HHS RIGHT NOW I JUST LIKE ASKED
ALL THE MEMBERS HERE. A TASK
FORCE IF YOU COULD HELP ME TO
GET THAT REVIEW COMPLETED SO WE
CAN MOVE FORWARD I WOULD
APPRECIATE IT. ALSO WANTED TO
TALK ABOUT YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN
SITTING HERE LISTENING TO JUNE.
CURRENTLY ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE AISLE WHO HAVE BEEN SAYING
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION IN THIS
TASK FORCE HAS NOT DONE ENOUGH
TO SAY BLACK STAND. AND YOU
KNOW WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THE
FACT THAT WE'VE HAD 42% OF THE
COVID DEATHS HAVE BEEN FROM
POINT SIX. PERCENT OF THE
POPULATION THAT HAS BEEN
NURSING HOME RESIDENTS NOW I DO
NOT IN ANY WAY I CONSIDER
MYSELF TO BE TO HAVE MORE
EXPERTISE ON COMMUNICABLE
DISEASES THAN ANY OF THE
FORWARD YOU YOUR SENIOR DAY.
HOWEVER I WILL TELL YOU THAT
YOU'RE NOT PROFESSIONAL CAREERS
THE PHARMACIST I WAS CONSULTED
PHARMACISTS AND I WORKED IN
NURSING HOMES I SPENT ALMOST
THIRTY YEARS IN NURSING HOMES
SO I DO KNOW NURSING HOMES AND
I KNOW THAT'S THE LAST PLACE.
THAT YOU WON'T. ALSO THE
PATIENT TO BE A- AND I JUST
WANT TO. OUT THAT IN I CAN
REMEMBER SERVICE A HUNDRED BED
FACILITY YEARS AGO. THAT FOR
WHATEVER REASON DID NOT GET THE
FLU VACCINE AND WE LOST ALMOST
20% OF OUR POPULATION IN THAT
NURSING HOME AS A RESULT OF THE
FLU OUTBREAK. BECAUSE WE DIDN'T
GET THE VACCINE THAT YEAR SO I
HAVE SEEN THIS FIRST HAND I'VE
EXPERIENCED IT. AND THAT'S WHAT
UPSETS ME SO MUCH ABOUT THE
STATE OF SO MANY GOVERNORS TO
PUT. THESE PATIENTS IN THE
NURSING HOME WHICH WOULD HAVE
BEEN THE WORST PLACE THEY COULD
HAVE PUT A MAN. NOT SAY ALL
THAT TO SAY THAT YOU KNOW I
STILL BELIEVE IN HUMANITY. AND
I DON'T THINK EVEN THOSE
GOVERNOR MADE THAT DECISION
DIDN'T CHANGE NOT THINK THAT
WHAT DETERMINE IF. DON'T PUT IT
WOULD RESULT IN. AT THAT POINT
I DON'T ALL OF US IN. THIS
COMMITTEE TO EVERYONE IN
CONGRESS. I THINK IT MATTERS
GRETCHEN IS. ANNOUNCED JOB IN A
BANK STATEMENT. EVERYTHING
RIGHT. NO NO. IT WOULD TAKE
THINGS DIFFERENTLY THEY COULD
YES AN APPLE THAT THES